Sal the
black do the
honors
I stands one nation under God
indivisible with liy and justice for
all amen
sh actually Vice chair of the house
criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
with the potential for executive
sessions to be held through all please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen and
temporary contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order I am confirming that all
members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general cour
website the notice of this
meeting notice complies with house rules
in irsa
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
3600 or email
HCS
l. state. n.
Us in the event of public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are meeting that are on the
meeting assisting us Brad Greenland
committee
research please note that all votes that
are taken during this meeting shall be
done by roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance when each member
states their presence please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during those meeting which is
required under the right of no
La
call chairman Welch here representative
money here representative Hopper here
representative green here representative
Wallace representative testerman here
representative true present
representative Pratt pres representative
Aron present the clerk is present
representative Harriet GA
present representative
panus present representative oarn
present alone representative
Bon present and alone representative Ms
here and alone in my office
representative
Newman president and alone
Balden uh president at home with my
family representative
Conley representative kle
Knight president and home with my family
representative Bradley president and
with my
daughter chairman
abis Mr Vice chairman we have um
chairman abis and
representative Wallace I believe
are chairman meeting so they be here
just first bill
today Bill
147n we uh
open the public hearing on
147n please remember that
the testimony will be limited to two
minutes sponsor introduc in
the representative abis is not here
representative love
available he is on
represent do you do you see
representative
love yes I've uh brought him up to
panelist status and have asked him to
unmute
thank
love
hello hello this is representative love
can you hear me
go okay uh here we go um I come before
you to introduce House Bill 147 as
amended uh house B Bill 147 would first
and would add first and second degree
assault charges for an assault on an
elderly person at the statute and th and
thus uh enhanced penalties compared to
simple assault many of our elderly
suffer lifelong uh disabilities and pain
from uh from assaults uh throughout the
country and uh several states have have
current currently similar laws on their
books Massachusetts Connecticut Florida
Texas Illinois California to name a few
uh some have mandatory oneyear State
Prison sentences some up to three and
and Texas takes the cake with five a
fiveyear prison sentence for assault on
on an elderly person New Hampshire has a
fair but firm reputation in its criminal
sentencing thus a serious deterrent to
to crime and um this this bill would
Define the crime of assault on an
elderly person in in in in punishment
for the heinous crime that it is I thank
you for taking taking my testimony and
uh I take any
questions
questions thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question right now as as the law is
written uh what is the penalty for
causing serious bodily injury to an
another right now our uh our our laws
are mostly defined as a simple assault
and uh you know people are walking away
with with fines and uh you know six six
months to year probation um you know
this will this law put some teeth in
this bill would put some teeth in the
law and um and put some teeth in the
punishment
also thank you
other
questions Mr
chair thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative love I'm now for the
first time looking at the amendment and
I not sure I
understand you have line you have
section e and G is it not the
same I don't have the bill in front of
me myself uh I I just got a copy of it
last night uh on you know on my uh on my
phone and uh my my computer's broken so
I'm using my phone I can't do both at
the same time but um uh the
uh I'm not sure I understand your
question
either the question
yes could you read it to me and uh well
I I've looked at it some more and the
only thing that I see that's different
is they threw in the word causes
unprivileged
physical and yes um that that would be
you know a a shove um you know up to a
you know an outright punch in the head
or whatever um you know um you know
unprivileged a hug is not unprivileged
but um
you know uh you know when somebody is
hurt uh and and elderly like I said they
uh they uh they suffer the suffer the
pain in disability a lot a lot longer
than a 20 or 30 year
old a follow up Mr chairman a follow up
yeah thank you so with that being said
and I not arguing with you I'm just
saying that the section e just States
purpos unknowingly causes bodily injury
doesn't that cover it I mean you need an
unprivileged in there
um I'm not sure I think I think he'll
have to uh talk to the sponsor about
that when he gets back um you know the
uh the prime sponsor is uh your your
chair and uh you know I'm sure he could
uh give you the reason for
it thank
you night have a question yes thank you
chair um thanks for taking my question
question you I might have to wait for
representative abis but I was hoping you
could give me a rough
idea um how many times this happens in
our like in our state I just want to
know um not you don't have to give me an
exact number but I want to know how many
times an elder suffers abuse roughly and
isn't able to do anything about it do
you have any rough figures I don't have
any figures but I did talk to uh my
police chief last year when I introduced
this and uh he said uh it it the crime
is often reported but uh very often
unprosecuted because uh the the the
elderly people are afraid of of
Retribution and um you know and and
right now our statutes uh don't have
much uh much teeth as far as the uh the
punishment goes and uh so it it like I
said it goes It goes unreported or
unprosecuted be because they refuse they
refuse to test
thank
you are there any other questions from
the
committee Mr and thank you
representative uh my question is isn't
this more about physical uh disparity
between the two parties like uh for
instance if I said that a representative
Road's mom wore army boots and she
punched me in the
nose she's next
year she would be guilty of this crime
because I'm T over 65 and she's you know
well younger than 10 years younger than
me so it it seems
like if we pass this people that aren't
that this shouldn't why to could also be
prosecuted well there's the 10year
difference in there and um you know the
the the fact of the matter is uh verbal
uh verbal josting uh should never be be
met with physical Force especially on
the elderly it shouldn't be met with
physical Force at all in society but uh
it especially on the
elderly thank you
any further questions from
the I see
that excuse me Mr chairman I see some
people online don't have their their
microphones needed and I'm wondering if
maybe that's part of the feedback we're
getting you could just ask
everybody yeah please put their
computers if everyone would uh unmute
with the exception
of cathine Cooper Katherine Cooper would
you I have a follow-up chair
sorry oh all right excuse me representa
kn has a followup question thank you
just one last question do you know um if
elder abuse is on the rise in New
Hampshire
represa
hello can you hear me yeah my I I keep
buffering here but uh anyway um I don't
know uh like I said my police chief said
that it's a a crime that uh you know
often goes unreported but more often un
unprosecuted because they're afraid to
to uh to to for any rep for any rep
retribution and uh thus we don't have
any statistics on it but uh he it is one
of the most unreported crimes there is
thank you so
much as
Koopa cine Cooper are you
there yes she she has just been promoted
to a panelist uh yes can you hear me now
I can yes you have two minutes um I'm
I'm calling in today on behalf of the
New Hampshire Association of criminal
defense lawyers to oppose this bill um I
would like to unless there's an
amendment that um is there that I'm
unaware of I would just like to point
out that this bill applies only to first
deegree assault
um not to simple assault and
first-degree assault is punishable by
seven and a half to 15 years in the
state
prison um this is not a crime that is
taken lightly um this is not a crime
where people are walking away with
probation and fines if you're convicted
of first-degree salt you usually go to
prison um or if there's some other sort
of strange circumstance you're going to
be on a long time of
supervision um uh I just wanted to state
that to clarify um but also we oppose
this overall because it's really
unnecessary um the new section e in this
bill is essentially arbitrary and
somewhat
meaningless um it's really no worse to
commit a crime against someone if you're
11 years younger than them than it is if
you're nine years younger than them um
and this age qualification creates an
arbitrary factor that sort of parses out
and creates classifications of victims
for really no good reason um if you're
assaulted and someone purposely causes
serious bodily injury to you it is
terrible no matter how old you are or
how old the person is who did it um I
also think this bill is rather agist and
promotes some discriminatory stereotypes
based on age I think there's many older
people who work very hard to discourage
being treated like they're weaker or
less powerful than those who are younger
um in the medical field there's a lot of
work being done in that Community to get
rid of the kind of agism that this sort
of Bill promotes um and I think the
legal system should follow suit with
that and finally um the biggest reason
is that this bill is
unnecessary victims who are purposely
assaulted are already covered by section
A and um the knowingly mental state here
is simply bootstrapping and increased
exposure um that would normally follow
under second degree second degree
assault again a very serious charge um I
did actually do a little bit of research
that um addresses one of the questions
um I I I'm sorry I can't remember who
asked it but there was a request for
statistics and um the United States
Department of Justice Office for victims
of crimes um has an information sheet on
this and they talk about the fact that
um older adults are actually less likely
to experience violent victimization than
the general population over the age of
12 so this bill actually segments out
and gives extra punishment on behalf of
victims who are actually less frequently
victimized than the rest of the
population and another interesting um
and relevant stat I found at the office
for victims of crimes is that more than
half of violent crime victimizations
against people over age 65 involve um
perpetrators who did not know the victim
so that makes it highly unlikely that
you know more than 50% of the people
involved in offenses like this would
even know how old the victim was um thus
defeating any kind of a um attempt at
the bill to discourage crime against the
elderly there just wouldn't be any
impact in that way so your your two
minutes is long
up I'm finished thank you very much
any questions of Miss
coopa I don't see any thank you very
much for your
testimony oh
represent thank you Mr chair and and
thank you for the witness
testifying um I think you said a couple
of things where this law is
unnecessary that the charge is probably
um too grave as first degree assault and
I'm just wondering if you have any and I
think yeah you said it was
unnecessary um uh could you just um
maybe further elaborate on how this bill
could be made uh to be more useful and U
more
appropriate um thank you for your
question representative Newman um I I'm
saying it's unnecessary because if you
look at the first-degree assault statute
um the elements of the crime is that a
person purposely causes serious bodily
injury to another that's in um in
paragraph a that is exactly the same
language that's being said out here
purposely causing serious bodily injury
so my my point is simply that e is
already covered by a so it's
unnecessary um and then the knowingly
mental state already appears in the
second degree assault statute so a
knowing mental state means that you know
you're doing something but you're not
necessarily purposely causing the harm
so it's a lesser mental state it means
that you you know you're doing something
bad but you're not necessarily doing it
on purpose to harm the person and you
know we set out the first degree versus
second degree because those mental
States mean that you're doing something
that's significantly worse um and this
conduct is already covered
in our current statutes so that's why it
is
unnecessary thank you U Mr chair um when
I first read this bill my opinion was
that perhaps this was being offered as a
uh solution for situations where someone
has a guardian they're elderly they have
a guardian or someone who is in constant
control with them and is being abused by
them um do you uh think that this bill
could be amended to cover that situation
if it's not covered in in current
law um well I think that situation
um would already be covered by this
current law if someone is purposely
harming someone they they have cared for
and causing them serious bottle injury
they can be proed prosecuted under the
statute currently and nothing in this
amendment um makes it you know has any
kind of an element where the person is a
caretaker so this applies to the entire
population thank you very much thank
you further questions of this
S I don't see
any thank you very much for your
testimony yeah thank
you I have no one else on my list
and I see no additional speakers either
Mr
chair I guess we will end the public
hearing
on
147 support
position uh yes uh on House Bill 147 uh
the number of people signing in in
support of the bill was eight and we
also had eight people signing in in
opposition thank
you we have some time before the next
hearing next hearing is at 9:45 so I
guess folks in the committee room
will take a rest and the folks at home
can have a cup of coffee we'll
reconvene 9:45
[Music]
still on still live though right I know
we
are the committee room is not
muted Mr chair I will mute the community
the uh uh the committee
room thank you
David you're not
muted thank
you
e
e e
Mr chair do we have to do something
special
so have an
echo the room needs to be unmuted and
everybody else the speakers need to be
um muted as well if someone can go over
to the computer and unmute the room that
would give R
vcho how's
that that
better can everyone hear me yes that
worked all right
we will begin the uh public hearing on
House Bill 493 FN and again we have the
bill
introduced
the witnesses coming after will be
limited to two
minutes at the hearing of House Bill 493
FN an act establishing a criminal
penalty for assault committed against a
person who is conveying public health or
safety guidance or requirements during a
declared state of
emergency we have a
[Music]
sponsor good morning Mr
chair and
committee is that that's a go right okay
can you hear me okay yes good all right
so uh the intent behind this bill has
changed since I first uh introduced it
uh when I first introduced it I was
inspired by a law passed by Illinois
that was more about anyone
violating uh mask ordinances at the
state or local level I have since
um I have since decided and this is how
the bill is written that really what I
think is most needed given uh
really there aren't many mask mandates
in New Hampshire and I that is not a
battle I want to fight uh the whether or
not we should have um mask mandates Etc
it is simply a bill to Target um the
sort of viral video type incidences you
may have seen the take place where
someone works and the person who is on
the receiving end of say someone's
belligerence is simply enforcing their
workplace uh policy for anyone entering
that
workplace uh that may or may not have a
mask on or may or may not be doing the
six feet distancing thing and if that
person is belligerent about their
enforcement so I took what was the big
battle and reduced it to Simply hey the
employee could be someone who would
prefer not to wear a mask uh have views
differing than mine on covid but to
protect that Frontline person in their
place of employment from uh any backlash
to just they're doing their job uh this
could be a place of business this could
be the DMV but any place where there is
a workplace policy that an employee must
do their job to
enforce and someone coming into that
place of employment as a
customer um or as a member of the public
and not working for that place would
simply be uh protected by that through
this law that um you know some folks
might have forgotten a mask that's fine
they're not in trouble you know some
folks may not have been aware of the
policy at this work workplace that's
fine you know this is simply to protect
an employee at a place of employment
from
belligerent uh
flagrantly um flouting that workplace
policy for any members of the public
entering that space and not abiding by
what that workplace uh policy is um it
could be the six feet different
you know distance it could be you know
the mask and the six feet whatever that
workspace policy is simply a protection
for that employee who is just doing
their job and if someone entering that
workplace from a member of the public uh
is not happy with that and does
something that uh puts that person's
health at risk and by violating that
workplace policy has maybe put that
employee um in a conflict they really
didn't want to be in to be honest with
you so I took what what could have been
one of those political battles that uh
have become partisan that's actually not
what I want this bill to be now at all
it is simply a a um
clarification and clearly outlining what
an employee at at their workplace might
be in a position to uh enforce with the
members of the public that's all this is
and that's after lots of conversations
with folks in the retail sector and
business owners um conversation with law
enforcement about what's already on the
law you know a certain level of this was
uh you know could be interpreted to be
under the existing assault laws but this
was specifically worded the way it is
because of the um because of Any uh
broad public health concerns from a
pandemic and only to protect someone
simply doing what they are supposed to
do in their job description and if
someone coming into that space doesn't
like it but then does the extra step of
becoming belligerent or difficult and um
blaming that person who's just doing
their job that's really all this bill is
um and I think it's a good bill and I
think it helps
clarify um for retailers in particular
but also uh nonprofits even in places
you know where the government where like
the DMV or local governments may have
these policies Municipal governments may
have these policies and simply
to um give a little bit of teeth to the
law in favor of that employee regardless
of their views on masks or social
distancing or even covid they're simply
doing their job that's the intent of
this bill I think it helps clarify a
part of the law around um any Public
Health crisis that simply um helps
protect that
employee from whatever opinion or view
belligerently reacting to to someone
just on the front lines doing their job
and that's the bill couldn't make it
more complicated if I
tried thank
you have a couple of questions
representa haa thank you Mr chair thank
you representative for taking my
question so somebody under this if this
passes somebody is
guilty of this crime if they don't
follow the recommendations of an
employee at a a place of
business if it's a healthc care
recommendation during a state of
emergency so I go I fall off my
motorcycle this spring I'm in the
ER and one of the workers there suggests
that I get a vaccine under this if this
passes if I do not comply and get a
vaccine would I also be guilty of
violating this ordinance
or I hope not because that wouldn't
actually be something that would infect
that employee if that I I believe the
way it's worded and I did talk with the
bill drafters about this to make sure
that uh this wouldn't be something that
would cause a difficulty at a health
care setting let me double check the
wording I would be definitely open to an
amendment if you don't think the way
that it's worded covers that
but to be honest with you that is
absolutely not the the uh intent or
purpose of this bill at all if uh you
know anything to put any sort of
criminal penalties to vaccination or not
is not my intent this would simply be
for Frontline employees to be protected
when they enforce just the policies for
entering the work or entering their
workspace um I I guess you could make
the case that if that workpace required
people entering uh to have vaccination
maybe but that is definitely not the
intent of this at all I don't think
anything regarding CDC
requirements uh that are currently being
addressed by employer policies have
anything to do with vaccinations so far
as I know I've only heard the basics of
this keep a six foot of distance uh
limit the number of people in a in an
area and wear a mask uh I would hope
that this is not um used to um enforce
some policy about vaccination that is
definitely not the battle I want to have
here but I'm pretty sure it's worded in
a way that it wouldn't include that but
I am open to amending this if you want
to be extra clear but I'm going to read
the I'm gonna look at the text again I'm
pretty sure that this just looks at an
employer policy I would hope Shaws
doesn't have a
policy you know no this would just be
about uh directions for it's here I'm
reading the bill in in section
onea um you know relaying directions for
Health Care safety from his or her
supervisor employer so this is
specifically about addressing what the
public does and I believe it is worded
in a way to not include healthc care
providers advice this is simply uh
employment duties at a workplace where
people are entering their workplace not
for health care but to um you know renew
their driver's license or buy
groceries I'm pretty sure it's worded in
a way not to affect uh suggestions from
a health care
provider
tesman thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
uh let me give you a scenario and see if
you're
guilty they walk into a local
supermarket and just keep walking they
don't make any comment they have no mask
on uh and somebody some employee comes
up to
him you need to put a mask on and gets R
religion about it
but the the person who's who's walking
in just keeps on walking does not uh say
anything to them or do anything would
they be guilty in this
case um I love good hypotheticals and
that's a great question representative
testerman good to see you this morning
um I don't think so if the employee has
conveyed the required policy that that
person's required to convey and they're
not continuing to follow that employee
uh and then I mean customer I don't
believe if that person isn't being um
compliant in and of themselves by
continuing to walk that doesn't that
wouldn't be necessarily what this bill
covers this is simply if someone is
[Music]
um uh flouting
that basically taking an extra step of
aggression towards the employee if a
person's just continuing to walk away I
I don't know I don't think that's at all
the intent of this
bill question one last question but one
a at the end says refuses to comply with
another who the actor knows to be and
I'm assuming that this person walking in
would know that that's an employee so
they would know they would be and they
are refusing to comply when I by just
not doing it so doesn't this then make
them guilty of the
assault I don't think so I don't think
anyone objectively would consider
walking in a certain
direction after hearing the policy from
the employee at their place of business
I don't think that anyone would consider
that an assault in and of itself I think
there are things that the governor has
suggested with retailers that maybe do
or don't have teeth to them about making
a call Toc law enforcement for that I
think these things are are that kind of
thing is uh between the governor and law
enforcement and retailers this wouldn't
um I think make this would not add any
new penalty to the law for someone who's
not wearing a mask and simply walking
into a place of business away from that
employee um no this would this would I
would not consider walking away a
belligerence
I think
objectively that would be an agreed upon
thing a belligerence would
be um getting in someone's face you know
closer than six feet without a mask or
starting a verbal argument that
escalates to someone ripping a mask off
or you know that sort of a thing but
walking away I think universally is seen
as uh not a sign of
aggression joh RH
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so uh representative
testerman uh his followup was along the
lines of what my question was going to
be but there seems to be um for a lack
of better word
whw yeah I mean it clearly says on here
second degree assault and it and it
clearly
says or refuses to comply it doesn't
say
um it it doesn't say well it shouldn't
matter or that's not what I mean it it
clearly is written or refuses to comply
so one how would this even go about
being enforced I I guess that'll be my
first question then I'll wait for a
followup okay I hear you on the first
part um on the second part it would be
enforced the same way any assault would
be
enforced um you know the person who has
been assaulted usually has to contact
law enforcement uh or the employer in
this case also probably would be the
person calling law enforcement and then
the process involving law enforcement
would continue per uh usual as usual as
an assault would be anyways um good
question uh you know I suppose an
employer could uh you know call law
enforcement for help enforcing this
policy uh anyway honestly given how the
governor has spoken about his own
executive orders but that is absolutely
not the debate I'm trying to tiptoe into
here I'm simply talking about um a
direct belligerent act to an employee in
a workspace enforcing a policy um you
know if an employer wants to call the
cops because someone is walking through
their place of employment without a mask
they can already do that
I this law wouldn't change that fact um
the teeth behind the uh misdemeanor in
this case is specifically about a
belligerent uh aggressive act
towards uh the employee enforcing this
you know I think what you're suggesting
and what representative testerman was
suggesting is something that you know an
employer could already call the police
about given at least how I've heard the
governor speak about these things and
that's definitely not a battle I care to
enter with this bill so if you think
that this gives teeth to that we could
def I would be very open to an amendment
to clarify the wording around this
regarding the um the way that the
penalty and the act of aggression is
worded but I will say if it helps resure
anyone I did vet this wording with law
enforcement and with a former prosecutor
to try to make sure that this bill just
gets to um you know a poor employee
who's just doing what their employer
asks
around uh Public Health crisis and and
that interaction between someone with
the public that is aggressive and
flouting a public health
recommendation that's it but um I feel
like I'm talking too much
I feel like what you're suggesting is
something that can already happen and
someone could already call law
enforcement is really the bottom line on
that and this bill absolutely shouldn't
be worded in a way to add any new teeth
to that based on my consultation with a
former prosecutor and and some members
of the law of law
enforcement followup question thank you
so to follow up with that I to to be
clear I don't believe that
representative testman or myself are
suggesting anything I we are simp
exactly exactly what it says here so and
you had talked about hypothetical so
this isn't actually hypothetical this
isn't
actual I have a handicap sticker and a
handicap card for my vehicles and that
surprises a lot of people but the reason
I have that isn't necessarily anybody's
business right there are more than more
times than I that I should even have to
count if I take it upon myself to use
that opportunity to park in one of those
spaces people come up to me and they
question me and they challenge whether
or not I should be part there and they
look to see if I should be part there so
I'm putting a in a position to have to
explain
myself making it even more uncomfortable
than I already am about the situation so
with that being said you know there are
plenty of plenty of situations where
people are not able to wear masks there
are some that choose not to and there
are some that clearly are not able to so
now you're going to put a person it has
to now explain again why they're not
able to wear this mask according to
your piece of legislation they would be
belligerent and now they would I mean
how is that going to be if the person's
Mental Health on top of everything
else first of all I just want to say I'm
sorry you have to go through that with
your handicap c um thing I I have
encountered that with members of my
family and you shouldn't have to go
through that second of all um so that's
just as a human being I wanted to say
that um second of all uh you know I
guess it depends on the interaction like
any assault
situation um there is an element of
assault that is that might feel
subjective uh to
someone um but what you're describing in
no way shape or form uh is would sound
belligerent to me if someone is saying
my health care provider says I can't
wear a mask and they continue to move
through the the place of business I
can't see that being interpreted as an
assault I you know and I'm not a member
of law enforcement but I like I said I
did vet this language going through
multiple potential
scenarios and I would hope that is not
how this bill is used I can't imagine it
would be um but if you think we need to
further clarify the language I'm open to
that representative
news thank you for taking my question
um listening to some of the other
questions uh this this morning for you
one of the things that strikes me is
that uh um that a lot of the situations
that we're talking about are covered
under our current assault and
trespassing laws um I notice in our
trespassing statute uh that that is uh
an unclassified misdemeanor so it it's
not classified as a or b i noticed that
you're asking for uh uh for the
particular offense that's outlined in
your bill to be a Class B misdemeanor my
my question for you is
are we better off if we were to go down
the road of having a statute like this
um of acknowledging uh the other
statutes uh and simply requiring that
during a or or simply saying that during
a public health
emergency uh these types of offenses so
uh trespassing offenses uh and assault
on a person in this situation under a
public health emergency should be
elevated to a class A misdemeanor
would would that address your concern uh
uh
better um I don't know that I definitely
spoke with the levels of misdemeanors
with law enforcement members and with
the former prosecutor and knowing how uh
stringent a Class A misdemeanor is in
New
Hampshire
um I
specifically did not want um it to be be
elevated to that I I am though drafting
an amendment to for
consideration uh to drop it to
potentially as a as a violation if you
think a criminal penalty for any of
these aspects that aren't already
addressed by assault um I'm open to
dropping it to a uh violation if there
if yeah I'll just leave it at that I
think that over answers your question
but um did I did I
answer I I think you sort of did thank
you
sorry representative Maron thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for taking our questions I simply uh i'
opened my book RSA book to
6312 and it's in here twice it was
amended and so on in 2015
and aren't we all under that and your
bill would simply make a carve out for
people that are in the health profession
of some kind and I think that making
Couts is a very dangerous precedent to
be going down and I think this bill may
be
redundant any thoughts um I don't think
it's redundant or I wouldn't have if I
thought it was redundant of course I
wouldn't have written the bill um I have
read the statutes of definition around
the various
misdemeanors and felt that the the the
way that assault is listed wasn't
specific enough um for an
employee enforcing a policy around masks
necessarily I feel like with all due
kindness to law
enforcement um there's a bit of
subjectivity to how this has been
applied during covid and there have been
instances um luckily not not so many
that have made viral videos but there
are enough instances where even owners
of these establishments have been
confused and to make it clear for the
protections of the employees I wouldn't
consider that that carve out this is an
addition to at least the way the bill is
worded it would be an additional new uh
misdemeanor that is in application
during a um
pandemic that um you know just protects
that
employee from enforcing their workplace
policy that's it I there is in no way
shape or form meant to be any sort of
carve out
um really this is simply adding and
clarifying what would be considered
assaults uh to an employee enforcing
their workplace
policy you guys are smart and asking
tough questions bring it I'm happy with
this you recognize for a follow question
thank you Mr
chairman in the RSA laws that are on the
books
6312 it talks about class B felony your
bill says class B felony not a
misdemeanor no it does
not for the
chair listen one needs to be a question
number two we're supposed to we're not
supposed to debate the witness uh we we
ask questions uh to obtain information
we always have healthy debates during
the executive session amongst ourselves
but it just that I always remind the
members of the committee of that that's
the
policy before you interrupted me I was
trying to ask I was not interrupting you
represent Marson I do have as chairman
of the committee I do have the
discretion to ask a member to suspend
that's not interrupting it's within the
rules of procedure it's a parliamentary
rules allow that to
happen May I continue
please point of order Mr
chairman repres you recognize for point
of order um I know it's at the
degression a discretion on the chair but
I believe this representative has asked
multiple questions and I've been sitting
here for a really long time my hand
up represent I'll explain that and I've
become an expert on what is and is not a
point of order a point of order and this
I really hope this last time I have to
say this because it's I repeat myself is
when a member is challenging the ruling
of the of the
chair and that is it if I make a
decision on on
something that is what it is now if you
saw at the beginning of this hearing
there was different chairman sitting in
the chair so the mere fact that I may
have deviated to some extent from the
rules please accept my apology I mean no
disrespect to any of the members apology
accepted that was not my intent I did
not think that you were a disrespectful
I just wanted to with draw your point
of Representative Marson you are now
recognized for a followup question thank
you this is only my second question and
my point to the to the uh representative
I want to apologize I thought what you
had in your bill was a class B felony
and I now caught my eye to it's a Class
B misdemeanor so with that being said I
would withdraw my question thank you I
appreciate the question and appreciate
the clarification thank
you representative
Newman thank you Mr chair um and thank
you to the witness for answering the
questions um it appears to me that your
intent was probably to um have this law
or or this bill address the situation
where to prevent an argument between an
adult and perhaps a teenage um Frontline
worker and that even though that it has
a Class B misdemeanor as the uh penalty
as in any case I believe under the law
it's uh that that penalty could be pled
down to something as low as a violation
is that was that your intent when you
put forth this
bill uh well said representative Newman
I would say absolutely the scenario had
in mind was about Frontline workers
typically low-wage workers you know just
as easily by the way could be um an
older woman to be honest with you
typically most of our low-wage jobs in
this sector are women
um like 80% actually um but that is an
EXC excellent point and I do feel that
we've put too many Frontline workers in
these situations to create these
difficulties when honestly I bet they do
not want to be in that position um and
the way you describe the pleading and
the discretion of a judge would
absolutely be um what my intention was
with the bill I mean we could reduce it
to a um violation I do think though
personally I wrote the Bill this way um
after lots of questions with law
enforcement and a former prosecutor and
talking through that just the that uh a
misdemeanor in New Hampshire means
something very different and is much
more hard-hitting than in many states
maybe Most states um I would think there
is a
possibility and certainly by the viral
videos we've all watched that some of
these interactions I don't think many of
those were New Hampshire in all fairness
could be quite serious so to have some
teeth for those instances would be very
appropriate um if you think we need to
add more discretion with a violation or
adding it the way you said it
representative um I'm open to that but I
I trust judges to um use their
discretion and experience and what the
penalty phase of these decisions would
be and having the teeth in this bill
with a clas be misdemeanor I think is um
is a good
thing thank you for your answer and my
intent was only to gather your intent
thank you yes and actually the way you
said it was better than my
answer
[Music]
night thank you chairman thank you
representative for taking my question uh
there's been a lot
of um like we we were trying to
understand this so a lot of my
colleagues were were making hypothetical
situations so as I understood this um I
have a question based off all these
hypothetical situations let's say
somebody intentionally comes and coughs
in my face like there's words exchanged
and then they go over and to intimidate
me they go over and sneeze or spit or
cough in my face and spitting is already
kind I think considered an assault but
where I'm going with this is is if they
did this during a pandemic is there any
recourse that I can take if somebody
coughs like this currently in my face
that I could go report to police and
police officers actually carry out
enforcement on on a crime like
that that is an excellent question and
that sort of um differentiation is why I
felt this bill needed to be written in
the first place because that that
actually enumerates exactly the sort of
thinking I was concerned about um I
think the interpretation of someone
spitting in one's face is already a
misdemeanor but the and so that's good
enough if that's all that people did or
potentially would do during covid that
would be fine I we wouldn't need this
bill um but someone merely even with a
mask on and and getting within three
feet two feet one foot um with this um
employee who's just doing their job
could also catch covid is also a concern
so this is specifically to
codify that public health concern during
pandemics and Public Health crisis is
exactly why we need this bill to be able
to
say um simply getting in a
closer um you know into the personal
space of someone during covid could be
deadly is exactly why I wanted this bill
to exist um that still to me is an
aggressive act and maybe could be
considered assault the way the bill is
written I mean the way laws are written
without this bill but too much of that
is left to
discretion this bill is specifically to
address that kind of concern where the
law is too fuzzy with with what is
considered an assault to specifically
getting to what the health
recommendations are today so that was an
excellent question
uh thank you chair can I have a
followup you recognize for a followup
question I'm still thank you um
representative I'm still a little fuzzy
um can you
just with with just the shortest answer
possible just tell me is there currently
a recourse for someone that has been
intentionally harassed or coughed on
during a pandemic to go seek law enforce
M help is there currently a system in
place I guess one can call law
enforcement
anyway
[Music]
um the definition of
assault doesn't cover what you stated
specifically you know a cough I don't
believe is considered an assault
currently so thank you yes you could you
know I don't believe that
yeah that I'm trying to be as simple and
short as possible that's the intent of
this bill is to
clarify um what you just suggested so
the bill would be needed to do it
properly thank
you representative Hopper thank you Mr
chair thank you representative taking my
question current uh so tomorrow I go and
get a a
pedicure and I'm really proud of so I
walk into the shop of hords without any
shoes what is the current law when the
employee says um uh sir you you have to
leave the building you're not allowed to
interfere without shoes what happens now
what is for
that I I I'm gonna be honest with you
that I'm not a lawyer myself so I'm not
an expert uh I believe Public Health
law covers that but I don't know for
sure I'll be honest I'm not an expert on
shoeless entry to a grocery store um but
congratulations on the
pedicure let's try to keep our questions
relevant to the bill I'm
not representative
bden thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
for taking my question um my daughter is
a teenage Frontline worker so she's been
coming up in this conversation she's 14
she's a cashier at a grocery store and
I've seen a lot of people um in her
store without masks on and I've seen
them go through her checkout line um and
the nature of her job and the lack of
cooperation with basic requests about
hygiene uh in the store has made it so
that we haven't been able to visit my
mom my elderly mom for months she has a
she's kind of high risk but I just
talked to her through the window and the
front door so obviously this has been
really stressful for our family and I
wouldn't ever want to put my daughter in
the position of having to choose between
her you know her her first job and her
paycheck and um our comfort so we we
forego visiting my mom so that uh you
know Sophia can keep working on on her
goals um so I appreciate this bill but I
have a concern um um I'm wondering if
there are people who aren't able to
comply with requests because of some
maybe physical or cognitive
limitation um I guess I I don't see any
language in the bill that provides
flexibility in that situation where
someone isn't complying and but it's not
it's not due to some um refusal to per
to cooperate it's uh really through no
fault of their own so I guess my
question is are you willing to maybe
bring some language back to the
committee an amendment that could
address the issue of someone who isn't
complying through no fault of their own
thank you um I'm open to amending this
however the committee wants to be honest
with you um I think in a situation like
that and the employee is simply
enforcing their employer policy that
leads to a difficulty I'm not sure this
bill would cover that currently but if
you think that needs to be a second
layer of the bill I'm open to it um I
the way that you Ed it I wouldn't see
that that would cause the employee to
need to enforce anything specifically
but again I'm I'm open to uh amending
the bill however the committee deems
necessary I hope that answered your
question see no further hands the
witness is excused thank you Mr chair
it's good to see
you well
representative and uh just to understand
due to time constraints we are limiting
uh testimony from the public one minute
we do I at chair's discretion we will
allow exceptions for the representatives
who introducing the
Bill Elliot axan
and I'm scanning the list for him Mr
chair I do not see
him La
cond if any members of the public are
present in attendance that wish to
testify please raise raise your hands
now as well I do have uh Laura Condon
and I'm elevating
her as we
speak thank you representative m
[Music]
I'm sorry I think looks like I elevated
the wrong
person Laura Condon okay
and Miss Condon if you could unmute
yourself there we go good morning can
you hear me now yes we can hear you and
just a reminder your testimony is
limited to one minute thank you very
much good morning chairman abbis and
honorable committee members my name is
Laura Condon I'm from Bedford I'm a
volunteer New Hampshire director of
advocacy with the national vaccine
information center and I oppose this
bill House Bill 493 that seeks to make a
criminal out of everyone who chooses not
to get get a covid shot and chooses to
strengthen their immune systems through
a healthy diet good hygiene and other
effective lifestyle
practices rather than get a CO shot that
is still experimental and only approved
for emergency use authorization the bill
also seeks to make a criminal out of
everyone who selects a different
medicine say like hydroxy chloroquin for
example for reducing covid symptoms upon
possible
infection other than the experimental
covid shots it is truly shocking that
there is an attempt to criminalize
health and medical decision-making and
choices and seek to make a criminal out
of everyone who might make different
medical decisions other than those
recommended by DHHS and the CDC during a
a state of emergency and Beyond I know
in the
Bill thank you thank you Miss Condon uh
your time has
expired see seeing no raised the witness
is
excused is next witness
Tammy
Anu I do not
seeon is present
okay remind testim one
minute thank you uh salt is a serious
crime and one which has no place in a
civilized society but peaceful
non-compliance is when a person disobeys
an order without raising their fists or
making angry threats and what I'm afraid
of is that this bill opens the door to
first being applied as intended and then
later when we're all gone it could be
misapplied to people who are simply
being peace
not obeying the orders of authoritarians
it's really dangerous when the
government starts granting itself more
power under the justification of a state
of
emergency so I just want to be
thoughtful and consider that we already
have laws that protect against assault
assault is bad we don't want bad
behavior uh but I'm afraid that this
would be applied against people like
Rosa Parks who was just disobeying an
order to go to the back of the bus she
was not assaulting the bus driver but it
was disobeying order and I just I I want
to just be cautious about expanding
government power in the Free
State thank you Mr
Wen seeing No Hands raised the witness
is
excused J recognizes Greg
PE greetings can can you hear me
yes we can okay I will be as brief as
possible um almost every word in this
bill is
problematic it appears the whole purpose
is to allow anyone to enforce anything
but law with the threat of force by way
of governmental penalty for simple
non-compliance the scope of government
overreach is quite frankly frightening
George Orwell himself might have come up
with a dystopian concept of public
service but it is no place to be in New
Hampshire Mr chair and the members of
the committee HB
493 must never see the light of day it's
pathological in its design and it is
bathed in resentment arrogance and
deceit this bill must be itl with
prejudice if possible thank you Mr chair
and members of the
[Music]
committee thank thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused Kaitlin
Hudson can you hear
me yes we can okay um I'm a member of
the public and I strongly oppose this
bill I believe this bill is a violation
of my constitutional rights under the
current emergency Mass mandate many of
us have already been under the threat of
harassment threats of physical violence
and discrimination for not
complying adding fines and possibly
forcing
vaccines is just adding fuel to a fire
of civil unrest we're already seeing
across the state the state should never
have the power to force any medical
procedure or medical product on its
citizens those of us who have medical or
ethical or religious reasons for not
taking a vaccine or wearing a mask are
already the minority we the people of
New Hampshire should be free to choose
what is best for our bodies and not lose
our ability to function in society
because we choose differently than the
majority I thank you for letting me
speak and I plead with you to vote
no thank you Miss Hudson for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is excused oh excuse me
representative
Muse yes I just had one question um and
my question is is where it is exactly in
this bill um uh that would force people
to uh to get vaccinations or would
penalize them if they
don't um I it just is such an open ended
uh you know with the compliance it's
pushing compliance so
say we turn where the majority does have
a vaccine am I not going to be able to
get a driver's license am I not going to
be able to go get groceries um because
that is the mass was the beginning and
the vaccine will be the next step that
is what they are saying the CDC and so
on is recommending these things but we
choose differently the M the small
minority of people choose differently
but we are going to be discriminated
against and this this bill gives power
to that for me to and and they're we're
speaking about young employees I don't
want young employees being harassed I
have never treated someone with
disrespect in a store when they ask it
is again with the medical issue I don't
want to sit and explain to a 16-year-old
that I have medical issues and that's
why I must not wear one and I don't need
to go in that same direction with the
vaccine because it is a a snowball
effect that this
is so a blanket statement for all kinds
of things that they want to do and it's
just
wrong thank
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the witness for a
testimony questions chair now recognizes
Rebecca
kinsky thank you very much I
respectfully urge for you to oppose this
bill failing to wear a mask is not a
criminal act there's simply not
scientific proof that wearing mask even
limits viral transmission we're talking
about the everyday masks that regular
citizens are wearing these are minute
minute particles
and even the FDA had put out a statement
on April 24th of 2020 stating to U the
manufacturers and health care providers
that the labeling may not say that hold
on recommendations against use in a
clinical setting where infection or risk
level through inhalation exposure is
High um they may not state or imply that
the product is intended for
antimicrobial or antiviral protection or
related uses or for infection protection
or reduction so even though this is
what's What's um implied by masking
there's not hardcore scientific data
showing that this is even effective so
to make this a criminal offense to not
Mas is is a is a huge
um
mistake thank
you thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is excused CH the chair now
recognizes Dan
verbil hello can you hear me yes we can
hear you just a reminder your
testimonies lied one one
minute
[Music]
okay yep um see I strongly oppose this
bill uh me and mine have been New
England natives our whole lives um and
we wound up buying Pro property in New
Hampshire why did we do that because New
Hampshire to our eyes is the last basan
of the Old Republic our Founders
designed this nation to be a conglom
conglomeration of states and people in a
barely controlled state of Anarchy the
government deals with the larger issues
we the little people cannot such as
interstate and international trade and
diplomacy National Defense as well as
arbitrating judicial matters fairly
impartially and justly beyond that the
government stays the heck out of our
business and the minutia of Our Lives we
are allowed to pursue life liberty and
happiness and all the minutia therein as
we see fit so long as their Pursuit does
not unjustly interfere with someone
else's pursuit of the same this bill
unjustly interferes with the
aforementioned Pursuit this bill
perverts those founding ideals let me
illustrate Mr vervo thank you for your
testimony uh we do have to limit
testimony to one minute and your time is
expired see no hands raised the witness
is
excused representative herosian
I am looking for representative shy and
I do not see
him Julie
um
the you have a phone call listener we do
have a phone call listener
you have I will would you like me to
unmute the phone call listener Mr is
there that person's hand up uh
no we do have Nicole nordland uh her
hand was up Nicole Norland you you
recognized thank you uh can you hear me
yes we can I strongly oppose this bill
as it is written I did send written
testimony however they were all bounced
back to each and one of your emails
unfortunately I would just like to POS a
question um if your job does not require
you to wear a mask if somebody comes in
and asks quote unquote belligerently
that you put one on who it would be
charged I just thought that would be
food for thought thank you for taking my
testimony thank thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused the the chair now recognizes
Curtis
Barry just a reminder your testimony is
limited to one minute yes good morning
Mr chair good morning members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify uh I'm Curtis Barry uh before
the committee representing the New
Hampshire retail association and it's
several hundred members both large and
small um I'd like to sum up a few of the
the comments um as we know emergency
order number 74 requires uh people to
wear mass in public spaces where they
can't distance
consistently that comes along with
responsibilities for the retailers in in
our case to inform the uh the customers
if they're not wearing a mask to enter
that that emergency order requires them
to do so now subsequent guidance issued
by the Attorney General's office um that
was requested by us outlines
responsibilities um which includes that
specific duty of informing the
customer um we support the premise of
the bill which creates penalties for uh
assaulting an employee simply for
relaying that information in that
circumstance that's required by the
government the employee could it be
elderly as previously cited could be a
teenager just simply doing their job
enforcing an emergency
or thank you Mr Barry uh we have to
limit testimony to one minute and your
time is expired
see no no hands raised the witness is
excuse is Elliot aan Mr chair I I did
have a
question so
sorry we're working
together no no problem
um Mr Barry I'm I'm curious I I know you
were you were cut off just as you were
kind of getting to a uh getting to a
point but it sounds like uh your
organization supports the premise of the
bill uh but you may have some issues
with some particular parts of the bill
I'm just wondering if you might be able
to outline for us what some of those
might be representative M thank you for
that yeah I was going to say we support
the premise of the bill if the committee
wishes to tighten up the language to get
at the the very specific intents that
that's fine
um I don't have any specific
recommendations but I'm happy to to work
with the committee on that um so thank
you for that question um and Mr chair I
do have um some information that may
respond to both representative balin's
question and representative Road's
scenarios that she inquired about
earlier in the in the
hearing I would I would encourage those
members to to seek that information on
question thank you for
sure representative Newman your Rec can
ask for
question thank you Mr
chairman with your organiz I I not
familiar with exactly what the
enforcement is Statewide on the mass
mandate but I am familiar with the mass
mandate in nashwa and it originally did
not it was very difficult to enforce and
uh they passed another amendment that
said uh no mask no service so so then
the it transferred the responsibility
kind of to the to the uh
uh realtor in that it was then um
unlawful to serve a person without a
mask unless they had a medical excuse
for not wearing one uh does your
organization have any
um opinion about how that might affect
them yes we have actually very strong
opinions um we think it's not
appropriate for a government entity to
ask a private sector employ employee
employee to enforce statutes they're not
trained in enforcement not trained in
detention not trained in conflict
resolution which is why the subsequent
guidance from the Attorney General's
office relative to emergency order 74
was welcome which says in essence uh the
the store the business relayed through
an employee simply has a responsibility
to inform the customer um and after that
if there's an issue then law enforcement
should be should be contacted um our
conversations specifically with the city
of nasua and then the the Attorney
General's office um were both
satisfactory in in that
regard followup Mr chair representative
Newman you were
recognized the I I withdraw my my
question I withdraw my question
thank
you represent Balden were
you witness want you to ask a
question
once
twice seeing no further hands raised the
witness is
excused are the other members of the
public who wish to testify that have not
testified already
No Hands raised we now close the public
hearing on House Bill
4933 on House Bill uh on House Bill 493
we had 71 people uh signing in in
support of the bill and
490 signing in in opposition and we had
one person uh who signed in as
[Music]
neutral at this time we're now going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
419 relative to ass Sol of a campaign
work at a poing
place I believe this is going to be a
cha recognizes representative
[Music]
peteran
recogniz chairman abis this is
representative prudom O'Brien did you
mean me oh sorry your name was cut
off okay because I had a little trouble
uh signing up I don't even know if you
can see me is is everything poetic there
we can't see you but we can hear you
just fine okay that's good we'll go with
that that that's good
enough testimony for the members of the
public is Lim is being limited uh for
the representatives in introducing the
bill the time restrictions do not apply
to that
represent okay Mr chair I do I do see
Murray Beth toosan and I'm just
wondering if uh they may be sharing a
computer
wife
s it is um this is the bill sponsor
introducing the bill so we'll allow her
to use it and then we
recognize Ro
next thank you uh so I I'll tell you a
little bit about this bill
um I'm sorry that you can't see me I
dressed up and I dressed nicely like a
State Rep today too so that's always but
anyway um
this bill was inspired by some events
that happened in Windham and in Derry uh
in February of last year during the New
Hampshire primary some citizens were
assaulted when they were merely holding
signs for their candidates outside of
the polling place and people that
disagreed with that candidate literally
assaulted them went up to them and
assaulted them now you know about the
case in in Windham that was newsworthy
and case and Derry though was not in the
news because the victim chose to not
press
charges so what happened in Windham was
quite serious
the the victims there were three of them
uh later had to get a restraining order
and go to court and the police were
there and witnessed the event but they
didn't they didn't arrest the man who
assaulted the victims immediately and
this bill would give police more uh
tools to address this issue
and I'll go back and I'll talk about
what happened in Windam in case anybody
does not know what happened was there
were people holding signs for their
candidate at at a tent and a man went in
and voted and then when he came back out
he walked by them and then backtracked
and literally assaulted them seemingly
out of the blue to the victims that was
how they described it is that they
didn't expect that this would happen the
man um took
a a sign uh that was on a wood holder
and hit a young teenage boy with it uh
or it was about to hit the young teenage
boy when one of the other men men
holding a sign got in the way but that
man got bruises on his face another man
attempted to stop the the um assaulter
and he got injured quite severely and in
in a way that I did not see in the news
and because I went and I and I spoke to
the men I know that one of the men I um
I knew already from his business in
Dairy in my town I buy gas from him I've
known him for a long
time and I
I saw that he had bruises i t I spoke to
the other man and that man had a broken
a fractured jaw and lost a tooth in the
attack and the expense of having to get
the tooth repaired is quite high it's in
the thousands of dollars to get a an
implant so this these people were
severely injured
and then to find out that they have to
do all of the work of getting the
restraining order getting lawyers trying
to fight this the the the attacker
wasn't arrested right away he lives AC
in the same neighborhood as one of the
men that was assaulted he and his family
were frightened by that uh
situation um so I I looked at what state
laws we have right now for uh pole
workers and I simply added campaign
worker to pole worker now with a c
campaign work I know it sounds like
somebody who's making money from the
campaign but this would also this of
course includes volunteers that are
simply holding a sign for their
candidates I never mentioned here what
side these people were on because that
is not that's not important that's not
relevant we need to have a a a situation
in our state where people feel
comfortable holding signs for their
candidates this is a free speech issue
and they need to be able to hold signs
for their candidates or if they are the
candidate and feel confident that they
will be um safe at the
polls you know
when there was a young person involved
there was a teenage boy involved here
who was much smaller than than the
attacker
and I I myself in the past have gone to
the polls without being certain about
all of the the candidates that were on
the ballot but I also knew that what I
do when I got to the polls was speak to
the people holding signs that would be e
the candidate or someone who supported
the candidate and I could ask them
questions about the candidate where they
stand what the issues are that are
important to them so when I have not had
the opportunity throughout the campaign
to learn more about candidates that's
how I have done it and that opportunity
should not be taken away from our New
Hampshire citizens so that they can do
the same thing and if we if we pass this
bill that will make people who are
campaigning at the polling place safer
and it will allow the police to have
more um another tool in their tool belt
to address this Ser very serious
situation I'm I'm glad that nobody was
hurt more than they
were so are there I I think that's
everything are there questions I hope I
can answer them
all representative for
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I'm are you aware
that we have laws against first degree
second degree and simple assault in the
state why is this uh law
necessary thank you yes we we are but
this was a situation that was witnessed
by police and the man was not arrested
he was he left and he left the polling
place went home and wasn't arrested for
days later
why did we I would go back and ask why
did we create this these laws originally
to
protect uh c um poll workers okay people
that are work this this simply adds
campaign workers to election workers in
our uh laws and why do we have those
such laws and that would be to protect
the people that are working at the
polling place so that they can do their
job and
and our elections are safe and our
Citizens Trust that they are safe and
that when they go to the polls that they
will be safe and I think the same thing
applies for people that want to hold a
sign for their candidate and again not
concerned with what side it is they
could be
Democrats Republicans Libertarians
vegetarians I don't care I think that
they all should feel safe going to the
polls and holding their
signs thank you any more questions
representative
Newman thank you Mr chair and thank you
to the witness for answering the
questions um the issue you just brought
up whether it should apply or not to a
citizen who is simply holding a sign and
and may not um be associated in any way
with the campaign you'd like to broaden
it to that it sounded like that's what
you said is is that correct and would
you recommend an amendment to do
that thank you I would be okay with such
an amendment but I do like to keep
things simple so that they that they uh
you know what I'm I'm fine with either
one and it's depends on if the committee
feels that way right now it does say
campaign work so it would be someone
holding a campaign sign so perhaps the
my wording with when I said vegetarian
doesn't actually apply but but I would
be I would be accepting of that the if
the committee feels that's
important representative Newman you
recognize for a followup
thank you for the followup um so the
um
the I withraw my
question
night thank you um chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
and um I understand your intent but my
uh
colleague representative bordon asked um
you know if this was already
covered um this kind of protection was
already covered already in our state
laws so my question uh is as I'm a
little confused bear with
me does election procedure or campaign
law is it is it different like we have
different rules in our body
legislation so state laws don't
necessarily apply like they're different
when we're in we're in a body is it
different similarly here is that why
this is
needed thank you for your
question the there
are enhanced penalties for if a person
is attacked while working as an election
worker so if you're working at the
polling place and you're say the
supervisor supervisor of the checklist
or you're the the town moderator there
are enhanced penalties in place that
protect you and these this would simply
extend those same uh laws to people who
are campaign
workers that is how it is phrased here
but it it would include a person holding
a sign for a campaign and I so that's
why I think this is a free speech issue
and when I found out that the people who
had been involved in the Windham case um
had to do so much work to advocate for
themselves elves after the fact and when
the man had a fractured jaw and is now
looking at the expenses of thousands and
thousands of dollars to get a dental
implant to replace the tooth that he
lost that's
just I was just um amazed and so I
thought that this was the simplest way
to enance penalties for people that do
such a thing and um protect members of
the public who want to hold signs at the
polling place
yes follow oh chair sorry Mr chairman
question uh thank you um chairman and
thank you
representative So
currently this man this victim he
couldn't get the assaulter to pay for
these damages or he couldn't get any
sort of restitution because there's no
law in place to protect
campaign workers or
volunteers well I think that may be
coming later he may find out more about
that later as the court case goes
through the system
but because the charges were there were
a misdemeanor and like I said the police
off the police officer saw it happen
there wasn't much he could do for some
reason the man was not even arrested and
he was let go and it was days before the
man was arrested now if we had this law
in place it would be obvious that it was
as serious as a of a crime as it
is Chairman can I ask one more
question you
recognize thank you so much do you
believe that this might be a police
protocol issue and not a simple a law
issue if the police were not uh you know
following a law that protects our
residents from assault already
thank you representative kin Knight I
think that's a good question but I think
that this bill will make it like I said
earlier obvious to all and that would
include all police officers that this is
a very serious crime and should be
treated as such just as we would treated
that way if it were uh up the town
moderator that you did this to thank
you representative
M yes thank you for taking my question
um earlier you framed this also as being
a free speech issue and so I guess my
question for you is is uh was the man
who committed the assault um acting on
the part of the state in any
way I'm not sure what his motivation was
I have not heard him explain what his
motivation was so that's unknown at this
point Thank
[Music]
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the representative for her
testimony
chair now recognizes
uh representative Peter to
roian hearing as Mary Beth
[Music]
verion thank you Mr chair can you hear
me okay yes we can hear you
representative thank you um good morning
um Mr chair and members of the criminal
justice committee for the record um I'm
representative p to Roan representing
Rockingham County district 14 the towns
of ainson and
plastow and
I'm testifying today in favor of autop
pass for House Bill
419 FN to me it seems like a common
sense um piece of
legislation
that for that matter anybody at the
polling place should feel they're safe
from being assaulted in in ser certainly
it at some point we recognized that we
need to put it in Statue to protect
people um working in the polling places
from the town city or or a ward officer
um I would uh suggest that a campaign
worker at the Poland place should be
protected as well um and it's it's that
simple it adds it adds a um a campaign
work at a polling place um I personally
had um was attacked last um February
11th the presidential primary election I
was holding a campaign sign for a
candidate in Derry at the polling place
at Calvary Bible Church which is 145
Hamstead Road and a a person coming in
to
vote shoved me now I didn't press
charges but it was it was simply it was
unprovoked um that person just I mean I
wasn't expecting it um it didn't knock
me down I have pretty good balance but
it would come out of nowhere and I did
um uh ask the da police they weren't
there at the time they came over and I
gave them some information I chose not
to press charges and that's really not
the issue the issue is you you shouldn't
be um feel threatened at at a polling
place when you're exercising your First
Amendment right um whether you'd be
working uh as a campaign uh worker or or
again is a is a a worker that's
participating to to
um help the process of getting people in
and out of the polling place voting so
um I would just suggest that um I don't
see any downside to passing this
legislation um many of you probably know
in New Hampshire assault can be as
simple as and as a definition for
unprivileged contact and this clearly
went to that level it was it was above
just touching it was was a it was a push
and it was a punch and a push I guess is
how I best describe it so anyway I hope
you consider the OTP of the um of this
bill and um I would just add one last
thing um I think we all know that a
polling place these these days can be a
place of uh of a lot of tension where
people's emotions run high so people
potentially more risk of of having these
sort of things happen than some other
places I would suggest yes but anyway
with that I would be U you know it's
pretty simple legislation I hope you
consider it and and uh at that I would
be glad to take any questions that the
committee may
have representative Knight
hi thank you thank you H representative
toosan it's really nice to hear your
voice um and uh yeah thank you for
bringing this bill I so you called the
police and they came and they offered
you the ability to press charges and
document your assault so my question is
how would this law protect you more than
you were already protected
thank you representative for the
question and um as I mentioned I I
elected not to to go down that road of
pressing charges um the the police did
not witness the event there were
witnesses that did I don't know whether
I would have been successful pressing
charges or not um I will would tell you
that there was not a lot of interest in
law enforcement wanted to get involved
in in the issue and I wasn't pushing it
I wasn't pursuing it so um I don't know
whether I would have been successful
with that or not certainly I this will
legislation of passed I think would
enhance um the penalty and um whether or
not that would make it easier to to
press charges I can't say but it's it
may me people think twice um if it's a
more serious um uh penalty than is
currently there people may think twice
before they they assault somebody again
thanks for the question no problem
follow sir you recognized for a followup
question thanks chair and thank you
representative toosan so
you're saying that if this were to pass
it add it would offer more protection to
people at polls than we already have on
the
books that's correct if if you look at
the language it it it it under um RSA
659 colon 41 assault Etc it it it add
simply adds the word or a campaign
worker at a polling place so it puts a
campaign working the same um class of
protection if you will as is um uh town
and City and Ward officials working at
the PO at the
poll thank you representative troan it's
a really nice again to well I can't see
you so thank you that's okay thank you
representative representative
Newman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking the question
do you know if the uh the phrase
campaign worker is defined in the law
and if not do you think it should
be thank you for the question
representative I don't know the answer
to that I don't know campaign workers is
defined specifically in other stat areas
of statue I don't know that I'm not an
attorney um but looking at the language
it it looks to me you know reading the
bill and again I'm not a co-sponsor um
but by simply testifying behalf of of in
favor of the bill um if you look at the
language campaign worker to poem place
it seems kind of a pretty common uh easy
to understand term uh but it the legal
aspect of that definition I couldn't
comment thank you
representative seeing No Hands
raised representative isus
thank you have a good day sh I
recognizes Catherine
Cooper um thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee this is
Katherine Cooper appearing on behalf of
the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense lawyers um we oppose
this bill I respectfully uh disagree
with the two prior Witnesses um this
will not make anyone safer and this will
not offer anyone more protection um this
is simply inflating penalties um and
essentially making people who are um
misbehaving at an election felons um
instead of
misdemeanant um I would also just like
to mention that I serve as the town
moderator um for the town that I live in
and I have several years of experience
working at the polls and running the
elections um I've also personally been
threatened a few times fortunately not
assaulted but um I agree that people do
get a little out of hand and a little
hotheaded during election times um but I
do not think that that justifies making
them a felon for what is essentially
simple assault I mean frankly I don't
even think that um this the statute
overall is necessary I think that the
general assault um statutes that we have
and the criminal threatening statutes
that we have that apply to the general
public are sufficient
um so I do not think this gives the
police any more tools I would agree with
one of the comments made earlier that
based on the story that was told this
was likely a problem with how the police
handled the situation it had absolutely
nothing to do with the statutory
structure of the state so for those
reasons um we think that this should not
um be passed and would request that the
committee itl this
Bill thank you thank you for your t
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused if there's any members of the
public who wish to testify that are in
attendance that have not testified
already please raise a
hand seeing No Hands
R CH I recognizes Gordon Campbell
Mr Campell you
recognize yes can you hear me yes we can
hear you hi uh my name's Gordon Campbell
I'm um testifying in support of House
Bill
419 it was actually my son and my family
that were involved in the Windham
incident um and from what I observed the
the police were basically powerless on
um that night of actually arresting for
a simple assault
um you know that my son was there
expressing his first amendment rights
those were infringed upon um I I think
it's a little deeper than someone just
slapping someone and calling it a a
misdemeanor I I think it goes beyond
it's repressing someone's rights I think
it should carry a little bit of a higher
penalty than uh what's currently on the
books um so any
questions I mean our family's been been
through quite a bit through this whole
uh this whole ordeal and it still is
with us today A year later so still
talked about it quite a bit but um going
forward I think the the perpetrator in
this whole thing even though he was
emotionally overwhelmed at that point he
he went in knowing um and calling um the
pole workers fascists and all this and
he just snapped when he came out and H
the first person he could find who just
happened to be my son so um there's
unprovoked assault and uh and I I know
the police did their best they said they
couldn't do anything unless they
actually
witnessed the perpetrator striking my
son the public was not very happy when
they let him walk walk away but they did
build a case they did bring it to
Rockingham County and um I'm really not
sure where the actual case that's at
this point but I I do support making um
this not a misdemeanor when that does
happen thank you for your testimony and
uh the chair just may inquire a question
so just for
clarification the police were present
but no one was arrested after this
incident happened and the ex what was
the explanation for why no one was
arrested um the explanation given to me
as actually a first responder that went
to the assault and it found out it was
my own son but um I was told by the
police that due to the fact that it was
not a witnessed
assault that just um Witnesses stating
what happened was not enough to arrest
somebody for assaulting a a a
minor or anything like that so they they
actually let him go and they actually
said they had to build a case before
um they could go forward with it um if
they had arrested him that night they
said that they really they really
couldn't hold on to him for any
particular reason so I think that's why
this bill's coming
forward to put a little bit more teeth
into the into the campaign worker you
know protecting
them thank you again my question
representative
KN thank you chair and uh virtually you
had had pretty much the same question I
really want to know the reason and I'm
not a lawyer uh forgive me um this is
maybe more of a question for the chair
because he is is that some is that
correct that police can take eyewitness
accounts from an assault of a minor and
and then not arrest
someone I please suspend for a
moment if you have any questions of the
chair especially technical ones that
involve complic legal matters maybe we
save that for the executive session okay
apologies thank you I I just wasn't
aware that that I just think this is
outrageous and I think that the the
police department um we really should
have an investigation on them following
proper
protocols thank you
represent representative Newman you
recogniz
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking the question
did you have any indication uh when this
was not followed up that the reason for
not following it up was that the penalty
was not worth you know not severe enough
to make it worthwhile or if it had been
some more severe that it would have been
followed up
Mr Mr Campbell yes uh I didn't know that
question was directed me
um I I think it was just going on a um
it was just a minor infraction um you
know I I thought that that assaulting a
minor would carry a little bit of a you
know it would be almost a felony not a
misdemeanor but um you know to me it
went deeper than that it's like there he
is you know at an event um showing
support for a candidate and yet that had
no bearing on the
situation I don't know if if he was out
on the street at McDonald's and he got
in the same thing happened would the
would the charges have been different
that that's where my question lies I I
really don't
know thank
you Mr if the chair May inquire of a
question and I apologize if you provide
this information already I I know your
your your son is a minor you mind me ask
how old was was your son at the time of
this
incident he was
15 thank you
Mr seeing no further hands raised the
witness is
excused thank you
everybody is that any members of the
public who wish to testify that're in
attendance already please raise your
hand seeing No Hands raised at this time
the public hearing on House Bill 419 is
closed and uh Mr chair we we do we did
have some sign on on signin on this bill
as well uh we had six people sign in
support uh we had 11 people sign in in
opposition
and uh I also see representative Bert in
the attendee list uh would you like me
to elevate him to uh to a
panelist that won't be necessary
representative B is considered absent
today we have a a substitute for him
that's
participating who's sitting in the room
with
us so representative Burke I believe
would be participating as member
public we're glad we're glad to have
join us
as at this
time we will now open the executive
session on House Bill
493 establishing a criminal penalty or
an assault committed against a person
who is coning public health or safety
guidance of requirements during a
declared state of
emergency I'm opening up for
ex I say public executive
session oh excuse me we're opening up
for an executive session not not a
public hearing the chair recognizes
reprentative Wallace to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman uh I move house
FN
second represent wish recognize the
second Mo of
yes representative do you wish to speak
on your motion point of
order representative you recognize for
point of order I'm not tring to gum up
the works at all Mr chair but did we
close the hearing on 419 I do not hear
the
did I close it yeah yes I'm being told
that I closed
it but that but I will say that was an
appropriate point of order how I not
Clos it then open the executive session
see that's that's making sure we're
following the rules but I will give
credit for a correct point of
order that means a lot to me actually
make correct
points now we' open our the executive
session House Bill 493 represent W you
wish to speak on your motion of inp
legisl thank you Mr chairman I will
speak briefly uh Al we understand the
intentions of this bill it is it it is
unconstitutional on its face on creating
a special class of of men if you will uh
and that violates AR part first arle two
the Constitution
repres you
recognized thank you Mr chair um uh
sadly I find myself in the position of
of of having to oppose this bill um I
think this bill uh is redundant with our
trespass uh and assault laws uh I am
extremely sympathetic to the to the
situation and I wish there was an
opportunity to uh uh to rewrite the bill
so we could consider uh uh penalties uh
uh in increasing the penalty somewhat um
for people who fall into these
situations um uh I'm especially
sympathetic with grocery store workers
uh restaurant workers and other people
uh who found themselves in this
situation I I don't think this is a
constitutional issue um it's more of a
of a redundancy in our law issue um and
I and I think one of the unfortunate
things is this has been uh conflated
into um uh a partisan situation when I
think you know what we're really talking
about here is the proper enforcement of
the law throughout the emergency the
state of emergency I think there's been
a lot of confusion around how the orders
should be enforced there's been a lot of
anxiety on the part of people who own
shops and stores and restaurants around
what the role is of their employees and
their staff um but what it doesn't
change is the fact that if if you are
asked to leave a place of business um
because you're not complying with a
policy of that business if you refuse to
leave or you walk by that person you're
trespassing and the police can be called
to take you out um and if you decide to
uh if you decide to uh to make a scene
and to push people around and to assault
people then
the other laws of our state apply in
that
situation I think we have more of a of a
possibly an enforcement and an emphasis
issue um and I also think we have an
issue sometimes where uh the owners uh
or the supervisory staff in in grocery
stores sometimes I don't think
understand uh especially early on in the
pandemic really understood the
importance of enforcing those orders so
all for the benefit of all their
customers from a public health
perspective but this particular uh Bill
uh the way it is written without an
opportunity to uh to change or fix it um
is not something that I can support
going
forward
representa I oppose this bill for a
variety of reasons we're focusing on the
the
grocery store in since I think that repr
Hopper presented one of the a good point
uh and that is if you look at this it
basically says if you don't if you have
some
policy uh that that your group intends
to enforce you it becomes a violation of
Law and and here it is relating health
or safety guide lines or recommendations
regulations or rules from a federal
state or local public health agency
that's a pretty broad statement and that
could be as much
as do you have a
vaccination uh or as she said you you
you get into a an accident you're you're
in the hospital and you are injured and
they want to vaccinate you after they or
maybe before you they uh they they end
up treating I just think that this is
such a broad law I know what it was
trying to do it was trying to say mask
was an anti- mask Law Without call an
anti-mask law I just think but I think
it's broader
implications are absolutely
horrendous the the kinds of injury that
could be occur here are
justb represent po thank you Mr chairman
uh to uh uh one one question uh of the
chair I guess is
[Music]
um I don't know why you kind of ruled me
out of order because the the although I
was making a joke about the pedicure the
idea that the store can already enforce
Health
ordinances seem to be very relevant
because this is just an additional
Health ordinance are youing a point of
order I'm just commenting so the uh but
the bigger point is the sponsor seems to
be extremely well-intentioned
but the way that the court
rules has nothing to do with intention
the court only rules on the actual
letter of the law that we pass and
whether we intended to do X Y or Z is
entirely irrelevant when it gets to the
court
so well as representative Testament said
this could be this law if passed could
be applied in a myriad of ways none of
which were intended but could still be
abused by people to uh
suppress represent hoer at the time that
you were asking the question I may not
have found it to be relevant I may have
gotten lost in the analogy and if that's
the case it may have been relevant I do
apologize was it just the thought of my
feet that probably that probably
contributed to the
distra but I do
apologize representative fly
Knight in the future in the future
though a point of order must be made
immediately if you made a point of order
now it actually would be an incorrect
point of
order I didn't want to get
into thank
you f night um thank you chair um
I agree with everything that my
colleagues are saying unfortunately I
think we could work on this and out of
respect for Frontline workers I think it
would be a disservice to immediately
kill this right out of the gate so I'll
be voting against the itl thank
you representative true thank you Mr
chair Mr chair maybe it just as a point
of information uh would the chair be
willing and able to uh explain what the
the end of the bills for a period of 6
months after such declaration what what
what time frame is so my my
interpretation of that and I will just
limit that to my own
interpretation so whatever violation of
this if this were to pass and the
violation or were
occur while we are in the current state
of emergency that is declared by the
governor the covid-19 pandemic but this
would also remain in effect six months
thereafter it also will this will take
effect January 1st of
2022 maybe have a glass half whole type
of guy but I'm really hoping that we are
no longer in a state of emergency by
January 1st
2022 that's just
this last
representative boate thank you Mr chair
I'm going to uh support the the motion
to itl uh this bill is completely
unnecessary um uh we have laws for
assault both first second and simple
assault uh we have laws against
threatening criminal
threatening but the third section
refuses to
comply as an assault charge
with uh that not
mean being the meaning the intent of the
uh uh a sponsor um is really AB
Abomination I don't think that they
understood the bill that they wrote so
I'm going to to vote for the it motion
[Music]
watch no one has to answer
that I would just emphasize one point
here that refuses to comply with another
I I understand maybe well
intended that could apply to social
distancing for someone who inadvertently
becomes within six feet of another
person
this this is going to be tough to
enforce one of the you know I don't
really engage in the conversation about
masks I always thought it would be hard
to enforce on 1.3 million people but um
I think this this would fall into being
very difficult to enforce and then
prosecutes with that being said if you
have to ask someone to comply with a
health order through the you know Co
whether it's the mass mandate or
whatever that they're technically
already violating the executive order
which is already in offense that's I
think it's it used to be a misdemeanor
the executive order change that to a
civil penalty but it's already that is
also still against the law already to
not comply with these these orders so I
don't we just instead of saying you're
being charged for violating the you know
state of emergency order you're being
charged under a second degree assault
but you're not committing second degree
assault you're you're violating
executive order I I think
that's if you're confused by what I just
said is the reason why you should
probably be
I seeing no for a hand raised
uh question will be
moved uh the clerk will now call the
role if you are in favor of the motion
inexpedient to legislate please say y if
you were opposed please say next
[Music]
and can the members participating
remotely please turn on the
cameras wel
hi representative Mooney yes
representative green yes I'm sorry
representative Hopper yes representative
green yes representative Wallace yes
representative testman yes
representative true yay representative
PR yes representative Marson yay CLK yes
representative Harry G
yes representative
pacus yes representative o'n
Gordon
yes representative Muse
yes representative Newman
yes representative bden
yes representative Conley yes
representative kle Knight
no representative Bradley
yes chairman ask the chair votes yes Mr
chairman the vote is 20 y one may I
voted 20 Y and one Nays the motion of
any expedient to legislate is passed
I'll move to put that on consent
will there be a Minority
Report I don't think so unless Nicole
yeah she she's saying
no
she anyone would anyone be interested in
preparing the majority
report I'll do it you
want thank thank you
I thought it at this time we will close
the executive session on House Bill
493 this time we're opening the public
hearing on House Bill 239 relevant to
the prose prosecution certain assaults
against minors
[Music]
I recognize representative
Aon this is representative Abramson can
you folks hear me yes we can all right
still not used to these uh testifying by
Zoom sessions um so this is House Bill
239 FN uh I'm not sure why there's a
fiscal note on it but uh
um this I introduced this bill last
session and it was one of the bills that
passed unanimously and of course passed
unanimously through the house by a
consent calendar and was killed during
the uh Corona virus lockdown the Senate
didn't take up uh you know vast majority
of our 2020 bills so essentially what
the bill deals with is a problem where
uh a child is abused or is the victim of
felony assault uh frequently with
someone they live with or stay with
uh if if it's felony assault the current
statute of limitations is six years and
I absolutely agree with the statute idea
of a statute of limitations the New
Hampshire Supreme Court has said that
there are two very important reasons for
having a statute of limitations that is
to kind of get the prosecutor on the
ball and get get the case moving forward
and not have things just uh delay in the
courts for a long periods of time and
also to ensure that the accused has the
right to bring in defense Witnesses in
their favor uh who have a relatively
fresh memory of the incident if an
incident occurred or if there's an alibi
or some such thing um that but there's a
problem uh with a child uh the child is
usually living with someone else um or
staying with someone else or has a
regular babysitter and that that child
could be uh severely victimized um and
if they are subject to Serious bodily
injury uh intentionally by another
uh attacker especially if it's someone
they live with then it's unlikely that
they're going to come forward right away
so I I don't base bills on specific in
instances or incidences but this one is
an exception where there was a child
where the the physical abuse started at
age four and there was certainly felony
assault committed against him um at at
some point along the way the problem is
that whatever attack happened when he is
4 years old the statute of limitations
has run out by the time he's age
10 so I had a sit down with legislative
services and um I suggested last session
that we start the clock on the statute
of limitations when the child turns
18 and a few members have suggested okay
well it's a six-year statute of
limitations why not have it go until
their 24th birthday and that would be
much simpler uh one of the the problems
if you read New Hampshire case law is
from time to time you'll have somebody
who knows that they're accused of a
crime and they'll leave the state for an
amount of time or they'll be
inaccessible um so the the the actual
statute of limitations clock if you
think of it as a stopwatch it has to be
it can only be running down while the
prosecutor has a realistic chance to go
after someone so that's that's why the
wording seems a little bit odd six years
after their 18th birthday that the so
the child turns 18 the victim turns 18
and then the victim has 6 years to come
forward um and it has to be six years
while the uh the attacker is still in
the state and is accessible by the
prosecutor and they can they can get
access to Witnesses sometimes you have
people who know they've committed a
crime and they they'll even leave the
country to evade Justice and try to run
out the statute of limitations so that's
why it's it's 18th birthday plus six
years um but again this committee did
pass it unanimously last year it was
just we we sent sended over to the
Senate and they they took a large number
of bills a couple hundred bills and uh
they just tabled them and they died on
the they died on the table unfortunately
so this is one of a few bills that I'm
reintroducing this year uh in hopes of
getting it
passed thank you representative for your
testimony thank you for Mr chairman
recognizing me and thank you
representative for taking my question
I'm sitting in on criminal law today and
learning quite a bit but I want to ask
you something in 2005 I co-sponsored
Senate Bill
75 which was very similar to this
related to RSA
508 colon 4 hyphen
g at the time I sponsored the bill it
was so similar it was seven years from
the 18 birthday and then there was three
years from the time of the plaintiff
Discovery but if you look at 508 colon 4
hyphen G
today there is no statute of
limitations have you compared your bill
with that statute and how does it relate
if it does it
all uh is that 508 section 4-g a person
alleging to have been subject to any of
offense under RSA 32A or 6392 may
commence a personal action at any time
correct that one is is based on sexual
assault so um that one for some reason I
I I read it some years ago in another
case that it was 22 years and maybe you
changed the law to to remove that
um and um I personally believe that you
have to have a statute of limitations um
having read the New Hampshire Supreme
Court cases on
um but I thought well if if someone
commits sexual assault and that doesn't
have the six-year statute of limitations
why aren't we also having a why aren't
we also starting the clock when the it's
it was actually at the time it was the
child turns 18 and then it was I think
22 years which I I feel like is a is a
long time to let the prosecutor kind of
sit on a case it's very rare um after a
year or two it's very rare that the the
prosecution just accumulat
additional evidence by chance although
it does happen does happen in wrongful
conviction cases um but the the statute
of limitations is intended to kind of
get the investigators to get moving and
not not hold on to cases and allow the
once you're accused of a crime uh you
need to be able to have a realistic
chance to go after your own defense
Witnesses and and gather evidence um and
and uh
um um there's there's a whole line of
law dealing with that but um that one I
thought was just sexual assault related
crimes so I thought well if it's felony
sexual assault for example against a
child then it made sense that if someone
also committed felony physical assault
breaking a child's arm for example um or
causing some other long protracted
injury purposely causing serious bodily
injury to a child that that would be
obviously felony assault even if they're
13 or 14 years old it would still that
in that case would still be felony
assault but it made sense in my mind to
just start the clock when a child turns
18 rather than potentially the child
turns 18 and now they're out on their
own they then go to report the case now
that they're no longer under the roof of
their
attacker um that it it didn't make sense
in that case that could be the in some
cases the first opportunity that the
victim has to come forward and Report
felony physical assault um it made sense
to me that this the statute of
limitations should actually run when
there's a realistic chance the clock
should run there should be a statute of
limitations but the clock should only
run when there is a realistic chance to
go after the
perpetrator so yes I am aware that it it
is different under sexual assault cases
but I'm I'm I just wanted to keep this
very narrowed down to uh felony
assault representative clent
night thank you chair thanks for taking
my question um do you know on average
how long it takes for the typical abused
child to come forward and make their uh
situation
known how many years basically when they
sit with trauma do they finally come
forward it could be the same
day um however in some cases both
physical abuse and sexual abuse people
are frequently in their in their 20s
before they come forward um in some
cases there are certain types of
abuse
um for example um trying to remember the
experiments by Joseph mangala this not
an American case but people were
children were subject to physical abuse
that was so bad that it fractured their
personality and with Joseph mango was
taking the the extremes of torture in
order to change their mind he was trying
to create something like a Manchurian
Candidate or somebody could be
controlled but they found that um that
that the trauma could be so bad that it
could fracture their personality and
people could be as old as 28 years old
by the time the they were finally able
to access their memories so it it it's
possible uh in that case um although
that's a very exceptional case um that
um due to the psychological damage it
could take even longer it could take up
to 10 years or 15 years before the
person um uh realizes it before the
memories finally come forward and the
and the the the brain is developed
enough that they can go back and review
what
happened
followup you recognize for a followup
question with that being said this bill
wouldn't protect them in my
understanding and uh it my question is
with 90% of children being abused by
victims of or members of their own
family and knowing that it takes that
long to come forward and be brave and
tell your story are you open to an
amendment
to make this this six years seems like
it's just not going to protect the
majority of victims that wait to come
because they don't feel safe to tell
their
story I'd even thought of going to 10 or
12 years um after they turn 18s so that
they're in the you know well into their
20s when they they uh come forward um I
think that pushing it even further might
be um obviously the the bill now belongs
to the committee um so it's a decision
that's up to you um but I'm just
introducing the bill to introduce the
the the question or the problem what
we're trying to do of course is with the
law create a deterrence so that there's
at least a realistic chance that
somebody who uh commits this type of
felony assault against a child uh yes a
super majority of cases it's it's
somebody who is under the same roof but
that's exactly why whatever you choose
to set the statute of limitations at I
would start the clock when at their 18th
birthday thank you so much
seeing No Hands raised representative
Abramson you are excused thank
you are there any members of the public
who wish to testify that have not
testified
already seeing No Hands
raised we now close the public hearing
on on House
Bill 239
and Mr chair on House Bill 239 we had 12
people signing in in support we had two
people signing in an
opposition say again uh 12 in support
and two opposing thank
you at this at this time we will remain
in recess uh the criminal justice public
sa we will remain in recess to at least
12:30
and
uh mute the
devices you don't normally get a lunch
break so just please enjoy your lunch
and we do a you guys mind if we do a
republican
C
e
e e
yes you should see the paperwork it's
got to go to the clerk office the
speaker
not come to your I'm
sure F home us
[Music]
hello
everyone represent represent can you
hear
us oh is that we can hear you repres Bo
can you mind just saying something make
sure we can hear you guys I can hear you
all
right
okay G good to see you we miss you in
the room today
see she's not used to having to
mute hey I'm sorry about that have to
get my car
registered F away from
me I keep looking to my right
and we're gonna at this time uh we are
going to open the executive session on
House Bill 147
recognize Ro to make a motion to
retain thank you Mr chairman I would
like to make a motion to retain house V
147 second by represent
wel you wish to speak on on that sure
thank you
um you know I actually am a huge
supporter of this bill I do think that
it is necessary however um I do think
that the bill uh there's some some work
that can be done on it I think to make
it stronger and instead ofing
it
representative thank you Mr chairman I
am not in favor of retaining I think
that this bill has no merit after
listening to Katherine Cooper I was
um convinced that there is no reason for
to have this
involed thank
you respect like I really disagree with
the statement that it has no merit but
that's all right representa
night um thank you I agree with
representative rhods I think there is
Merit to this and I think elder abuse is
on the rise in our country not sure
about the statistics in Hampshire I know
that um for we have a real problem with
elder abuse when it comes to theft and
fraud and um and I just want I I would
see us I would like to see us work on
this more and I'll support the retained
motion thank
you seeing No Hands raised uh the matter
uh the we call the role now we put the
question if you in favor of the motion
attain please say yay if you opposed
please say
nay Vice chairman Welch
yay representative Mo
yes representative Hopper yes
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testman yes
representative true
yay representative Pratt
yes representative
Marston yes the clerk votes yes
representative Harry death
no Representative
pakus
o'
no representative Bon
Bo you got a mute
no representative Ms
no representative Newman
no representative
Bowen
no representative Conley
yes representative kle
yes representative Bradley
yes chairman abis chair votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is 14 yay seven
n by the vote of 14 yay and seven days
the motion to retain is
passed we will now close the executive
session on House Bill 147
[Music]
ma get a little
brand I have a question of the
chair yeah um
who move who who are the two people that
made the move on that believe
representative roads made the motion I
believe that was seconded by
representative Welch thank you
[Music]
at this time we are opening the
executive session on House Bill
307 I believe this this last
open went recess because there was an
amendment that was
202-
0411 some concerns by committee members
that were expressed loud and clear about
having an opportunity to review the
amendment
that was on Friday
so this ruining weekend but I presume
that every member Le had an
opportunity to review the
amount I believe was they wasn't off to
pass motion with off the amendment
however that motion is no longer in
favor
repres you wish recognize off
to make a motion pass
Amendment motion toop
am well has there has to be a positive
motion FL representative you wish to
make a
motion about to pass and
offering I'll make a
motion Sign House Bill 307
am is that Amendment 20
21-04 one
each I say that
again 0411
H Mr chairman just for clarity the the
motion right now
is ought to pass the amendment it's
option of amendment it's the
pass that needs to be seconded adoption
to
Second representative true you recogniz
the second
second you wish to speak the
amendment you don't have to Mr
chairman represent kakis
yes I wish to I want to tell you that I
do not receive those amendments I just
put off my email and I did not receive
John Burks from last week I don't know
what the
problem is is there someone in the but I
am not receiving them is there someone
in this room can they please forward a
copy of the amendment two representa P I
can take care of that Mr
chair
thank represent P accept our
apology thank
you the matter open for discussion
thank you Mr chairman
uh this bill is so bad that any
amendment to it will not improve it
unless it is to repeal uh RSA 159 colon
26 thank you
representative
M yes I'm uh opposing this amendment and
I do realize that there uh there have
been some changes made the level of
liability uh has been reduced from
$100,000 to
$10,000 um and uh it looks like
individual uh elected officials in
cities and towns uh will no longer be
liable uh personally uh for for the for
the cost of the suit but what it what it
still does um is it essentially allows
uh any person uh or not any person but
it it it involves allowing people who do
not live in a particular Community who
consider themselves AG grieved uh
whatever AG grieved means from a legal
standpoint um to bring one of these
suits and to file to file for damages um
I think that regardless of whether we're
talking about Second Amendment First
Amendment Third Amendment Fourth
Amendment is an extremely dangerous
precedent for us to set um we heard
testimony uh from the New Hampshire
Municipal
Association uh that they opposed this
bill uh and the reasons why the
municipal Association oppos this bill
have not been addressed uh in the
amendment so I have to agree with uh
with h representative Bourne um
amendment should go down and this bill
should go down with
it who's that
go representative
truth thank you Mr
chair uh the way I'm reading uh
307 uh with the
amendment is it is uh it is simply
restating the fact
at New Hampshire is a Dillan rule
state and to reinforce that fact so
that all municipalities in the state
recognize that fact it puts some
teeth into a
penalty for a town that
says we don't agree that New Hampshire
is a Dylan rule state and we'll do
things our own
way and under New Hampshire law and
Dylan rule they don't have the authority
to say
that if if I am traveling through an
area of New
Hampshire that I am not
from
and I am a grieved because some Town
decides that they have an ordinance
uh regarding firearms that is in
conflict with the Dyan
rule it doesn't make any difference if
I'm from
Sandown or if I'm from
Pittsburgh if a town is violating my
rights they're violating my rights and I
should
have IL legal access to uh to ask for
for to be to be made whole
thank you Mr
chair seeing no further hands rais the
matter we put the
question all the role you in favor of
adopting Amendment
202-
41h please say yay if you are opposed
please say n and M participating at home
remind turn turn on your video
devices camera
devices Welch
hi representative Mooney yes
representative Hopper yes representative
green
yes representative Wallace yes
representative testerman
yes representative true yay
representative Pratt yes representative
Marston y represent clerk votes yes
representative Harriet gri no
Representative
pantelakis
no Representative o'
no representative G
no representative
Muse representative Newman
I believe stepped
out yeah he might have stepped out
so Representative bden
no representative Conley no
representative kle Knight
no representative Bradley
no chairman n the chair votes yes Mr
chairman the vote is 11
by a vote of 11 Y and nine
y by 11 y nine y the motion to adopt
amendment
20210 11h has
passed to make a motion about the pass
as amended now I'll make a motion not to
pass with Amendment for house
307 thank you Mr chairman I second that
motion represent W represent well wish
to speak to the motion no I think we all
understand
it chairman um I have to oppose this uh
amendment to a bad uh Bill law um 159
col 26
disallow School Board schools to
regulate uh schools on their property
which federal law already uh permits
those regulations in fact they restrict
uh the use of the carrying of guns on
school property unless they have a uh
concealed uh permit
um and then if a a town or municipality
want to restrict the use the The
Possession or use of firearms in public
parks they should be able to do that on
their on their own individual town now
uh if some towns don't want any
restrictions on the use of firearms in
their Parks then they don't have to uh
make such ordinance but I totally re uh
reject this bill and 159 coling 26
representative
Muse thank you Mr chair I I I think
that bill um in addition to all the
other issues it has also has a a
constitutional issue um so in particular
um the definition of AG grieved is
having a feeling that one has been been
wronged um and this is very different
than the requirements under our law that
demonstrating a person or entity has
required a definite and concrete
personal injury and has personal rights
that were impaired or prejudiced which
is actually required by part one article
74 of the State
Constitution uh in order to have
standing to bring a lawsuit I feel that
this this bill um that we're about to
take and not to pass with mment vote on
um is unconstitutional for that reason
and does not deserve our
support repres
representative thank you Mr chairman it
in reference to representative Bourne's
comments that if a if a town or
municipality and I'm not quoting exactly
so the town municipality wants to make a
a rule or a law that says that you're
not allowed to have your firearm in
their town but they should allow to do
that how how could that even be a second
and I don't even know what to say to
that so when you're driving through a
town now you have to stop and take the
you know take your magazine out of your
firearm go lock it up in your trunk get
through that town go back be able to go
back to being able to protect yourself
again
not I I'm sorry I I've got nothing else
on that I don't know what to
say
representative K Knight um thank you
chair thanks colleagues you know in
light of what representative bordon and
representative Muse uh have said I I
can't support this it opens up the state
to being sued because it directly is in
conf with federal laws that are already
placed here and if that is the case that
means our
taxpayers will be paying for the right
for everyone else to just carry their
guns and and not be an observant of the
federal guidelines that are already in
place and that's very irresponsible and
it's not fair to my citizens and for
that reason I'll will be voting against
this
[Music]
I representative green thank you Mr
chair H A friend of mine moved back from
Georgia not too long ago and he told me
that there's a town in Georgia that if
you want to live in that town the
requirement is that you own a
firearm and everyone in that town has a
firearm and it's one of the safest towns
in the
country so I will be voting for this
bill
[Music]
K yes thank you and those conscious
obes who
know I'm sorry what town was that
Kena Kena it's the law that's that's a
town in Georgia just for the record just
outside represent pus
yes thank you Mr chairman I think this
bill is too far reaching not everything
is guns we do have rules about dogs and
other things within our towns and cities
is that going to grieve
somebody is that want is that question
no I I do respect the point I I just
think
okay everyone who hasn't had opport
hand up oh no no
no repr wall did you have your hand
up we have a few more bills to ex for
130 uh so has anyone not spoken yet that
would like to
speak see seeing no for
new speakers with their hands raised M
put the
question the RO my hand up Mr
Speaker
elevated represent Maron please you know
recognize the speak uh representative
Knight I the what the chair is doing is
that I'm I'm recognizing everyone to
speak uh if I'm not I haven't recognized
any member to speak a second time it is
within chair's discretion to not
recognize any member to speak a second
time so in the interest what we have
left I'm gonna move we're gonna move the
questionless anyone who hasn't spoken
already
wants thank you chair seeing no uh
further hands raised uh the matter will
be put the question the clerk can uphold
the role if you in favor of the motion
of a the pass as amended please say yay
if you're opposed please say nay
Vice chairman Welch
hi representative Mooney yes
representative popper yes representative
green yes representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
pre yes representative Marston
yay the CLK votes yes representa har G
no
Representative
no Representative o'n
no representative B no representative
muse
no representative
Newman Representative
bden
no representative Conley no
representative Quin
Knight
no representative Bradley no chairman
the chair votes
yes vote is
11 by vote of 11 Y and nine y the motion
of O to pass is amended
passed is is someone willing to commit
do the majority report
know will there be a Minority
Report
yes at this time we close the executive
session on House Bill
307 at this time we are opening the
executive session on House Bill
239 relative to the prosecution for
certain assaults against
minors is there anyone interested in
being recognized to make a
motion not all once now which what
number we
[Music]
on9 representative for you recognized
Mo I um make a motion to Al to pass and
I'll second
it that motion has been about the pass
been seconded by represent
Gite you wish to speak your motion about
the pass I think this is a reasonable
extension of uh uh present law to uh
allow the statute of limitations to go
six years past the age 18 for minors
thank you representative B and uh you
and I both uh served on the committee
last term as a lot of members and I
believe we passed this uh on consent is
that am I correct when I say that yes
I'm not sure
probably thanks um I don't have the
statistics in front of me but the I know
the majority of of uh child abuse
Survivor victims of child
abuse really take a long time to come
forward so I this is great but I I don't
think it it's does enough I don't
think 18 plus six years is enough for
victims um so I really would like i'
really like us to to make this longer
um I I hope there's someone on the
committee that feels the same way I do I
I I wish we could make an
amendment um for that um but if that
isn't the case I'd rather see this pass
than nothing at all so um thank you
represent night I I
appreciate what you had to say and I
will tell you this I do agree with you
that I I would at at different times
would support making six years 10 years
but I will say we did have a bill last
term that did not pass that would have
got rid of the stat lications all the
way we could reach a point where too
much is too much so I would say would
start with six but in another term at a
different time if you and I are both
members and you wish to file a bill
maybe Keep Me in Mind as a
co-sponsor thank you chair
anyone else wish to discuss the motion
about to pass seeing No Hands raised the
matter we put the question the cour will
call the rooll if you are in favor of
the motion of V to pass please say yay
if you were opposed please say
no chairman W
hi representative Mooney yes
representative Hopper yes representative
green yes representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative C
yes representative Marston
y Clark votes yes representative harri
Gaff
yes representative
pacus
yes representative o'n yes
representative
B
yes representative Muse
yes representative
Newman representative
Borden yes representative Conley yes
representative yes representative
Bradley yes chair chair votes
yes I voted 20 Y and zero Nays the
motion of a to pass passes I'll move put
that on for
consent represent will you be completing
a majority
[Music]
report B on time just just a quick
friendly announcement to everyone and
please someone make sure this is
communicate with R so we're in all
likelihood we're going to meet on the
11th sorry the 10th so after Wednesday
the 3 we're going to meet on Wednesday
the 10th right we're also going to
have something scheduled on the 11 in
case we don't that's also our deadline
so all the bills we have left need need
be out this committee with reports my
ADD so if I get a little
uh you know fired up getting your report
forson just forgive me now but
uh it's it's I'm going to get some
clarification on whether we have to
schedule something for the 11th or we
can just meet to EXA it's not proper for
us to formally notice an executive
session but if we can avoid meeting on
the 11 that would be great so my
question is to the members whatever's
left on Wednesday it would be about
eight bills we can get all those done on
Wednesday kind of like
a marathon if we can get that done we
don't have to come in on Thursday but it
may be a late night and then you you'll
have we get our reports let's keep that
in mind is there any feeling on us
staying here till 7 o'clock on a
Wednesday
thanks if representative M wants to
Subs let's
not she may she may say yes now then
change your mind throughout the day you
know the rest of the
day but I just want to let everyone know
that can avoid us that would really help
the other committees out too because
there's a limited amount of the me so
maybe we maybe we try to go the distance
on that Wednesday but it will be a late
night if you if you come to the room and
can't stay uh just please you know you
need to put in for a substitute if you
wish for someone to sub
for simple as
that is there
a does anyone have any issues with that
please speak
now because once I once I give away the
Thursday the 11th is not coming
back if we're gonna go past five o'clock
you should probably get a substitute for
me you would have to formally notify me
that you can't but that's we would I can
Envision us you need to be prepared to
go past five if you want to be present
right that's what I'm formally telling
you saying that now that was the formal
okay all right uh I
believe the only Bill other Bill we have
outstanding right now is house bill
419 at this time that we are opening the
executive session on House Bill 419
relative to the assault of a campaign
worker at a poing place
representative
B thank you Mr chair I like to make a
motion to itl this
bill
second that motion has been seconded by
representative Hopper represent you wish
to speak to your
motion uh yes um I feel the the bill is
unnecessary and um
the the raising of uh the assault issue
at for a campaign worker which is we're
not sure what who that who that person
is uh from a possible simple assault to
uh a uh uh felony assault is I think
Beyond The Pale
representative
m i i I would agree I I would also say
that um we do have existing assault
statutes on the books um that would seem
to uh to address these issues I think
this is sort of our day to get um
legislation we really sympathize with my
uh my wife is a campaign worker um I
think all of us at one time or the other
have in our careers have stood outside a
polling place with a sign in our hands
and understand what it's like to kind of
deal with people who might be might be
confrontational um but we do have laws
in the books that uh that that do
provide Justice in these situations and
I think maybe one of the things that
might be necessary in some departments
is occasionally reminding officers you
know especially in in inflammatory
situations like the polls can be anymore
uh to really be on the lookout for this
stuff and to and to not have uh any
tolerance at all for physical
confrontations um but um I like I said I
I I sympathize with where the sponsor is
coming from but I'm I don't agree with
changing our law uh in the manner that's
outlined in this bill thanks
if I can just point out this is
more not necessarily the policy of this
bill it does say in there I find it it
says a Class A or class B
felony uh which when we see something
written that way just for interpretation
purposes it really leaves the leaves it
within the discretion of the
county county just to prosecute A or B
law is written that way if it's a really
old law will
have be written sometimes we just say
felony but a person needs to be on
notice when they're being charged what
the offense
is so they know what the penalty is
specifically that's that's
constitutional right I don't think this
really violates that but we we really I
wouldn't support really having it be
left open to the discretion of the of
the County Attorney to whether they want
they feel should be a Class A or Class B
I just think regardless of the policy
you should pick one um whe that's
stealing dogs are assaulting people at
the campaign workers you know at just
just
a that that's something to keep in mind
um I think what happened in Windham
particularly is I I am shocked that such
a a situation A minor
who's 15-year-old kid can be assaulted
by an adult in front of so many
people and you have certain amount of
witnesses including someone who suffered
you know broken jaw trying to break you
know defend the
child uh and no one be arrested on site
now maybe no harm no follow because the
person still eventually indicted I'm not
sure they indicted it's going through
the court system
now I just find I mean so it is kind of
concerning that person wasn't arrested
right
away I know that what I do know about
the facts that the person was defendant
was local residence as well maybe there
some I don't want to speak to the police
I'm just very surprised that person
wasn't arrested for a violent crime if
this was a domestic violence case would
be an exception assault on a
minor I again I'm I'm just concerned how
that happened but that's that's really a
police practices
situation and some of the maybe should
be looked into and why what what
occurred and why was there no wrestling
on
site I'm not a police officer but I
think it's a problem cause
issue Mr chair I can introduce a bill
upstairs you don't need to this do
you it's my bill upstairs
so when I'm the voting you're free to I
mean all right I just want to say that I
need you to stay to vote I know looks
like it's be unanimous anyway I love you
I would love you but I understand that's
not
possible don't worry about
it representative KN said he
[Music]
you I'm really I I want to say that I'm
shocked at this story but I'm not it's
sadly something that I've been hearing
ing from other residents that this sh
this situation shs A light on our police
State Police protocol and procedures and
how they're not being followed and I
mean this could happen to any one of us
we could be assaulted our kids could be
assaulted and we call the cops and they
do nothing and what world is that okay
this this uh obviously this bill doesn't
fix police Pro protocol and procedures
from being followed
but I think the testimony that we we
heard and the bills we've heard prior on
streamlining Pro police procedure really
need our work we really need to
respect um our citizens and in the fact
that make sure making sure that our
criminal justice system is working for
us like if they're not showing up when a
kid gets
assaulted what's the point of them we
need police that protect us this is
outrageous and I I mean this again I I
can't stress how enough that when people
say oh this might not happen in my town
oh we have great police here in our city
whatever I want to know where I go
anywhere in New Hampshire that I can
call the police if I am being the like
you know assault whatever have you I
want to know that they're following a a
police procedure this is this is scary I
think everybody in this room should
should should be very very concerned um
just for clarification purposes I don't
believe that the police didn't respond I
believe they were on they were
physically at the the voting board what
happened was they my understanding was
that they because the police officer on
that was pres did not see what happened
that they claimed there was no they were
unable to make an arrest at that time so
it's a little I mean it's not they will
call and then they just we're not going
to show off that that is a little
different I just I have a question uh
chair since you're a lawyer I don't know
if you can help me with this so let's
say 10 people are eyewitnesses they say
this guy over here punched a 15-year-old
in the face and the cops didn't see it
the cops just they don't arrest the guy
like what what is the usual thing that
happens then well my understanding and
I'm not giving anyone legal
advice if an officer believes that
there's probable cause that a crime has
occurred and that crime is is above a I
think a Class A Miss it's a Class A Miss
higher
then they they they can arrest a person
now they would base it on the
credibility of you know if 15 people
tell me the same thing I didn't see what
happened I would think it would be very
difficult for that that many people to
organize such a elaborate lie that quick
I just it's all about a valuing
situation you have someone who's
bleeding you it was clearly visible
evidence that a violent altercation
occurred it was really a matter of who
did what
[Music]
so you I just thank you for trying to
explain I just want the record to show
that this is really concerning in our
state and I've heard this I I myself um
you know had some teenagers down my
street and they were screaming and I I
went over them I'm like what's going on
here and they said there's somebody
coming after us with a baseball bat okay
I called 911 this is a true story they
never showed up I called them again they
never showed I mean like I don't know
what's happening
that's why I wanted to be in this
committee there is a real uh breakdown
of communication and response to our
criminal just our police I I don't know
what's happening but I think this is all
this is a really red flag for all of us
this story and I just want to highlight
it it's it's very important because if
the police aren't protecting us what are
they doing and let's just clarification
to the the public when we say the police
this involve
Windham not I'm not saying that Windham
has a problem with how they operate just
this isn't this wasn't a state police
offer and same thing I just want to make
sure
night this isn't a not not every
Department repres I see put your hand
up believe at one point you are have
experienced in law enforcement I would
have can if I can ask a question
can ask but I'm getting close to having
to go to work and I think we're just
we're just getting way off track
here
okay is that is that what you wish to
say that's what I would say I think we
understand what's going on uh this the
bill and the police matter I think are
two different things and we're talking
about the bill and we should just deal
with
it representative
pesia Thunder
no I just wanted to say that we need to
address the
bill whether we like it or don't like it
because we were not there we don't know
what they saw what was done and it you
know can't have a kangaroo good thank
you
see seeing no further hands raised the
the matter will be put to question the
clerk will call the RO
what the motion
is
I you got stra the
motion the clerk will now call the RO
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
the clerk will call the role if you are
in favor the motion of inexpedient to
legislate please
say yay if you opposed please
say Vice chairman Welch
hi representative Mooney yes
representative poer representative green
yes representative Wallace yes
representative testerman y
representative true yay representative
Pratt yes
representative Marston
yay the clerk votes yes representative
har G yes representative
pantus
yes representative o'n
yes representative B
yes representative Muse
yes representative
Newman representative bden
yes representative Conley yes
representative P Knight
yes representative Bradley yes chairman
chair votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is
19 by vot of 19 Y and Zer NS Mo any ex
legislate move to consent
representative bne you wish to make the
majority report I
shall thank you very much at this time
we will close the executive session on
House Bill
419 we remain a recess until
1:30 why is it when some people vote
their picture doesn't show up on the
screen
I no
idea when everyone votes the picture
comes up on that screen this one yes
that you can set the zoom to different
features whoever is
speaking uh will get the big screen I
have mind set I to see everybody there's
a gall or speaker yeah yes what I'm
saying is when we're taking the vote I'm
not seeing the
picture the face of the person who's V
if it you I am
watching I can see everyone on my screen
as well you notice my little pause for a
second I
was there was a representative who had
the camera on waiting for the body to
get back get back to where it
[Music]
was yes Mr chairman could you tell me
how many builds I left to
ex right now we actually it just except
every bill that we could possibly EXA we
are so we
are we are
good which is which is great because we
what
about thank you what about the one that
John um Burke
had that was H 307 we we did that
today yeah thought he was doing the okay
sorry I thought we had a re
reconsideration there was a
reconsideration of cacr
a
right we I believe we EXA that
in on Friday and it's all set I don't
believe there's any outstanding exective
sessions on Friday I don't wasn't there
I don't I
remember that we asked that it not that
we hold it until Monday because we
didn't all have the amendment and it was
a strong amendment that was 307 307 we
did that it's the one you didn't have
okay thank
you one thing we should do
I'm going to start the public hearings
one thing we should do when we send out
the Amendments they all go to your
legislative email if you have a
preferred email maybe we create a
preferred email to send the amendments
to if it's not your legislative email I
don't that would be more helpful uh so
represent I leave it to you maybe
gather everyone's PR
email um in your pocket and I the same
mine and maybe
a master what you want to call we'll
make one email so and we'll give that to
the committee assistant to forward them
to that might be okay we'll
do printed uh copy there still be
printed copies here but I'm just saying
it's the people um the members partip
remotely aren't always receiving and
that legislative email I mean gets
sometimes with emails that if we try to
look for it just
I have a legal question for
you ask may
I you're
guilty we we are what's the question
send me a reference to House Bill 419 on
the assaults at the campaign offices yes
a lot of times the police officers will
not make an arrest because when they get
into the courthouse and the judge says
were you present and saw
this they say no I wasn't and that that
can kill
a that might explain why why they it
sounds like they they followed up on the
investigation let's get because they
eventually didn't make an
arrest
righten to just
discuss and she would like to let you
know that DRS she does not believe
they one email
list other than to send out that's why
they're all
going well the zoom invit I'm talking
about the Amendments that we have to the
committee right she's saying they're not
allowed to
[Music]
send we'll clarify that all right let
let's get started at this time we are
opening the public hearing on House Bill
526 relative to the fine and the sale
the sale or possession of cannabis and
House Bill 511 will be heard
simultaneously
and that is relative to the penalties
and possession of certain controlled
drugs the time constraints we are going
to limit testimony for uh each bill for
members of the public to one minute uh
with the exception of the uh
Representatives that are introducing the
bill bill
this time the chair recognize
representative
abson
introduce a you being recognize
introduce uh House Bill
526 all right thank you Mr chair members
of the committee I'm going to try and
speak as quickly as I can um so that you
can get through with your work House
Bill 526 is intended um the bill that
wouldn't actually uh legalize or Rel
legalize uh sale or possession of
marijuana the intent of the bill uh is
to reduce the fine to $1 per gram uh
which would be if if it were viewed as a
tax it would be paying about the same
amount as what you would pay in Maine
and other New England states um
unfortunately we have uh uh we normally
don't talk about the Senate but being
realistic the Senate uh majority right
now would not vote to Rel legalize
personal amounts of marijuana right now
so I think this is probably as far as we
we could go as a house in reducing the
penalty or or bringing the penalties in
line with something that that that I
think is more realistic um $1 per gram
of course for a half an ounce would be a
$14 fine one of the the the problems we
run into is someone goes to a medical
marijuana dispensary and their ID card
is either they're waiting for it it's
insired it's from out ofate I know that
there's another out ofate bill out ofate
medical marijuana ID card bill coming in
um and you have patients who who require
cannabis in order to deal with any
number of symptoms um sometimes they
people change doctors and the doctor
gives them a different um same uh
diagnosis but a different prognosis and
they they prescribe uh opioids or
Oxycontin or something that that may be
a little bit excess where uh medical use
of marijuana may be preferable but
another problem that I I encountered
when going through medical marijuana
statutes is if if a cashier
sells uh marijuana over the counter to
someone um I believe the penalty is six
years in prison and a felony if the
person's um ID card is expired or out of
state um and I thought that was a little
bit of not just a little bit excessive
that's crazy
um just missing a factor detail I
thought it was uh um pretty bizarre um I
was contacted I think the rest of us
were contacted by um
DHHS and they they did bring this this
issue up that it is potentially a felony
for for selling this over the counter um
and
um so um I'm going back and forth with
legislative Services right now to update
the the the the the details of the bill
but um the the the house last session
passed a measure to Rel legalize
personal amounts of marijuana and I
think it passed by a margin of almost 5
to one knowing full well that it wasn't
going to make it through the Senate and
wasn't going to be signed into law um
which is unfortunate um we do spend an
enormous amount of money as a country
trying to enforc marijuana laws um there
are still a lot of arrests going on we
do have police coming up saying you know
almost every week saying we can't arrest
our way out of the problem marijuana
policy project has listed 10 reasons why
marijuana prohibition doesn't work um
but the main one is that it it's
contributed to a breakdown in respect
for the rule of law every time Congress
has stepped up uh drug prohibition since
the uh
1967 when it started under Lyndon
Johnson I think is when the national
announcement was made every time they've
stepped it up crime has gotten worse
drug use is tripled uh death rates are
skyrocketed and uh prohibition
especially marijuana prohibition uh gets
in the way of harm reduction which are
generally efforts to minimize the harm
caused by uh drug use um the loss of
civil liberties the 80,000 SWAT raids
into people's homes every year um as a
state I believe somebody put a figure
out of about $45 million a year in terms
of lost revenue and money that we're
spending on arrests prosecution and
incarceration um obviously the
environmental problems that that result
um the loss of control um that the sales
of of uh drugs when they're made illegal
or alcohol or or any type of prohibition
gambling prohibition gun prohibition uh
alcohol
prohibition um and doing research on
Article Five um by the time uh alcohol
prohibition was the only amendment
passed to the Constitution through State
ratifying conventions and it's
interesting going back on the history of
the debate that they found that it was
so
obvious um by the early 1930s that
prohibition had been alcohol prohibition
had been a complete disaster and here we
are with marijuana prohibition fa facing
the same problem or the same same crisis
um making uh marijuana illegal tends to
drive people away to other um Alcohol
and Other Drugs uh marijuana Prohibition
in particular has caused more problems
more arrests has led to uh
disproportionate sentences for poor
people and people of color about um I'm
told that 88% of people serving time
behind bars for for drug violations are
for mere possession of marijuana and
85% are black Latino or American Indian
so it disproportionately hits people of
color much harder than any anything else
um this is this has been a policy or
this has been a policy that has uh cut
across party lines for a long time and
um in most of New England at least it's
it's almost Universal and certainly
among younger people that that it makes
absolutely no sense to see people's
lives being ruined um for this so the
intent is not to make the policy change
because of both federal law and because
of the condition in the Senate um it's
simply to reduce the penalty to $1 a
gram uh which is certainly a compromis
position um the intent was that the
revenue would be collected by the town
or that the dispensary would simply pay
the pay the fine to the town um allowing
the town to use the money for improved
uh uh funding for
EMT uh resources but that would be a
decision to be made by the people of
that particular Town um
uh I think that this bill could probably
pass on the floor pretty easily um as is
but I I think as much as The house's
position has been that that we should
Rel legalize personal use um that just
isn't the position of the Senate right
now so I think this is a this is a
compromise to try and and and see if the
Senate will come back with
something representative pakis you
recognized
you have mute
[Music]
represent thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative for taking my
question how how does a a person or
place that sells medical marijuana give
the marijuana to the people without a
cat
it in theory they don't but there's a
bill coming over to deal with the same
issue from your question what happens if
somebody comes in with an outof State
medical marijuana ID card or what if
someone has an expired ID card or what
if someone shows up um a
disproportionate number of people are
disabled and they they come in uh it's a
very difficult trip to the dispensary
and they don't have the with
them U they would not be able to
probably would not be able to buy it but
if the cashier recognizes that person
and believes that they have uh a medical
condition uh they would be risking
prosecution for selling marijuana for
for medical use to someone who has a
legitimate
condition second
question represent P you recognize for a
followup
yes uh it was to my understanding when
we made the rules for the medical
center
and the people that bought and owned the
build businesses agreed that these laws
were put in place for that reason so
that so I
don't understand why we want to give up
that fact that that cashier would go to
jail for six years she's supposed to be
following our laws have you had any of
them u i I lost some of your question
due to um due to uh signal loss um but
it it's it's a matter of represent P do
you want to clarify your your question
again before the witness
answerers
and no it's s
thank you you still May respond to the
the question all right I I I just
believe that the the penalty we wouldn't
do this for any other business uh as far
as I know we wouldn't go to this excess
and we certainly wouldn't want to uh put
a a cashier who's selling I don't know
tobacco cigarettes or or or even beer to
somebody who has an ID that looks like a
legitimate ID but later on in court
maybe somebody on the jury says oh this
is a fake ID or here's an expired ID or
or who knows what or here's an ID and it
it doesn't quite look like the person or
somebody misuses an ID the cashier
should not be put in Jeopardy thank you
jail time at
all thank
you representative tro thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question uh the rsas that
presently say uh it's a felony if you
are selling over the counter and the
idea is that addressed in your bill
there's a lot of crossout here I haven't
found that yet so I was contact I the
intent was what I explained to
legislative Services was the intent was
that for absolutely all purposes in the
state any any sale or possession would
be Li reduced to a $1
fine um however I was contacted by DHHS
and they said well this bill wouldn't
have that impact so I went back to
legislative Services I've gotten a an
amendment back and we're going back and
forth with
I've taken that that amendment that I
just got back from legislative services
and I emailed it to all the members of
the committee so it should be in your um
email inbox for this morning so if I
have to come up with another amendment
to to further clarify that I'm willing
to do the
work thank
you say no further hands
raised the representative is oh excuse
me representative harer uh thank you Mr
chair um thank you representative for
taking my question um what concerns me
is the uh and has for some time
is products are infused with
tetrahydrate
canol they're they're wreaking havoc
with children in Colorado and other
places because they're it's it's not
like marijuana somebody has an ounce of
marijuana on the table a child is un
likely to eat it if a if a person passes
out on their couch and there's a bowl
full of uh infused gummy bears the kid
will eat them all and the kids kids have
gone into uh actually one senator from
Colorado told me it could ended up in a
coma from there do you do you uh how do
you propose to deal with the infused
products that might end up in the hands
of
children if we're going to speak from
uh that problem can only be solved by
either Rel legalizing or or completely
decriminalizing marijuana um and that's
one of the things that I'm trying to do
with the bill facing of course the
problems we have with the Senate um it
if when we legalized alcohol in 1933
until that all through alcohol
prohibition people were going blind off
of of bathtub Jin people were the the
the amount of Meth ethanol that was uh
existing in illegal alcohol was alcohol
prohibition was causing more problems
than it was solving by far and certainly
marijuana prohibition is causing a lot
of those problems if the sale or
possession is illegal already you've
already kind of crossed that line we
want to
have or majority of members of the House
want to have
marijuana the the the sale and
distribution needed to be uh ulated and
legal so that it's it's reputable
businesses supplying these things not
illegal suppliers one of my friends is
Chucky Rosa of Chucky's fight and his
eldest son died not from the marijuana
that he smoked but because it was
illegal I believe it was fentel was was
was put into it and he didn't know that
there was fentanyl in it and he he died
not from the marijuana of course but
from what it was laced with if marijuana
is Rel legalized if the supply is Rel
legalized um then that would be much
harder it is still possible to lace
tobacco or alcohol or anything else with
illegal substances but it wouldn't be
done by the manufacturer and it wouldn't
be done by reputable businesses it would
be done by presumably someone giving you
say rolled tobacco and then people
sometimes put other drugs into tobacco
but it's just it's much less common
because tobacco is
legal representative
testerman thank you Mr chairman thanks
representative Aon for taking my
question you
dodg uh representative Hopper's
question represent Testament we don't
speak to the intent of
members gummy bears
infused with marijuana in the case that
we heard testimony on are totally legal
because they're marijuana byproduct in
Colorado uh those are available uh you
know to purchase on the open market it's
a valid question and I want you to
answer this is is if there
are somebody leaves a bowl of gummy
bears out and gets to them
uh yeah what's your
responsibility I mean I you legalize
your total legalization makes no sense
when when marijuana today rather than be
5% like it was you know way back when in
the 60s be up to 70 80% so I I want to
know you why you're trying to legalize
something that is basically uncont
controlate the wi either
kind of a hard
it resp to the question not the debate
part yeah I'm trying not to get into
bait you could have gummy bears that are
just you know regular gummy bears with
sugar like the ones we got as kids and
anybody could lace those with anything
right now and and when I was a kid there
were when we went uh you know door to
door Todo uh for
trick-or-treating um we had to throw
away a lot of candy that we couldn't be
sure about because of the risk of crazy
people out there who would lace just
existing candy or you know for adults
alcohol alcoholic beverage sometimes get
laced or spiked or just you know uh the
punch bowl and back in high school I'm
not sure if that happened at your high
school but it it certainly happened at
college and high school back when I was
a Youngster people do Spike substances
like that but it's it's harder to do it
if if it's legal if you have a legal
product like tobacco or or or or soda or
something like that because soda is
legal you're getting a 2 L bottle of
something and uh you open it you can see
it being opened and it's it's pretty
hard for somebody to to spike it at that
point whereas illegal substances are
just kind of very very informal um and
they just kind of get rolled manually my
my preference would be that that the
supply of substances should all be
legalized um or Rel legalized because we
don't want things spiked we don't want
fentanyl put in things we don't want
illegal substances or dangerous
substances put in um that aren't even
properly
labeled representative Klein
Knight thank you chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
and bringing forth this bill I think we
have a major lack of misunderstanding
when it comes to regulating cannabis to
make it safer so it's not laced with
things and would you believe that I am a
medical uh card carrier and this is what
gummies look like it's in the in
medicine bottle would you believe that
that is how they package it there's
labels there's warnings there's not a
bowl of gummies left out and it's
regulated completely there's nothing
added
in uh yes I would believe that I know
that the that that really is the reason
why um some conservatives who don't want
to legalize uh oh don't want to legalize
the use would still Rel legalize the
supply in other words the sale and
possession than the use represent C mind
I we speak privately for a
moment phone
you want me to mute this
sir no I was
[Music]
call
night I do recommend that you turn your
video off
please are we recess Mr chair are we
no testimony is limited one minute per
person members of the public all right
see no hand up anyone of the committee
have a
[Music]
question we thank representative for his
testimony thank thank you representa I
didn't know I didn't know if the
representative was done if he had been
cut
off thank you thank
you ER
pz
yes hi um my name is Erica Barz I'm with
the New Hampshire youth movement and I
am speaking in support of both HB 526
and HB
511 um given that many states have moved
to legalize and are making massive
profits off of cannabis it's unfair to
financially punish other people for it
and a fine for cannabis should not
exceed
$100 um and I believe that there should
be no fine if people are caught with
cannabis so I support this bill because
it minimizes find that they would get
um and as far as uh HP 511 goes one in
seven people are serving time in prison
in New Hampshire for a drug offense the
average cost per inmate is
$35,000 um annually and putting us at
the top the top third in the country for
incarceration
expedent um the state of New Hampshire
has spent too many tax dollars on
imprisoning people and we should be
focusing on Rehabilitation and lowering
fines because fines tend to put people
in a cycle of incarceration because
people cannot afford Their fines due to
um minute sorry my video cut out
um yeah in
conclusion I support these
bills right are there any questions
[Music]
h43 I've seen all people on the list is
there any members of the public oh
I do see three hands uh four hands up
now uh Mr chair um Melissa
Staples yes Melissa
Staples good
afternoon my name is Melissa Staples I'm
the director of the State Police
forensic laboratory and I would like to
address House Bill
511 511 makes the first four convictions
for possession of four grams or less of
a schedule 1 through four controlled
drug a Class B misdemeanor currently a
class B felony just to put this in
perspective one could have more than 100
bags of fentanyl Doses and be under the
4 gram limit or about 80 bags of heroin
doses someone who may be charged with
sale of these items based on the the
number of bags could argue the charges
down to a misdemeanor if there's no
corroborating evidence of a sale for
example I wanted to discuss uh the
impact on the laboratory of this bill
but due to the time limit I'd like to
jump ahead to one thing that I think the
committee needs to be aware of which is
this bill is at odds with HB
615 which has already been heard by this
committee voted all to pass with
Amendment and referred to the house Ways
and Means Committee last week HB 615
also amends the same section of the
control Drug Act RSA 318 b26
section 2A by replacing it with verbage
making possession of no specific weight
of drug a misdemeanor for the first
charge but a class B felony for
subsequent violations so HB 615 and this
HB 511 both aim to amend the same
portion of existing law in different
ways so I wanted to point that out to
the
committee uh and if if you would grant
me more time I could talk a little bit
more about the impact of the laboratory
of House Bill 511 but I want to be
respectful of your
time very much any question from the
committee thank Miss I actually didn't
have a question for you specifically but
I I wasn't able to hear if you were
testifying in opposition or support of
the bill I'm really testifying just from
an informative view uh the department of
safety is does not take any particular
stance um I can tell you from the
laboratory's perspective House Bill 511
does prevent several issues for us from
a resource
standpoint um it would increase
significantly increase for example
prosecutions in District Courts uh I can
tell you when marijuana possession was a
misdemeanor the lab received up to
almost 2,000 subpoenas a year and spent
about 500 hours annually in court that's
about 12 and a half weeks of someone
full-time hours the number of cases a
waiting analysis was was lengthy
turnaround time took quite a long time
we basically were only able to test the
cases we had subpoenas for each month
and that was just with one drug being a
misdemeanor currently with marijana
obession being a misdemeanor a number of
subpoenas and court hours has been cut
by a third now if we add all scheduled
drugs as misdemeanor charges for the
first four offenses that Court
obligation is going to increase
dramatically to meet or even surp pass
those previous levels and that's a
concern for us as a laboratory because
for our analysts are out at court
they're not here testing the drugs and
so that is one uh potential impact on
the laboratory um of house spill 511
should that pass um in addition to added
analyses that need to be performed for
possession
charges
question true have a question thank you
Mr chair thank you uh to the witness for
taking my
question can you tell me where I would
find a listing of schedule 1 through
four control drugs you know I personally
Googled it the DEA certainly has that
list on their website um it's not that
difficult to come across if you if you
simply Google it um essentially schedule
one are things like heroin um LSD
ecstasy schedule two includes fentanyl
uh Aderall
um methamphetamine and those are really
our our top drugs are the
methamphetamine the fentol and the
heroin um schedule one and two Drugs
That's primarily what we see in the
laboratory other question is thank you
Mr J thank you man for taking my
followup and um I don't know how many
when I I will Google that and how many
words am I going to find in those lists
that I can't pronounce like
thuma TR pan there may be quite a
few but as I said uh as far as New
Hampshire goes and and what we're seeing
primarily uh fentanyl's number one uh
methampetamine is number two and the
Pharmaceuticals like the adderal the
rellin uh those types of things are a
number three drug um beyond that cocaine
is further down the list uh but those
three are generally the ones that we see
thank you all right any other questions
from the
committee represent
M thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I not to make you
go back over this again but I I'm not
quite sure that I followed how the
passage of this bill would increase the
work of the lab um maybe one more time
slowly sure absolutely it was freshed as
I said
uh let me explain to you just quickly
quickly but hopefully slow enough um
there's essentially three impacts on the
laboratory that I foresee should House
Bill 511 pass number one uh currently
under current law there's no weight
limit associated with possession charges
if we received a submission of five bags
of a white powder for example we can
test one confirm heroin and be done with
our analysis should this legislation go
through through we would now need to
obtain a total weight of all of the bags
and potentially perform additional
analyses on at least some percentage of
the packets over the course of the
number of requests the lab receives
annually this would increase our work
lob substantially more analysis means
more time for analysts to interpret
results all of this impacts our ability
to keep Pace with the incoming
submissions secondly the one I spoke to
earlier is the time commitment for
District Court appearances
uh our analysts will receive numerous
subpoenas every year and we will always
appear in court um it's not going to be
the thing where you wait and see if we
show up we will be there and oftentimes
once we arrive these court cases tend to
plead out over time the amount of time
spent by analysts going around the state
to court is very impactful on our
ability to perform analyses back here in
the lab if you can imagine that uh and
so when so many more drugs essentially
almost all of our submissions four grams
or less uh could involve a district
court appearance and this can very much
impact uh the laboratory's resources in
terms of personnel um and also the
district courts tend to want a faster
turnaround time and get results because
they're scheduling their cases somewhat
quickly all of those things impact the
laboratory's resources and the final
point is that more analyses needing to
be performed means the instruments that
we have in the laboratory will be more
in
demand uh we may face situations where
our analysts are essentially uh waiting
in line uh to utilize our
instrumentation due to the potential
increases in the analyses that we would
need to perform so the impact on the
laboratory of House Bill
511 you know certainly there's a big
resource impact both in terms of
personnel and Equipment um that would
would happen for the labor
atory thank you very much you're welcome
thank you for the
question you have no other hands
up thank the witness for Testimony thank
you very
much here call Richard head
are you
there there we go um thank you Mr chair
um my name is Richard HED I am the
government Affairs coordinator for the
judicial branch um here to testify with
regard to House Bill
526 this follows up on a a letter I sent
to the committee on the 19th we take no
position on the bill we do ask for an
amendment to the bill however relative
to the effective date which is upon
passage um as I put in my my February 19
letter there's a statute RSA 14 colon
9-a which governs the effective date of
legislation which says that each law
affecting judicial practice and
procedure or establishing or eliminating
criminal prohibitions civil causes of
action or remedies or limitations of uh
of action shall take effect on the
January one following passage we are
asking that the if this bill were to go
forward that the effective date be
modified and amended from upon passage
to January 1
2022 because this bill does affect
criminal prohibitions and uh judicial
practice and procedure the reason for
that and and the reason why that statute
exists I believe is because hundreds of
of um changes are required after each
legislative session to the uniform
charge table to our Odyssey database all
of which tracks um fines tracks how
fines are fine monies are distributed
who receives them what are the criminal
charges the uniform charge table is used
by law enforcement throughout the state
and there are literally hundreds of
changes that are required at the end of
a session they all have to be done very
precisely um because they they drill
down into sections into
paragraphs um and are used throughout
the state to ensure consistent charging
is conducted in in court cases so we we
simply take no position on the bill
itself but ask that it be amended to be
have an effective date of January 1
2022 uh consistent with rsa1 14 colon
9-a Ian with that I would be happy to
answer any
questions any questions Mr
head I see
none thank you very much testimony thank
you thank you all very
much here call Cam
Kenny hi there thank you Mr chairman um
before I start I um I noticed people
were testifying on 511 h511 I'm actually
the prime sponsor so I didn't know if I
should testify because people were
already speaking on behalf of it or the
process there you you may uh just
determine which one you to testify on
and you have one
minute all right um thank you so I'll
I'll introduce 511 thank you chairman um
and my colleagues on the criminal
justice committee my name is
representative cam County representing
straford County District district six
towns of Madbury and Durham which
includes UNH uh I am here to introduce
HB 511 relative to the penalties for
possessions of certain controlled drugs
I worked closely with rights and
democracy on this bill and they will be
testifying today as well um under two A
and B in this bill it aims to defelonize
the possession of personal use amounts
um in this bill 4 ounces or less of
scheduled drugs reclassifying to
misdemeanor B for the first four
convictions for possession after the
first four possessions for schedule one
through four it would be a class a
felony and schedule five would continue
to be uh be class B felony um after the
first four possessions which doesn't
change uh uh two c and d have to do with
marijuana nothing changes um e nothing
changes from current law and F I wanted
to explain um the amendment I know that
members of the committee got an
amendment I wanted to have that prepared
just in case at this time as the prime
sponsor I I um I would prefer it without
the amendment and keep in f um in the
end we want to keep it because we're
basing this off the language that came
out of Colorado rapn was a matter of
special concern because it's sometimes
used to harm other people not always
personal use so for the committee that's
why you had um had that Amendment um why
I sent it in but I do want to keep that
at this point um I know this was touched
upon by a testimony um but the main
difference between um 615 and 511 is
this bill does go further um to give
people who are suffering ample time to
seek help recognizing that this is a
public health issue um so this is needed
because between 1980 in 2016 the state's
prison population increased in size
nearly ninefold and admission to the New
Hampshire prison increased by 24%
according to the ACLU one in seven
people serving time in prison in New
Hampshire are in for drug offenses the
average cost per inmate in New Hampshire
is nearly 35,000 annually putting us in
the top third uh in the country for
incarceration expenditures um and yet a
felony conviction for a drug possession
offense has never decreased drug use
it's only created constant barriers to
future success and paths to recovery I
think we need to shift as a society on
how we treat addiction
stop treating it criminally so
individuals can get the help they can
get um and this bill is a great start so
to conclude I can send in my written
testimony if that's helpful um rights
and democracy and several experts some
who have already spoke some who will um
should be testifying um so please feel
free to direct your questions where you
see fit thank you so much Mr chairman
and members of the
committee representative true thank you
Mr chair and I thank the witness for
taking my question I'm referring to
section F in the Bill yes what is that
drug um I believe it's uh a rufy in
other
words the layman's terms Ro roab thank
you you're
welcome representative I I want to thank
you for your testimony the chair would
like to inquire a question and if you
did answer this in your testimony I I'll
apologize I was not here for the begin
and it's good to hear from
representative in in on page one section
A Lin 8 through 18 it says in case of
possession of four GRS or
[Music]
less is that referring to um all classes
of controlled
substances can you can you say that last
part one more time chairman is that
section that the I would say the bottom
part of section A which is in case of
for grams or less the person shall be
guilty to class be
misdemeanor is that is that section
referring to all classes or all
classified schedules of Controlled
Substances um I believe that one is uh
just one moment Mr sham I believe that
one schedule one through 4 and B to B is
schedule uh
five thank
you see seeing no further hands raised
the witness is excused thank you so much
Mr chairman good to see you as well
[Music]
right good afternoon good afternoon yeah
I'm a little confused about um the way
we're taking testimony is this for both
one both 511 and
526 okay well to one minute if you do
wish to speak on both there will be some
flexibility to discretion with you yes I
would like to speak on both um so yeah
good afternoon the criminal justice and
Safety Committee members my name is Asal
honei and I'm the movement politics
director for rights and democracy New
Hampshire it is a Grassroots
organization that organizes around human
rights issues and today I'll be
testifying using expertise testimony
from our national harm reduction
Coalition associate director Mike celac
who is um personalizing this to New
Hampshire specifically um it says I am
voicing our strong support of HB 511 for
many years now the statement we cannot
arrest our way out of our drug problem
has been used time and time again but
progress towards shifting from a
punitive approach to drugs to a
health-based one is DIY needed HB 511 is
a step in the right Direction by
lessening the criminal legal
consequences people who use drugs face
because of their drug use this bill
would have important and significant
impacts on the cost of incarceration in
New Hampshire it spends
$35,000 annually in incarcerating human
beings incarcerating people who use
drugs for the drug use does not have any
positive impacts on their health or
their drug use the result is wasting
taxpayer dollars a significantly higher
chance of overdose death once someone is
released and a criminal record that
creates barriers to housing employment
and other opportunities that could
actually help people change their lives
imagine what a difference it would make
if we reinvest that money in
evidence-based interventions such as
harm reduction programs overdose
production programs and medications for
opioid use disorder such as bu
buprenorphine and methine these are the
gold standard treatments for opioid use
disorder and cost significantly less per
year than incarcerating someone would
New Hampshire is currently dealing with
a crisis of Overdose deaths overdose has
been the leading cause of accidental
deaths in New Hampshire for many years
the New Hampshire overdose rate is
33.1 per 1,000 in 2018 significantly
higher than the national overdose death
rate of
20.7 thank you for your testimony due to
time distraint we do have the limit
testimony we did allow allow you to
speak for two minutes but we do have to
uh conclude you to time
[Music]
constraints seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excuse the chair the chair now
recognizes
Jason I'll remind witness testimon is
lied to
one yes thank you Mr
chairman how how long do I have to
testify your Tes is limited to one
minute however you to speak
yes thank you Mr chairman um so I am a
licensed clinical social worker and
Master's level drug and alcohol
counselor in the state of New Hampshire
I am a board member of the New Hampshire
providers Association and also a member
of Rights and democracy um so working in
the therapeutic Fields my colleagues and
I have time and again um found the
hindrance of therapeutic process um as
most of the time is being spent
uh dealing with punitive repercussions
of felonies from our clients that we
have been working with um and also uh
time and again countless re research has
shown that punishment of simple
possession charges of drugs uh is just
absolutely zero deterrent for
individuals uh to uh stop using or not
carry uh drugs um and we have found that
there is absolutely zero re itation
happening within these uh Correctional
Facilities um thank
you thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands
raised the witness is
Accused CH I recognizes Jo Jody
Noel hi um thank thank you for allowing
me to be here my name is Jody and uh I
will be speaking to the personal impact
of the criminalization of drugs um 13
years ago my fiance the father of my two
boys overdose just 10 feet away from our
oldest and I on the other side of a
closed door Corey had been through detox
and rehab he was doing what he could to
stay sober in fact it became his
full-time prior priority having lost his
job uh our sole income as the result of
an arrest for possession of heroin he
faced a mandatory minimum prison
sentence based on the quantity and we
all as a family face the threat of the
head of our house old's absence I
believe that unfortunately this threat
was not only unhelpful in dealing with
his addiction it exacerbated his
struggle and contributed to his relapse
and overdose the research is clear those
dealing with substance use disorder need
Compassionate Care they need support
from their Community not isolation from
it drug use and addiction aren't enemies
to be defeated by force but complex
societal and medical problems punitive
measures have only worsened the social
problems causing addiction and overdose
but and their implementation has hurt
countless people not not just those
whose lives have been lost but those who
have been left behind like my sons and I
HB 511 would allow us to redirect funds
toward proven treatment opportunities so
people can recover and stay well the
benefits of doing so would be widespread
and long- Lasting it would allow people
to recover and find work successfully
reintegrate into society support
themselves and their families remain
grounded in their communities and build
a build a future my story Corey's story
is in the past and there's nothing we
can do to change that but I beg you as a
mother not to persist in this failed
approach because the next generation is
at stake thank
you thank you for your testimony uh
seeing No Hands raised the witness is
excused the chair now recognizes elen
Eagleton hi my name is elen Eagleton and
I'm a resident of hover New Hampshire
and I'm a researcher at Dartmouth
College and I study neurotrans that are
implicated in depression and substance
misuse disorder and one in for adults
who do have a mental illness also suff
suffer from substance misuse Disorder so
these um illnesses are commonly
co-occurring so it's important to have
this bill passed because it helps
destigmatize substance misuse um by
decreasing the penalty from a felony to
a misdemeanor um and people who do
experience stigma in regards to their
drug use are less likely to seek
treatment and this results in economic
social and medical costs um so I'd like
to voice my support in the bill um HB
511 thank
you thank you for your
testimony see seeing No Hands
raised witness is excused
[Music]
shair I recognizes Dr Joe
Hannah good afternoon members of the
committee thank you for for listening to
us today uh my name is Joe Hannon um
former State Rep retired doctor and uh
been very active in the recovery and
harm reduction community in New
Hampshire for the past several years um
I'm also a person in long-term recovery
for over 29 years myself uh I can tell
you that having uh this bill pass in
this form would be a big step forward uh
it' be better if it was a little bit
further along but I think that this is a
very good start uh we can't keep
criminalizing people and for felony
offenses for possession amounts uh it's
counterproductive there's no evidence
that proves that it's actually helpful
whatsoever there are many countries
around the world that have death
penalties for possession and they still
have drug use in those countries um you
know someone can't get a college loan
they can't get housing they can't get a
job because of a felony conviction uh we
see someone who's in uh in in in trouble
because of substance use uh and we'll
say why don't they get a job why don't
they go back to school why don't they do
these things they can't once you have a
felony conviction you can't do many of
those things so I think this is
something that's absolutely necessary
the time is long p uh for doing this and
I implore you to please pass this
Bill thank
you representative true thank you Mr
chair and thank you uh representative
for taking my uh taking my question the
bill states that four grams doesn't show
an intent to
sell could you give me an idea of how
much four grams of like fentanyl or LSD
would be what what's the mass of that
what how much is it four
grams I'm not sure I understand the
question mass is that is in MA if you're
asking how much mass is that it's four
so you're asking what does it look like
how many doses is it is I'm I'm not
really sure I
understand recognize for a followup yes
yes it's it's
uh I'm looking for the how many
doses are in four grams of of
fan um good
question uh not exactly sure but I can
look it up
I I don't know you want me to look it up
right
now follow thank you I'm sorry the
witness does not have to look any up to
any the only reason I'm asking is
because I don't know what I'm dealing
with in this bill and so if if four
grams says it doesn't does not show
intent to sell and four grams of LSD
will get uh the whole nation High then
then maybe it does in maybe it is an
intent to sell and I don't know what
what we're talking about when it
says how many doses uh that's why I'm
asking uh fenel is usually measured in
micrograms I can say that um you know
maybe if you want to if if this was such
a big concern uh you know you can
actually have someone look into what
specific
doses are are gotten from a certain gram
amount but
um you know fentanyl is usually in in
milligrams or micrograms sorry thank you
a lot smaller amount four four grams if
you want to just real real General it is
is it is a pretty good amount of
fentanyl to say the
least
100% so just put that in perspective
sorry inter this it's okay what what was
the question now I'm
sorry I'm all set thank you
okay represent
T never mind let me just show you
something I'll
show with drawn see seeing no further
hands raised I want I want thank you for
your testimony the witness is excuse
thank you have a good
day the CH recognizes Ryan
follower great thank you Mr chair and
thank you committee for hearing me today
my name is Ryan Fowler and I'm a person
in long-term recovery I'm also a
Certified Recovery support worker and uh
before I get my minute did you all
receive the letter I sent this morning
that kind of has most of my thoughts in
it there was a letter I sent this
morning with most of these thoughts um
if you did not get it I'd love to get
that to you I'm here as a member of the
public um person in recovery I have
worked for various versions of the safe
stations I help to roll out the doorways
I've worked for the addiction Crisis
Line wraps I trained substance use
professionals and I was kind of one of
the people who were saying that this
bill would be a really good idea it
would simplify the scheduling apparatus
for a simple position profession and
make law enforcement's job easier like
we've seen in other states the idea is
that the scheduling apparatus that you
all keep going back and forth with is
always subjective it's not founded in
science it's oftentimes founded in
targeting certain populations the
current scheduling operatus at the
federal level makes no sense and it
oftentimes translates to the subjective
dispensing of punishment and I'm
somebody who benefited from that I'm a
straight white middle class male from
new h sure I've been arrested with
felony drugs five or six times and I'm
not a felon and because I'm not a felon
I was able to excel in recovery uh in
the past six years I've developed
professionally and I've engaged in
research uh both personally and with
Dartmouth um I've done a lot of really
cool things using my negative experience
for good and I see all too often people
whose felony conviction follows them
forever keeping them from housing
employment um education and it's really
uh contrary to what we know about
substance use disorders because we
Define these disorders as continuing to
use despite negative consequences so the
first offense for a small amount of
drugs should not be a lifetime of a
scarlet letter F that follows them
forever when is time served um I could
answer questions you had about uh the
personal use amounts uh my 10 years of
chaotic drug use included selling I was
in distribution um and because of my
research I've had some interesting views
of um like what's going on now now with
the um current situation and uh moral of
the story is prohibition does not work
punishing people is not the answer to
this and we're really talking about
punishing people and who goes to jail
and who does not really it's about
compassion and human dignity and
treating this like a health issue not a
criminal issue this would support law
enforcement and it's really time to
change what we've been doing we have 100
years of Prohibition we know prohibition
does not work and if you uh I've sent in
a letter you can read the rest I think
my minute's up happy to answer questions
thanks for hearing
[Music]
MEK thank you for your testimony seeing
No Hands
raised the witness is
excused the chair we now recognize
Tristan
[Music]
M hello hello my name is Trist mlan I am
going to speak really briefly on behalf
of Kylie Mardi she is not able to be
here today as she is in the hospital
however she really expressed her
testimony to be heard and i e that
sentiment dear chairman Bradley and
members of the committee I Kylie Mardi
wish to register my support for House
Bill 511 reduce criminal penalties for
simple possession of all control drugs
under four grams from a felony to a
misdemeanor defense I have been a New
Hampshire resident for most of my life I
am writing this to you as a proud woman
in recovery from long-term intravenous
drug use however I cannot think my home
state for any of the outstanding changes
I have made in my life to be honest New
Hampshire has failed me and it continues
to fail sick and suffering let me ask
you would you incarcerate someone with
skizo effective disorder for having
auditory
hallucinations why do we demonize human
beings suffering from substance use
disorder I personally have been
incarcerated for reasons due to my
plight with substance use disorder it
has only made it harder for me to find
recovery our prison systems are flawed I
receive no help for my substance use
disorder while I was within jail I was
only beat down and made the feel
Unworthy of a happy life I signed up for
every AA meeting and none of them ever
showed I searched the bookshelf for
anything that could help me and all I
found was one torn up AA book I listen
the woman cry himself to sleep every
night because they just couldn't
understand why they couldn't stop using
they swore that they would never pick up
again and then they were released out
onto the street with no resources to
allow them to help themselves there is
nobody there telling them that they're
worthy or capable I am one of those
women we cannot stop using
because disorder is a health use issue
and not a criminal issue the very
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again expecting a
different result why do we allow this
Insanity to continue why is change so
scary when it's proven to save
lives institutionalize women for being
outspoken and opinionated you cannot
tell me that there is no room for growth
within our system there are always be a
need for growth and understanding
because our society is ever evolving are
you going to let the ones are you going
to be the ones to make a change are you
willing to help an entire younger
generation get their parents back or you
continue to show them that their
parents' lives are not important because
they're inflicted with an invisible
disease let us be the change thank you
for your consideration sincerely Kye Mii
I also Echo the sentiment of support for
house B 511
any questions from the
committee seeing none we thank you very
much for your testimony thank
you what do we have
left are there any others that you can
see I do not see anyone with their hand
up at this time Mr chair actually we
just had one person pop their hand up uh
Nikki
fordley I will uh and actually we have
we now have three hands up uh I will uh
I'll uh I'll put Miss fordley
on hello uh can you hear me
okay yes okay thank you uh my name is uh
Nikki 40 I am a licensed clinical social
worker and Master's licensed uh alcohol
and drug counselor in New Hampshire um I
work mostly in Manchester I'm testifying
in support of HB 511 today um I helped
put some of it together and did a lot of
the research behind it um I wanted to
answer some of the questions that came
up uh in terms of you know why four
grams how much is four grams what are we
talking about um it depends you know
obviously on the substance but it also
depends on what the tolerance of the
person is I currently work with people
being released from federal
incarceration um I have seen what a
felony conviction does to someone and
re-entry is very very difficult in this
state there are very few resources
available my hands are often tied um but
in working with people who use drugs who
have used drugs for many years um in
fentanyl when they tell me about what
was at the height of their use how much
were they
using I have multiple people who are
using up to 10 grams a day so it really
has to do with someone's tolerance and
what an amount is going to do to one
person is not the same that it's going
to do to another person so we we chose
four grams because we wanted to specify
an amount it is not perfect there's
never going to be a perfect designation
a perfect line but we wanted to create a
line because as it is now where there is
no amount specified you could have the
smallest amount of a controlled
substance and you're automatically a
felon in this state that is wrong um and
I I strongly believe in this bill that
it will be able to help many people
reintegrate into society much easier and
as far as treatment in while
incarcerated versus treatment in the
community treatment in the community
Works treatment while incarcerated is
very difficult especially in times of
the Corona virus there's almost nothing
going
on thank you for your testimony we do uh
we do have time to limit
testimony however you are permitted to
answer questions by members
representative
Newman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question to the witness um
I I realize that there's a difference in
in um substance abuse problems with
alcohol and with drugs and I know they
both difficult but the one with drugs is
probably much more difficult uh could
you make some comments on the the number
of four prior offenses is that not
enough too many and and what your
opinion is of that uh concerning uh a
successful recovery for
someone sure um I I don't know if I
would agree with your statement about
the difference with alcohol and and
substances and drugs um I think we often
make a distinction between the two
because alcohol has been legal for most
of our Lives um I have seen people's
lives completely destroyed by alcohol
and alcohol Alone um in terms of the
four offenses um as I think Ryan Fowler
mentioned we did model this on some
legislation that had come out of
Colorado again recognizing we wanted it
to not be unlimited um but the the
definition of substance use disorder is
continuing to use despite negative
consequences and we didn't feel that a
first time just a one-time deal a
one-time shot made sense that there can
be multiple situations particularly if
people are in the same um social groups
or in the same parts of New Hampshire
the way that policing works you know
there are certain parts of certain
cities that get uh you know people get
picked up more often so we we wanted to
create a line um in terms of it not
being unlimited and we felt that we
needed to at least at least a few
chances where someone would have a
misdemeanor and and you know maybe the
first one is not enough of of the wakeup
call um maybe it's not enough to get
them to think about having something
different for their life um but to have
a couple chances and interactions with
the law and what what that can make that
possible you know the the idea is to
rehabilitate
people and increase their life
functioning and branding them felon does
not help
that thank you for your answer
representative hoer you thank you for
taking my
question I con seeed the uh point about
not making anybody a
felon but um would you believe that a um
somebody who shoots fanol into their arm
is has completely lost control of their
ability to decide and maybe they should
be incarcerated for at least 6 months to
give them a possible chance of breaking
the the bondage that they're
in um I would I would not say
necessarily if someone is using um
fentanyl intravenously that they have
lost all control that is very it's very
different um I
have through different things I'm
involved with with um and I did work for
two years at a methadone clinic um in in
Massachusetts and New Hampshire um so I
I have interacted with many people who
have used drugs recently or currently
use drugs um there are some people that
you would never know if they didn't show
you their arms you would never know um I
think our our conception of what what an
intervenous drug user looks like or
sounds like can be can be very deceptive
and there's a lot of stereotypes out
there um in terms of you know would a
few months six months in jail help
someone find recovery or turn their life
around there are definitely you know
cases that I I've been doing this type
of work for about eight years so I have
counseled thousands of people at this
point Are there specific couple
anecdotal cases I could I could tell you
about where where a jail sentence did
help sure but it's not um I don't think
it is helpful for everybody I have heard
far more cases of people um experiencing
terrible withdrawal that has not been
medicated in jail um also we need to
remember that jails and prisons are not
drug-free spaces um the majority of
people that I am I am counseling now in
my position um people getting out of
incarceration um many of them use drugs
in jail um many I have had people start
drugs in jail in prison um in to cope
with the reality of of being
incarcerated so I I don't think it well
I I wish it were that simple I wish that
we could lock someone up and you know
and okay fine that would work but in
reality that's that's not how it plays
out and if anything the trauma that
people experience while incarcerated can
can comp complicate their drug use and
actually prolong
it thank you seeing no the hands raised
uh the witness is excused I want to
thank you for your
testimony thank you here are the top
search
results CH now recognizes the U the
Bedford New Hampshire police uh just uh
please identify your full name for the
record you're recognized
having technical difficulties the chair
now recognize Anthony
Harris hello thank you chairman you guys
my name is Anthony Harris um pronouns he
his and him um I'm the co-founder of
felon the Freeman
um I'm testifying in support of House
Bill
um I don't see um any reasons that that
an addict should be arrested and
incarcerated um due to their addiction I
don't think that incarceration ever
helps in an addict on the road to
recovery you know I just thinks it takes
away the options that they have on that
road you know um and I want to testify
to the four grams you know an addict
it's more susceptible to be walking
around with four grams from the time
wherever they got the drugs from on
going to where they're going to use this
drug and in that time you know they have
to escape the law you know and um I
don't think it it it's right to
continuously incarcerate our our addicts
who actually just need help and on that
road to
recovery um the ones that are dealing
the drugs aren't the ones that's walking
around the streets with up to four GS
you know um those are the ones that that
um are the ones that that need to be
incarcerated and not the ones that's um
that's actually suffering from from this
addiction Mr Harris we do have to limit
a testimony I believe that time is
expired but I want to thank you thank
you for your testimony all right thank
you Mr chairman have a beautiful day God
bless you God bless you as well
sir the chair now Rec recognizes
Candace Bard and representative Muse
before the witness begins their
testimony I I we managed to have two
witnesses at once if you don't mind uh
seeing if the Bedford police
are are they still okay finish with Miss
Bard and then we'll call
the yeah they are there and they have
their hand
raised M
bashard there we go
all right we'll we'll move on to the
next
witness we'll call we'll call The
Bedford New Hampshire
police yes good afternoon chairman uh
thank you uh for hearing our testimony
and thank you for hearing uh the New
Hampshire Chiefs of police um and the
Chiefs uh in the state of New Hampshire
are opposed to both 511 and HB 526 I'll
be speaking primarily to uh HB 511 today
I have more than 42 years of continuous
law enforcement experience 27 of those
are spent dealing directly with
substance abuse by passing this bill the
Chiefs believe that making possession of
four grams or less of a um or less a
Class B misdemeanor you're effectively
making the possession of enough of a
certain controlled drug sufficient to
kill 100 or more people a Class B
misdemeanor each Street bag contains
enough fentanyl to kill a person the
consequence of this bill when we are
still within the grip of an Insidious
killer fentanyl which is killed more
than 3,000 people in our state with
another killer falling close behind
methamphetamine is potentially
devastating we as a society must be
clear to all those who seek to abuse and
sell drugs that kill that Society does
not contone this Behavior there must be
consequences to possessing killer drugs
you've probably read the tragic story
out of one da where an infant died
because the parents and another person
allegedly were in possession of killer
drugs that resulted in the infant's
tragic deaths in my 40 years I spoken to
hundreds of drug users and drug Sellers
and most of those who survived to that I
spoke with told me that being arrested
gave them another chance at a change an
opportunity uh To Be Drug Free long
enough to reconsider parents have begged
us to have their children arrested so
they'll be in jail away from drugs that
can kill them reducing penalties used
against traffickers is just not the
common sense approach to dealing with
criminals whose only purposes to make
money by selling poison that destroys
lives families and harms our economy in
the future
if you really want to make a change kill
this bill and reinvest in evidence-based
uh drug treatment programs for those in
jail that really work that really work
give them a chance and don't take their
few chances of survival away thank you
for hearing Our
Testimony I want to thank you for your
testimony if if you don't mind that the
chair would just like to inquire of uh
two questions uh just for for the
knowledge of the committee there's a
different schedule
of uh of control drugs can you just
describe just a few drugs that would be
fall in the schedule 1 2 3 or four sure
uh schedule one are those uh control
substances that have no medical value or
use and are highly addictive so uh those
are drugs such as heroin um and other
types of drugs that have no medical
usefulness and are declared by DEA uh to
be highly addictive and dangerous and
should be placed in schedule one
scheduled Two drugs like fentanyl of
course there is a um pharmaceutical and
medicinal use for fentanyl um that um
anesthesiologists use so as an example
fentanyl is placed in schedule two along
with cocaine and derivatives like
lidocaine um things that dentists use
when you go to the dentist um those are
placed in schedule two but schedule Two
drugs are also deemed to have um a
greater risk of of addiction and and
version and misuse schedule three drugs
are those drugs that have medicinal
value and that have a lower risk and
potential for uh addiction and scheduled
for drugs are generally those medicinal
drugs that have no risk for uh addiction
or misuse I hope hopefully that clears
it up for
you thank
you representative
Muse yes thank you for taking thank you
for taking my question I'm I'm just
curious whether HB 511 would in any way
affect your ability to arrest people who
are selling drugs versus simply
possessing them so does it does it does
it do anything that makes it harder for
you uh to enforce the law against people
who are actually selling
drugs well yes and thank you for your
question uh absolutely uh representative
um um for grams of of heroin fentanyl um
are equivalent to 100 Street bags and uh
often times we encounter dealers that
are selling four five 10 15 20 bags um I
can tell you that when various laws
change regarding the possession of
quantities that reduces the penalty for
a threshold quantity what uh traffickers
typically do is reduce uh just below
that that threshold so that if they are
caught then um they simply will face the
the Lesser penalty in this case a Class
B misdemeanor for which in our state
virtually no one goes to jail and pays a
small monetary fine so four grams is a
is an enormous amount when we're talking
about heroin fentanyl methamphetamine um
and some other drugs that kill
people
thank representative
CH thank you Mr chair and thank you
officer for taking my question
um I think you're trying you're helping
me get a a handle on what what the doses
are so so four grams of heroin uh I
believe you said would be 100 Street
bags I'm assuming that a street bag is
one dose so how many doses would a
normal person use in a day well again I
think that you heard previous testimony
that people develop a tolerance a
physiological tolerance to certain drugs
so that it requires over time uh greater
use right so a bag of heroin um
typically runs around quarter gram ten
gram and it all depends on the strength
of that drug that um determines whether
or not that person uses an entire bag a
day um but oftentimes over time an
individual who is using a drug that they
develop a physiological tolerance to
such as heroin will increase has to
increase uh the amount of drugs that
they use so they may incre to several
bags a day uh to be able to avoid being
what we call drug sick um or going into
some withdrawal uh syndrome so um 100
bags uh is is an enormous amount uh
Street sellers uh in Manchester Nashua
and other places of the country
typically sell 10 20 30 40 bags um a
less 100 bag dealer is a significant
dealer than you
representative Colley thank you Mr
chairman and thank you sir for taking
the question am I right this discussion
around trafficking I think that's sort
of separate from the attend of the bill
but um am I right that current
statute
um offers a lot of discretion to
prosecutors around
weighing um circumstances of a case to
determine what to charge someone with so
the it sounds like this bill is more
about possession and we've
gotten off on a discussion of
trafficking so am I right in that um
there are ways to discern between
trafficking and possession for personal
use well yes there is and and you're
right that prosecutors and the Judiciary
take into account um that information
and and I think this bill is attempting
to fix a problem by creating a problem
and um that goes directly to U what what
your question is and thanks for your
question I think that what this bill
would do is effectively uh eliminate an
opportunity for law enforcement to deal
with drug traffickers uh drug users as
you rightly know in many cases
throughout the state and many counties
go to drug court um because they are
typically in possession of uh personally
use quantities of drugs and so they are
diverted into Drug Fort system um the
people that I talk with um over the
course of my 40 Years of police work
tell me time and time and time again yes
yes there are there drugs in jail sure
there's drugs in jail but oftentimes
when they're in jail it gives them time
to reflect a time to think about um and
gives them another chance to um consider
where their life's trajectory is going
what where we fail is making sure that
we provide those folks who do end up in
jail because oftentimes drug users don't
end up in jail they end up in jail after
failing drug court two or three times
and then they end up in jail let's make
sure that when they do go to jail and
they're a substance abuser no matter
what the substance is that they're given
an evidence-based treatment program
that's where we need to
be thank
you representative
Newman thank you Mr chair and thank you
to the W witness for taking my question
um we've had some discussions and we
talk about going to jail and I know that
felonies mean that you go to prison um
what's your experience for people that
are first offenders and they get the
benefit of whatever the judicial system
does for them that people actually go to
county jails and have get are able to be
successfully rehabilitated
there thank you for your question and in
my experience again when we're talking
about uh personal use quantities of
drugs that are not to the level that
we're talking about in this bill in 511
those folks again are it into drug court
um there often times prosecutors know
that these folks um who are involved in
shoplifting let's say that we see in
property crime that end up in domestic
violence cases that have an underlying
substance abuse problem we work very
hard in law enforcement to get those
people into the types of programs that
they need but the Leverage is um that if
they don't complete or they don't put
their shoulder to the grindstone with
respect to a treatment program that the
government has leveraged to exert
control so that the individual is forced
into and hopefully forced into an
evidence-based treatment
program followup Mr chairman represent
Newman you recognize for a followup yes
sir um so that would they still have
leverage if in fact that the penalty was
was one that would not put them in state
prison uh no because there's no there's
no incentive uh there is no incentive
for or someone to who's facing a Class B
misdemeanor to follow the law because
oftentimes we see that they don't
because they know that effectively a
Class B misdemeanor um results in no
jail time and usually maybe in a low um
Financial crime or fine so uh in order
to make sure that people do what the
government wants Society not government
Society wants them to do which is um get
better um and treat the problem
uh in often cases we need that leverage
to make sure that the individual follows
through thank you thank
you see no further hands raised the
witness is excused I want to thank you
for your
testimony thank you if there are any
members of the public who have not
testified
already
that uh wish to speak please raise your
hand
leoy I got that right yes bki thank you
so much for uh giving me an opportunity
to speak my name is Leo bitki I'm uh on
faculty of the law school and school of
health sciences at North Eastern
University just
south uh of New Hampshire in Boston and
I just wanted to say a few words about
um uh my my research focuses on the
overdose crisis
and the legal and policy measures to
address it and we've done a lot of
research on laws such as this um we
broadly term them drug induced homicide
laws or uh drug delivery resoling death
laws uh throughout the United States
these laws have been proliferating in
response to the overdose crisis um for
many of the reasons that folks have
flagged um and uh We've evaluated their
impact from a public health perspective
so obviously there's different reasons
to you know pass laws like this such as
uh you know victim's rights rationale
and kind of Retribution rationale but
from a public health perspective um
we've looked at the impact of these laws
and found that generally as a public
health measure they do not um they're
not effective in addressing overdose um
so even just uh looking at the numbers
uh states that have passed similar laws
do not see overdose
uh decrease they actually see typically
uh increases in overdose on uh the uh
amount of about 7 to
10% and the uh mechanisms for this uh
you know we can only posit that uh some
of the ways in which laws such as this
uh may increase overdose is the
following so one of the ways in which um
they may be counterproductive
is do have to is a uh the testimony is
limited to one minute You' almost
reached two minutes so I do have to
suspend the testimony however you the
witness will be permitted to answer
questions representative Hopper thank
you Mr chairman um thank you uh for
taking my question how can they be um
the last statement
was how how can they be
counterproductive so yeah I apologize
that I uh wasn't aware of the time limit
but um they're counterproductive in in
uh several ways one um we know that many
of the overdoses that are witnessed um
help is not summoned and the person ends
up dying um one of the reasons why to
top reason based on surveys why people
don't summon help is because of legal
repercussions and when a law such as
this is passed um the public awareness
that a lot of um that that gets uh sort
of affected in terms of public media
outreach and prosecutors talking about
these laws is people get uh those legal
concerns get aggravated and people are
not uh motivated to seek help during an
overdose event so that's that's one of
the
ways um I can I can keep going I don't
know how much time I have but Newman you
recognize for a
question thank you Mr chairman uh your
last comment it seems like most of your
research had to do with preventing
overdoses and um did you uh have you has
your research addressed the the question
of people that referencing that towards
trying to provide successful recovery
opportunities to
people representative I think that's a
really important question I as was
mentioned I think uh it was a uh the
witness who had talked about the uh
importance of um giving folks access to
evidence-based drug
treatment and uh we know that
unfortunately in New Hampshire as in
many other places um such treatment is
is typically not available for people
who are incarcerated so um to the extent
that people get um incarcerated based on
these laws as well as others uh for drug
dealing a lot of those folks are
actually using and have addiction issues
and what happens is they go into the
criminal justice system they do not
receive treatment and when they uh are
released they overdose and die at really
high rates so we know that the rate of
Overdose among people who had been
incarcerated is about um 120 to 130
times the background rate in the first
six weeks after
incarceration thank you for your
answer thank you
No Hands raised witness is
excused excuse me representative
board thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
for taking my
question as we heard earlier um uh
having the uh the penalty of a felony
over their heads are one of the reasons
that people uh uh go to drug
court and I think New Hampshire's drug
court uh has a fairly successful uh uh
ratio so if we redu got rid of the
felony uh penalty do you think that uh
we would still have that kind of
success representative I think this is a
really important question I I I think
that it is absolutely critical to have
uh a drug court system that provides
access to um uh evidence-based
scientific treatment and New Hampshire
has made great great strides in that
direction I think though it's also
really critical to have access to um
such treatment on demand in a community
in other words um in addition to
improving the way in which the criminal
legal system deals with people with with
addiction we need to have other
opportunities for people to access
treatment that is free and on demand and
as as low barrier as possible um in my
view forcing people into treatment um
and this is not actually my view this is
based on on scientific research there's
a a concept called intrinsic motivation
which is that a person needs to want to
get help and that's when treatment works
best and so providing opportunities for
people to access treatment when they're
ready and willing to do so is the best
chance that we have for people to find
recovery whereas to uh do so through
through
coercion um is not as effective and
sometimes uh the the failure rate is
high much higher in those circumstances
so uh to your question I don't think
that um sort of increasing the penalties
that hang over people's heads is the way
to go I think the way to go is to invest
in a variety of Pathways as many as
possible to get folks help when they
need
it recn
follow thank you CH thank you for taking
my question um you may have realiz may
not realize we just passed a bill
615 who which really uh allows uh the
first uh offense for simple possession
of any drug to be a uh
misdemeanor but further uh uh
convictions become felonies so if we use
the uh first offense as incentive to uh
have people seek treatment but they refu
they do they fail to and their the
second time they are faced with a felony
then we are
basically uh forcing them into a uh drug
court
situation now question Both
Worlds I I mean I'm a big believer thank
you for the question I'm a big believer
in just uh you know all all possible
doorways as many as many different paths
as possible for people to get assistance
and support um you know I I I don't want
to comment on the sort of the priorities
of the legislature and and the I have
not read the bill that you cited I
apologize um I I think that making
treatment available through the drug
court system is a really important
priority and I I certainly support um
doing so for felony charges as well as
mruna charges I will cite some research
from um that came out last year from
Philadelphia where they looked at
treatment Court um outcomes so they what
they did is they uh essentially did a
retrospective review of everyone who had
overdosed in Philadelphia for the year
I think it was
2017 and they assessed whether or not
where were the touch points where did we
miss an opportunity for that person who
had overdosed and they found that um
about 80% of the folks who had overdosed
had a contact with the criminal legal
system at some point over the last 18
months so there's a lot of missed
opportunity um in in in Philadelphia the
their treatment Court was narrow had
narrow eligibility requirements that did
not allow folks who were repeat
offenders or had a violent um offense or
other kinds of considerations they'
eliminated eligibility for those people
and so it sounds like what New Hampshire
is doing is it it is using those
eligibility CR criteria widely and not
kind of eliminating the opportunity for
people with more serious offenses to get
access to treatment and I think that's a
really important lesson that we have to
learn is that you know it's not just a
low-level and sort of firsttime offenses
in fact many people who have serious
addiction issues have a really serious
record and that doesn't mean that they
can't find recovery it just means that
we need to expand our thinking as far as
who is eligible who can benefit from
these kinds of
resources thank you
see no additional hands raised the
witness is excused want to thank you for
your testimony thank
you MERS of the public if you have not
spoke already and your hand is not up
please raise your hand now if you wish
to
speak seeing No Hands raised we will now
close the public hearing on House Bill
511 and
526 this time we are open the public
hearing on House Bill 603 relative to
manaugh and the use of deadly force and
circumstances involving the sale or use
of a control drug or control drug analog
in uh house bill
prohibiting sorry I My Own St on victim
actual or perceiv gender gender identity
gender expression or sexual orientation
from being used as offense of
manslaughter
you want to do the honors for the prior
hearing yeah why don't uh I'll do that
um so for HB 526 there were 72 people
who signed in in support and six people
who signed in in
opposition for HB
511 there were 197 people who signed in
in support of the bill and five who
signed in in
opposition represent answer your
question uh we are we are we have now
opened the public hearing on House Bill
603 and House Bill
238 yes and to the members of the public
testimony will be limited to one
minute the exception will be for the
representative who introduced es
the
bills Representative
Vincent Representative
Vincent I know he's aware I believe
Vincent you you recognized to introduce
House Bill
63 thank you Mr chairman can you hear me
yes we can thank you Mr chairman and
thank you honorable members of the
criminal justice committee uh for the
record my name is Kenneth Vincent and I
am a state representative and I serve
District 17 which is uh dover's uh Ward
five and six and Summers R ward two I'm
here today before you as the prime
sponsor of House Bill uh
603 uh this is a bill that is going to
enhance the self-defense statute 627
semicolon
4 you're going to hear
testimony sorry you're going to hear
testimony from one of my constituents
Art Williams who is a retired detective
uh with more than 20 years of service uh
from the suers police department who is
currently a private investigator
representing Donna Barrett a mother who
lost her son back in 2017 in a drug deal
where he was killed Donna Barrett is
also here today to testify so basically
in short uh I want to add
um I'm trying to add to the law so drug
dealers are not protected and here's an
example so if I want if I went to a drug
dealer's house to buy
drugs and something went down and I was
killed at that person's house then they
could actually go off scotf free uh from
the current
law um and what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to make them accountable
uh for their actions here um and I think
to I think that um uh I would love if I
could turn it over um to Donna Barrett
the mother of the the mother of the son
that was lost
um and Mr chairman we are all here in
the same room using the same computer uh
I would I would beg you if you could
please allow uh Donna to talk and then
um Art Williams uh it would definitely
uh make the the line and the pattern
here uh very clearable if that's
possible we we can accommodate that
Representative Vincent the only thing I
asked is that for each
member for each each witness that is in
with you to have them State their full
name U for the record is whether they're
in
support in opposition of the bill just
so for clarification purposes of the
clerk that's not going to be a problem
I'm GNA turn it over to Donna Barrett if
I just may ask question the chair May
inquire
representa yes I'm sorry Mr chairman go
ahead if there's any questions I want I
want to first thank you for your
testimony and thank you for taking my
question you you testified or or
suggested it was a self-defense bill
that uh this would enhance can you you
mind just
repeating that that RSA you referring to
yes it is going to be
RSA 627 semicolon
4 thank you very much you're welcome
representative Cy may I ask a question
of the representative she's willing to
entertain you recognized to ask a
question thank you Representative
Vincent um for coming before us today
having this over um is it is my
understanding correct
that this would U remove in in cases
involving uh drug
transactions it would make it so that
the seller of the drugs would not be
able to claim
self-defense if there is some sort of
altercation and deadly forces use it's
the act of the dealing of or the sale of
drugs that hinders the
self-defense
um justification am I right and that's
that's what this bill would
do thank you for your uh question
representative Conley uh yes I'm
believing that's what it what it would
do um so I I think that you know I think
that the real uh expert here is um going
to be uh former detective or retired
detective um uh Art Williams uh he was
my constituent when he came to me uh in
this matter and um I think he would
really be the one uh to ask that
question to but I do believe uh that uh
that's right this would not protect uh
the the drug dealer um let's face it um
like I said before if um if I'm a drug
dealer and I have several people coming
to my house and I'm selling drugs from
my
house and say that's 20 people 30 people
in in in two days and something goes
wrong and as a drug dealer uh in my
house I killed a person uh because I
didn't like what was going on in this in
this illegal
sale uh I just think that that would
protect the drug dealer um that's that's
how I feel and that's what this that's
what this is all about about this bill
is thank you
representative thank you for your thank
you for your question representative
Conley Representative Vincent and the
the next r with you yes the next uh
person to testify will be Donna Barrett
and she is going to be in favor of the
bill she can tell you that herself hang
on and and Miss bar we do have to limit
testimony to one minute per
witness I I did I wasn't ble to hear
that question just just a reminder that
we do have to limit testimony to one
minute uh per witness okay um my name is
Donna Barrett I'm a resident of the town
of Dover I am in support of this of
House Bill 603 and its amendment I want
to thank the chair and Ken Vincent and
all the members of the committee for
allowing me to speak um I want to begin
and tell you a little bit about my
son uh I want you to know that this just
doesn't come from me as his mother but
how other people have described him to
me um Michael was easygoing he was
thoughtful and generous he was
constantly doing things for
others I want to give you a few example
of remembrances people had told me if
you were moving and this was a true case
scenario uh everybody else bails out on
you doesn't want to come and help you
move my son would be the one to come and
help you move no matter how difficult or
unpleasant the job was I'm sorry a
friend of of his came to me and told me
that there was a time when he needed
baby formula he wasn't able to pay for
it my son helped him to pay for it and
they bought the formula together he also
told me that my son had expressed how he
wanted to have a child one day another
person came to me and told me when he
was the new kid in school and although
this is back in high school you know how
it feels when you're the new kid and my
son would be the first to say hello and
befriend him and he remembers it after
all these
years these are just few examples of how
Michael touched people's lives and I
know I can't go on but there are many
more so now I have to go on and talk to
you about why I think House Bill 603 is
so important along with the amendment
because my son Michael was brutally
murdered by a drug dealer after he was
sold cocaine my son was 22 at the time
I'm going to give you a sequence of the
event a person arranged a
sale um and brought Michael to the drug
dealer's house and left him there
cocaine was delivered to the Dealer's
house a short time before Michael
arrived Michael and the drug dealer
ingested
cocaine after a while an altercation or
some sort of disturbance occurred
Michael was stabbed to death by the drug
dealer Michael sustained multiple stab
wounds a compound fractured to his leg
one for trauma to his head and many
other injuries and contusions only
Michael the drug dealer in the drug
dealers room were at the house the Time
Michael was killed the drug deal and his
roommate sustained no
injuries I I would also like to tell you
about the 911 call at this time and I
would like to give my support to the
amendment to the 911 in Michael's case
the drug dealer and his roommate had the
opportunity to call 911 but they delayed
they never called for M and only
reluctantly called for the police the
911 caller was described by Dispatch as
hostile and
uncooperative when police arrived
Michael was found unconscious and with
no pelts the police had to call for
EMS Michael's life could have been saved
if the drug dealer and the roommate had
not delayed in calling 911 and requested
an ambulance the 911 call was neither
timely or made in good faith and my son
lost his life
under current law no charges were
brought against anyone in this case two
people were involved in Michael's
death and three people involved in the
cocaine deal under Michael's law
everyone in the cocaine sale could have
been held culpable I asked you if this
was your son What charges would you want
brought against the people
involved my son was not perfect he was
buying cocaine that night but he was a
good person
he didn't have to lose his life that
night Michael loved life and he loved
his
friends and family he had hopes and
goals for the future and I know he would
have achieved those and fulfilled those
we love him and we miss
him I'm cading with
you as a mother to support House Bill
603 in its 911 Amendment our sons and
daughters are dying at an alarming rape
due to the direct actions of drug
dealers in the secondary effects of the
drugs they sell drug dealers are
committing crimes and they need to be
sent a clear message knowing that they
will be held
accountable House Bill 603 and its
Amendment would bring some justice to
Michael's death and I believe it would
help other families who find themselves
in the same situation being the person
Michael was I know we would have wanted
this to happen and in honor of my son
and in his memory I would like it to be
called Michael's law and I sincerely
thank you very much for allowing me to
tell my story in support of House Bill
603 in its
Amendment thank thank
you thank you M for your testimony thank
you you have the I believe I speak whole
committee and sorry for your lost thank
you m Mr chairman this is our
Representative Vincent again um I
understand that the that the members may
have questions for Miss Barrett uh and
that's fine and then I would respect if
uh detective or retired detective Art
Williams would speak after yes and I I
don't believe any members have their
hands raised so the witness Miss Barett
is excuse me representative Newman you
recognize for a
question thank you Mr chair I think I'm
unmuted can you hear me yes hear you
yes okay my my question is is there any
one of the witnesses that could respond
uh just to clarify um how why the
charges were not brought and how or if
they were maybe I'm not sure of that and
if how that relates to
[Music]
I can probably answer
that thank you
um your name Arthur Williams retired
Detective from Summers
Warth if if I just may recognize the
witness represent I believe the if I
just overheard the
conversation the police detective maybe
more able to answer that question for
you I just I need for the I do need to
recognize the the detective first
detective please state your name U the
record whether you are testifying in
support or opposition the
bill I'm in support of the bill my name
is Arthur
Williams to answer your question on the
deadly
force this case in point that you just
heard was ruled by the Attorney
General's um a justifiable homicide
which is kind of the foundation for the
bill because um the me and the AG claim
that the deceased suffered
um they call it something different what
is it excited excited delirium I always
get that wrong I always call it cocaine
psychosis but they said that his violent
behavior um precipitated the deadly
force the violent Behavior was caused
according to them by the cocaine
ingestion that's why in the manslaughter
proposal that we have um we've included
that section I don't know can you see
this what the proposal is no might
Representative Vincent if I may
interrupt is there an amendment that is
being referenced and if so has been sent
to the
committee I'm sorry Mr chairman can you
say again please I heard a reference to
an amendment if you few times is there
an amendment to uh house B3 that is
being referenced there is an amendment
uh that was brought on by representative
uh Reed Ellen Reed um she brought it on
last week
um uh it's Amendment
um and it is um you you have it you
should have it uh in your possession
because it was uh stamped by uh legis
the uh
L uh
services do you mind just forwarding
that to the members of the committee I
saw a thumbs up over there and can you
also forward it to the committee
assistant and have her print out a copy
for the members of the room okay do you
want that to happen right now
representative Muse I believe will be
able to assist us with that and uh we
will let um we'll let the detective
continue this testimony sorry
interrup okay
thank you Mr chairman Arthur Williams
back um I was answering the question
that
was um proposed is that answer
sufficient yes I I think that's a good
answer I I just didn't understand I'll
have to just check that's fine thank
you is there any more questions from
Miss barren
detective uh this representative abis
the chair of the committee I do I want
to thank you in advance for taking
question uh when I when I read uh
subsection C it it had the sale the
transfer injection or
inest and I I understand the sale to be
it
says if it if it's directly or
indirectly related uh to the sale
transer I when I was reading this I
anticip my anticipation was obviously
not not correct but I was anticipating
this had to do where someone would maybe
pass away from
overdose uh
would which is not the case that
obviously the examp provide to us I'm
just asking would that section apply to
overdose section uh overdoses as
well
yes thank you
see have
testimony in detective if you wish to
provide any testimony I know you answer
the question to start we allow you one
one minute okay um there's three parts
to the proposal when we were looking at
Barrett case we were looking at some of
the deficiencies in the laws and
Representative Vincent had touched on it
before that deadly forces the proposal
would be that deadly force is not not
authorized in the sale of a controlled
drug by either the buyer or the seller
so that
if any drug activity goes on in a house
um that negates any deadly force because
the violence that surround some of those
drug
deals um I can only imagine what the
consequences would be without
it in some of these cases the other
Amendment or proposal that change the
language was in the
um under the 318 the drug
statutes
would make somebody strictly liable for
the death Andor the conduct of
another um I think we just heard about
the case in London der where the young
baby got a hold of some Fentanyl and
passed away parents have been
charged um person who delivered fenel
could be charged as well under this I
think
that's
um not
inconsequential we're averaging over 400
deaths a year for
overdose that's 800 parents a year that
are looking for
answers um some of these
proposals I think have been
long in the coming I
retired from active duty in 200 7 and
I've just seen from the sidelines the
drug
crisis thank
you thank you Mr chairman of the
committee thank you thank you for your
testimony representative Marson you
recognize for a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you detective for
your
testimony I'm confused about the whole
situation who initiated the altercation
that ended up in the death of the young
man do we know we do not know because
the only two people who lived through
the altercation gave conflicting
stories so the truth we don't know
thank you
I'm representative TR thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
I I believe I believe I heard you
testify that um under under the bill
that we have before us it also includes
overdoses my question
is if a now without Before the bill as
as the law is is now if a drug
dealer gave somebody drugs they
overdosed and died is not the drug
dealer responsible for that overdose
now they
are is the proposed change to the
language says the death Andor conduct of
another is
defined which results in the injection
so
I guess what we're seeking
is um it's kind of like the the bar that
over serves the patron who goes out and
kills somebody
else the conduct of
another so if somebody becomes under the
influence of a controlled drug goes and
kills somebody else whoever supplied
that drug is
liable that's the easy way
explain
it for follow up thank you thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
again
so when the conduct causing the death is
directly or indirectly related so if a
drug dealer were to sell somebody some
heroin and a few days later that person
uh had a bad reaction to heroin and kill
somebody this bill would drug dealer
responsible for what happened two or
three days later I think there's a 12-h
hour limit imposed on that
conduct you recognize the follow I I I'm
and where was that where is that where
was the 12h hour limit
where where is it
written is it not written on the it's
not written on here I think it had been
written on here and I think it got
removed oh I'm sorry it's apparently has
been removed that was the um the
original idea was it was a 12-h hour
limit so there wouldn't be any confusion
as
to like the proposal that you said the
situation that you
mentioned thank you
representative
tman thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um as I understand it
here tell me if I'm right if if a drug
dealer sells drugs he basically has
essentially product
liability for as long as that those
drugs are in use and and in good be held
liable this is for manslaughter if that
person causes or or you dies of
manslaughter is that correct it's
correct good to me representative Conley
thank youman thank you detective um this
is I guess a follow up on my own
question because I'm still this commit
to dealt with RSA
674 a lot this term and I'm still a
little bit uncertain
about how this proposal affects that
bill and I wonder if the detective or
the timee sponsor can offer some clarity
I hope I'm not coming up the work with
this question I'm still not sure what's
proposed and what
do it just add to
it sorry I didn't quite get the question
I'm having a hard time
hearing detective I'm going to try to
communicate the question on behalf of
Representative col please representative
call give me a thumbs up or thumbs down
if I do not cap intent of your question
I believe representative coling was
asking whether how would this uh Bill
House Bill
63 change or impact the use of force
under RSA
627 home 4
specifically involved the use of deadly
[Music]
for I think that I could best answer
that this is Representative Vincent if
you would allow me Mr
chairman so yes so uh you know I
understand that we're talking about the
standard ground law and I understand
that when you talk about stard ground
law everybody gets all nervous about it
I just want to let you know that this
bill is in no way wants to change and I
don't want this bill to change standard
ground law at all what I want to do is I
wanted to
add the
non-protection of an illegal act such as
a drug dealer because if a drug dealer
is dealing
drugs what are the chances of I get
something that I don't like and I am uh
not happy with what I have and then then
then or the drug deal is mad at me and
then he kills me and then claim stand
your
ground I believe in stand your ground
that a king or a queen is their castle
and anybody to go in there I shouldn't
have to
retreat however under a drug sale
activity
that's all off in my
opinion um but I am for stand your
ground but I just think if you're doing
a drug deal activity with is a mind
altering substance use uh a sale of an
illegal drug uh I don't think uh that's
uh a robbery it could be robbery too and
then the person that they're robbing
that went to their house kills the
person and then there's there's no
ground to stand on I just um I just find
that uh you know I understand that as
lawmakers we try to think of every
Avenue however sometimes we we don't get
it all right and we come back to it like
we are I think today and I I really
respect and appreciate you uh letting me
answer Mr chairman Representative
Vincent the chair would have requireed
one additional question I hope I didn't
exceed my limitation of two questions
uh just correct me about when I always
look at the the standard
ground protection under 6 RSA
6274 that often implies that the uh
person inside their home or standing
their ground is
not committing any type of illegal act
of their own they are they have Clean
Hands per se I'm not sure if that's
clearly written in that
RSA but is the spirit of what is trying
to be accomplished is to basically if
some you don't want someone using RSA
627 4 to basically create a c use the
castle doctor inside their home to
facilitate a
drug that is
correct
question you
recogniz thank than you Mr chair I don't
know if this is a followup to my
previous question or my second question
but anyway I've also looked at that
paragraph and has spent a lot of time
pretty much looking at
6274 and I believe that the new
paragraph because this is a completely
new paragraph prohibits the use of
deadly force in in those kinds of
situations and I think that it also does
not limit it to your own own Dem
domicile I believe that that could be
done anywhere so that's just my opinion
of the bill and I'm wondering if the
witnesses might or the prime sponsor
might think that that's appropriate
understanding thank you
um Mr chairman did you want us to answer
that I believe it was a a question by
representative Newman the which the
amendment is now being passed out um but
you may respond to represent Newman and
I'm going to let if you if you so uh if
you so desire I'll let uh the Detective
Williams answer that question yes the
prior chair of this committee who I have
a lot of respect for who I sered with
last term did allow when we were meeting
in person more than one witness to sit
at with the sponsor of the bill so this
is perfectly fine to kind of interchange
thank you very much Mr chairman we
appreciate that um in answer to your
question
the proposed law change would make
deadly force unauthorized anywhere if it
involved the use sale possession
anything to do with controlled drugs
so it's whether it's in a home
and in public any place um it would just
negate the
self-defense
because violence surrounding the illegal
drugs is sale and possession of is not
authorized
anywhere and thank you very much for
that answer that comported with what my
opinion of what that paragraph was
saying thank you thank
you see seeing No Hands
raised I want to thank the
representative as well
as the testimony could Mr chairman one
more time I apologize there is another
individual that was kind of part of this
group uh his first name is Bill I'm not
sure I'm thinking that you'll see him on
your screen uh he wants to talk towards
the amendment part uh we I'm not sure if
his last name is involved because
there's an ongoing
case uh with um his daughter who passed
away in December uh if you see I would
uh beg you to to CH to pick Bill to talk
more on the
amendment well represent vinon when that
person is called we will be sure to
recognize that
individual thank you Mr
[Music]
chairman seeing no further hands raised
I want to again thank the Representative
Vincent
the two witnesses for their testimony
for taking our
questions in respect to House Bill
238 is there a representative that is
intending on introducing
that representative
AB looking for someone to introduce to
Mr chairman I believe the prime sponsor
is present for
238 thank you
represent representative
Joshua you recognized to introduce uh H
238 uh thank you uh good afternoon Mr
chair and honorable committee members my
name is Josh query I represent
Manchester's ward nine Hillsboro 16
uh I'm here to int today to introduce
House Bill
238 I'm introducing this bill because
the gay Panic defense is a legal
strategy that asks a jury to find that a
victim's sexual orientation or gender
identity expression is to blame for
defendant's violent reaction including
murder what we've seen around the
country is that this discriminatory gay
Panic defense is used successfully to
excuse the murder of members of the
lgbtq plus Comm
Community this is a bipartisan Bill to
ensure that this type of Defense can
never be used in New
Hampshire let me begin with what this
Panic defense means when a perpetrator
uses an lb lgbtq plus Panic defense they
are claiming that a victim's sexual
orientation or gender identity not only
explains but excuses a loss of
self-control and the subsequent assault
this is currently allowed under New
Hampshire law
this bill HB 238 will ban the use of a
panic defense on the basis of someone's
gender identity actual or perceived
gender gender expression or sexual
orientation someone's mere existence as
an lgbtq plus person does not constitute
a reason or provocation to commit
manslaughter the American Bar
Association opposes the use of gay Panic
defense and since 2013 has called for
local local state and Federal
legislatures to curtail the availability
of this
defense let me be clear this bill does
not dismiss traditional self-defense
lawsuits and does not deny existing due
process defenses this means lgbtq plus
people would not be immune from
prosecution should they be accused of a
crime if passed New Hampshire will join
12 other states in Washington DC in
Banning this type of defense and join
eight other states who are considering
similar
similar legislation this year including
Virginia Which just passed this
legislation is now going to the
governor's desk for our state we would
be proactive in protecting individual
rights by barring this
defense nationally one out of five hate
crimes are committed against lgbtq plus
people to put this in New Hampshire's
context in our state 5% of granite
Staters identify as lgbtq plus the
equival equalent of 60,000 people this
is not a small
constituency our state values personal
freedom and our state also ranks very
high in
lgbtq
protections over the past year I have
had multiple citizens from across New
Hampshire ask me to sponsor this
legislation some are members of the
lgbtq plus Community who fear this law
would excuse their murder but mostly
I've heard from people who have friends
or family members who are gay and have
seen this Panic fence used play out in
other states and do not want to see the
same happen here this legislation will
be correcting an oversight that is
needed to Grant the lgbtq plus people of
New Hampshire the security that this
cannot be used against them and their
loved ones thank you for your time and I
welcome any questions I will say that uh
we do have someone from the national bar
who can answer more of the specific
legal questions
thank you representative uh for your
testimony representative green thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question could you tell me what the
eight states are yes I can um so
Virginia uh
Vermont um
Massachusetts and uh sorry I'm just
pulling up that list right
now Florida
is also on
[Music]
there and I apologize
uh New Mexico and Oregon in
Maryland thank you
[Music]
I can I can email my testimony and it
does have those lists on there for your
guys' records representative you mind
just repeating the eight states one more
time so the CL can
uh of course um I also mixed up a few of
the ones who already have it legal so
that might have been my bad so they are
Florida Iowa
Maryland
Nebraska uh New
Mexico Oregon and Vermont and then
Virginia who just passed
thank
you representative Maron thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question the other states that have this
on the books are we writing
our uh House Bill exactly as they have
it yes um so we looked at uh all of the
other Bill uh States who have it
currently and we used theirs as a basis
um OS did have um a few things that made
it New Hampshire specific including that
last line in section
A thank
you representative
bord thank you chair uh thank you for
taking my question um you say you are
putting this as an excuse not
for
defense is it how is it a defense
today yeah I think I understand your
question um So currently someone can uh
if someone committed murder um in a kind
of a against an lgbtq person they could
say that they were acting in a moment of
insanity brief Insanity because of that
person's identity um and then they can
use it as a p that that was a panic um
and that's why they they committed that
crime so this would just ban
it representative
tman thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um how many instances have we had of
peoplee
using as a
defense that they found out
inadvertently that person was part of
this
community here in New
Hampshire So currently New Hampshire has
never used this
defense represent CH you recognize her
fall followup question thank
you well Nationwide
how many instances are there life
FS um unfortunately too many for me to
count off the top of my
head how about
now um I'm not Ure of the of the number
I would believe you know probably over
cases representative I want to thank you
for your testimony just inquire u a
question and I want to thank you in
advance for taking my question uh when
you referring to saying a defense um are
you suggested that rather rather than
fall in the manslaughter it would be
second degree
murder yeah I believe in that case yes
it would it would no no longer be um
murder but yeah just follow the second
defense thank thank thank you for taking
my
questions seeing No Hands raised I want
to thank the representative for his
testimony thank
you the chair now recognizes William
Waters and just a reminder Mr water your
testimony is limited to one minute time
restraint I actually um I was trying to
get in on house build 603 and I was
having a little technical difficulty but
can I still um keep my comments yes you
may but we we are the public hearing for
both House Bill 603 and House Bill 238
are being heard simult so you may okay
so I'll try to make it brief I thank you
very much to the chair and the members
for the opportunity to speak on this
matter um my name is William Waters I
live in Guilford New Hampshire and I'm
speaking today in support of the
proposed amendment to house Bill
603 specifically um section 2D uh which
says a person is guilty of manslaughter
when such person causes the death of
another by failing to request medical
assistance for another person under
circumstances where the actor knew or
should have known that such person was
in need of medical assistance in our
situation here on December 12th 2020 the
light went out of our Lives when our
daughter died of a suspected opioid
overdose she was accomplished um
awardwinning costomer um she was 29
years old and she had accomplished so
much in her life and was looking forward
to um many new uh Adventures she was a
volunteer for the White Mountain Steward
Trail asso stewardship she was deeply
loved by her family and friends her
death has left a huge hole in our hearts
early in October of 2020 she started
dating a man who introduced to the
opioids she was not an opioid user
before meeting this man
um it turns out that the man was a drug
addict and a drug dealer and had already
been arrested twice for drug possession
including another case involving an
overdose in the early morning hours of
December 12th a daughter experienced an
OP opioid overdose and the drug dealer
boyfriend had been with her all evening
and there was no way that he didn't know
that she was overdosing she didn't have
to die if only he had called 911 and
sought help
in fact he was in her bedroom with her
the whole evening with her dead body for
several hours and he did
nothing in the morning when the
boyfriend heard A daughter's roommate
get up he um told him that something was
wrong with
her and they tried to do CPR but
realized she was still wasn't breathing
and her roommate went for
help uh in the meantime the boyfriend
ran away from the apartment and it
appears he did this before in the last
overdose he was involved in he ran
away so we believe that he was running
away out of fear of being arrested again
but so a person who is present for any
medical emergency has a duty to call for
help at the very least to not do so is
reckless and negligent inaction is the
opposite of acting in good faith
especially if the inaction results in
the death of The Afflicted
person if this man had sought help when
it was obvious that our daughter was in
trouble she might still be alive
today this could also help in other
medical emergencies in
accidents our daughter is irreplaceable
we cannot bring her back she will
forever be missed by those that love her
our lives will never be the same again
and she left a hole in her hearts that
can never be filled we can only hope
that the change in the law will be a
deterrent against
inaction so somebody else's loved one
might get the help that they need during
an overdose
crisis please remember that every victim
of an overdose is somebody's loved one
somebody's
child no one deserves to die
needlessly thank you for this
opportunity to provide my thoughts and I
sincerely hope that none of you have to
experience the agony of a similar
situation we respectfully ask you to
support this proposed amendment to House
Bill 603 thank you very much it's all
about saving lives
thank you Mr waters for your
testimony welcome thank you ra the
witness is
excused recognizes Cassandra
hello can everybody hear me
here thank you for allowing me to speak
today rep of HB 238 the lgbtq plus Panic
defense straty
stry is a legal strategy that asks the
jury to find a victim's sexual
orientation or gender identity SL
expression is to blame for a defendant's
violent reaction including murder it is
not a freestanding defense to criminal
liability but rather a legal tactic used
to bolster other defenses a m recent
defense of the use of this defense was
in
2015 Daniel Spencer was stabbed in
murdered by his neighbor Robert Miller
in
2015 Miller claimed that he rejected a
sexual advance from Spencer and acted in
self-defense when Spencer became
agitated but physical evidence disproved
his claim that he was never in danger
Miller's conviction was mitigated for
murder to criminally negligent
manslaughter I will leave you with the
following quote by honorable former US
Representative Joe Kennedy III from
Massachusetts who said
murdering or assaulting anyone because
of their sexual orientation or gender
identity is not a defense it is a hate
crime one would hope that as time
progresses we would have learned and
done better for the victims but we have
not and I hope that we joined the other
11 states and change this law thank you
and I will divert other questions to
others testifying
today thank you representative testimony
I
believe believe the representa does not
wish to answer any
questions representative
toll honorable members of the criminal
justice committee my name is Amanda
Elizabeth tol I represent Chesire 16
which encompasses the city of keen at
large I'm here today in support of HB
238 I think the vast majority of New
Hampshire constituents regardless of
political party support codifying lgbtq
plus rights into law and making New
Hampshire a welcoming State nearly every
New Hampshire constituent knows and
loves someone who is a member of the
lgbtq plus Community I cannot think of
another instance in which a victim's
identity can be used as a defense in a
crime and so this is a long time coming
our neighbors in Connecticut Rhode
Island and Maine have passed similar
legislation we want people in our state
to feel safe and we take pride in being
a state that values diversity this bill
would be a crucial step forward in
establishing legal safety for the lgbtq
plus community and I urge you to support
it I will be deferring questions thank
you for hearing my
testimony thank you representative for
your
testimony representative Max
abson thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you for taking my testimony I'm speaking
against House Bill
238 um not sure it'll take a full minute
um it the way it's written um doesn't
quite match the the testimony that
that's been given so far um it the bill
as written appears to violate Article 15
which is which states every subject
shall have a right to produce all proofs
that may be favorable to himself to meet
the witnesses against him face to face
and to be fully heard in his defense by
himself and counsel frequently if you're
charged with murder and you're um
introducing a lesser included offense of
manslaughter uh manslaughter is often
admitting to all the elements except
that you're saying um that you're you're
trying to
introduce uh the influence of extreme
mental or emotional disturbance caused
by extreme provocation
and you have the right you have a due
process right to introduce all evidence
and all eyewitness testimony in support
of that um this has nothing to do with
protecting lgbtq plus people who um do
deserve to be protected um an example
would be a woman who's being
continuously provoked by a man or woman
uh romantically or sexually over and
over again um possibly even being uh
touched where it doesn't rise to the
level of a defense
representative you're uh if you have to
limit testimony to one minute for
witness uh your time is
expired however you members are free to
ask questions of the
representative seeing No Hands raised
representative
is the chair recognizes representative
Ryan fer
just a reminder your testimony is
limited to one
minute if there's any members of the
public that are present who wish to
testify on either House Bill 603 or
House Bill 238 please raise your
hands Mr chair who was the last person
you
called that was representative Max
abson I'm sorry did you call somebody
else uh just now
orc represent Ryan uh
Fowler Ryan Fowler
um I am not
seeing is there a Ken Barnes
available I am not seeing a Ken Barnes
either Anthony
Harris Anthony Harris there isn't
Anthony
Harris hello thank you
chairman hello to everyone my name is
Anthony Harris I'm the co-founder of
felon the Freeman um I'm calling in
support of House Bill
238 um there was a time where I didn't I
didn't like Gates but I was young and
ignorant you know um and when I was 12
years old my mother took me on the porch
and she actually um she had me and my my
siblings on the porch and she said what
if I told y'all I was gay and she was
laughing about it and I said some words
that I regret to this day and I was like
Mom I'll dishone you and she fell out
the chair crying and balled up on the
porch and that was the day I found out
that my mother was gay and and we cried
with her and and I um I said to her uh a
couple days later I said you know what
Mom if a if a female makes you happier
than a male then it makes me happy and
the end you're my mommy and I'm going to
love you forever you know and then I
thought to myself I was 12 years old and
I said you know I can't say I hate gays
because I would never say I hate my mom
so it brought in my mind to it and I
actually start talking and open up to a
lot of them especially in college you
know and and I realized yo that people
just like us you know um they are who
they are and in the end we're all human
you know and when I found out that
there's a law that someone can just say
you know oh because this uh they're gay
and I I didn't know and this and they
did this they can just uh do whatever
they want or up to even kill me and get
away with in the in the in the in the
Court's eyes and I would I would never
uh want to see any harm done to my mom
because of the person she is and the way
the the the way she chooses to live her
life you know and um so I'm call I'm
calling in support of this
Bill thank you Mr Harris we do have to
limit testimony one minute for witness
uh due to the negligence of the chair
actually actually for two
minutes I just got to keep stay
consistent for members of the public I
apologize however members are free to
inquire questions of of the
witness seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank Mr Harris for for his
[Music]
testimony recognize
Sophia hi can you hear me yes I I didn't
get I didn't want to guess the last how
to pronounce the last name all right um
thank you everybody for taking my
testimony um my name is Sophia Bondo is
how it's pronounced um I'm 14 I live in
Manchester um I'm speaking today on
behalf of the New Hampshire High School
Democrats and as a member of the LGBT
community in support of HB
238 I support HB 238 because it would
prohibit the institutionalized
recognition of hate and LGBT alienation
in our state allowing the LGBT pan of
Defense to continue to be used divides
and stigmatizes the LGBT community and
says that we are something to be afraid
of
and that violent action against us
simply because of our identity is
justifiable it's estimated that almost
5% of our population in New Hampshire
more than 64,000 people is part of the
LGBT community this legislation would
help make New Hampshire a safe space for
those
64,000 New Hampshire should not be a
state where LGBT people have to fear for
our lives it should be a place where we
welcome diversity and understand the
value of every one of our citizens by
taking this step We join other states in
taking a stance on LGBT rights and
ensure that we do what's necessary to
protect our communities in order to
promote equality and sure that we as a
state do not recognize hate and to show
the rest of the country that we are
doing what is needed to protect LGBT
people in New Hampshire I urge the
committee to recommend opop pass on h238
and thank you for your
time thank you for your
testimony see no hands raised the
witness is excused
Jody
well hi um thank you for allowing me to
speak um I'm going to be speaking um in
opposition to HB 603 um and first I just
want to extend my sympathy to um Donna
and Mr Waters the parents of um people
they've lost your descriptions of your
kids remind me so much of my Corey and
I'm so sorry for your loss the night
before Corey passed I dropped him off at
the program he was attending to get well
later that night he recorded a van full
of folks singing Under the Bridge I
cherished that recording and I listened
to it over and over and over until the
phone finally died in my grief and
distress I wanted an explanation I
wanted resolution I wanted someone to
blame and it occurred to me that the
these were the voices of the last people
he was with before he came home I became
obsessed with finding out who gave him
the heroin and eventually I found that
but the thing is finding them didn't
give me the piece I thought it would
rather finding them gave me a face it
was the face of a person I didn't know
but a person all the same a human being
who struggled much in the way Corey did
meeting that person didn't make me want
to kill them or have them rot in jail or
uh for the rest of their lives instead
of wanting to continue blaming them to
report them to pursue some type of
Retribution all it made me feel was
empathy and sorrow I wanted to help them
and I wish we had some better system to
help them not a system that'd throw them
in jail um rather than helping them
rehabilitate in our quest to rid our
community of a drug we've ostracized
people we've vilified and maligned
members of our community we've taken our
community from them and I'm afraid we
could be moving in much the wrong
direction uh even more so this year this
bill would give life in prison to anyone
who sold or gave drugs to someone who
dies of any overdose I think if anyone
in New Hampshire would feel this is
Justified it would be someone like me
who's lost a loved one to uh overdose
but having been through that I learned
just the opposite I learned that
criminalization is not the answer it
only serves to peret perpetuate a
punitive mentality that assigns malice
to hurting people people Whose desire to
relieve pain man manifests in this
particular way so rather than double
down on this failed strategy I humbly
request that we seek out ways to support
them rather than uh throw them in you
thank
you thank you for your testimony seeing
No Hands raised the witness is excused
J
recognizes uh Dr Joe
Hannon uh good afternoon for members of
the committee thank you for hearing me
again my name is uh Joe Hannon and I am
speaking in opposition to House Bill
603 um we heard previous testimony and
other bills about uh how police and
other people in law enforcement would
like to see more
evidence-based um Treatment available
for people uh to help battle the uh drug
problem in the state but we never hear
anybody say we want
evidence-based um prosecution of
enforcement and and law more laws on the
books there is no evidence whatsoever to
support a law like this helping to
reduce overdoses deaths uh in any way
whatsoever if anything it can actually
deter people seeking life-saving
treatment because because of fear of
arrest we do have a law that allows for
uh Good Samaritan law to allow for
calling for help in an overdose but it
would not prevent someone from uh
calling in an instance like this they'd
be less likely to call for help and more
people will die uh another really bad
part of this uh is section c
specifically where it says uh directly
or indirectly related to the sale
transfer injection or
ingestion um you know that doesn't that
goes way further than the homicide
section where it has to do with the sale
the drug this has to do with anything
this could be giving someone a ride
there this could be someone involved in
a syin service program providing a clean
needle so someone doesn't get Hepatitis
or Aids and if they are giving someone
the means to safely inject they could
technically be indirectly related uh
liable for um their death and that is
ridiculous uh as far as the I I can talk
about defense of a person in the stand
your ground section if people have
questions do Dr Hannah we do have to
limit test to one minute and additional
NE you Clos to two minutes I apologize
um if we do have to suspend suspend your
testimony but members are free to ask
questions representative Marston you
recognized thank you Mr chairman and
thank you former representative Joe
Hanson uh I worked on that bill that you
just reference to about if somebody has
had a reaction to a drug and is in
trouble
and they call 911 no arrest can result
from that and I worked on that and got
that passed do you recall the RSA number
that that now
is yes I do it's uh
6268 uh if you look at section four uh
you know if an accomplice in conduct uh
I'm sorry oh no I'm I'm very sorry I
apologize that is um I'm sorry section
it's 318b
28b and uh if a person in good faith
calls the you know for medical
assistance for an overdose uh in a
timely manner doesn't have a 12-hour
requirement or anything like that it
says they shall not be arrested
prosecuted or convicted for possessing
or having under his or her control a
control drug and violation RSA 318 B2 if
the evidence for the charge was gained
an approximate result for the Quest for
medical assistance that doesn't mean
that someone can't be arrested for
outstanding warrants they can be
arrested for uh self-defense they could
be arrested for trying to defend
themselves say a drug dealer is asking
someone for you know forcing themselves
sexually they could be um found liable
they they could not be according to this
bill they wouldn't be allowed to defend
themselves against uh rape or another
deadly or but life serious bodily injury
because they were involved in the deal
this doesn't just pertain to drug
dealers this pertains to anybody
involved in using or injecting or in any
way this could be the driver who drove
you to the drug dealer's house um you're
not protected so it's a very dangerous
precedent for stand your ground and I
think it is uh it is there's two very
major issues with this bill that are
that are more than concerning and I
think uh I I do thank you for helping
with that other bill it has saved lives
in my mind I believe it has but we want
evidence-based practices and we have not
heard one bit of evidence that any of
these kind of laws help in any way
whatsoever and I've been listening all
afternoon I've not heard one
thing thank you representative Bourne
you
recognized thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my
question
um Jo do you know what happens if a
bartender sells a customer alcohol and
they go outside the bar and have a
accident on which they someone dies in
an accident is the bartender uh accused
of manslaughter uh as a general rule no
but they can be they can be charged or
sued uh if they were knowingly serving
someone who was excessively intoxicated
and they didn't prevent them from
getting into a vehicle I believe I don't
know the specifics of how that works but
I I know that it has happened I know of
a few bar owners that have been charged
or sued because of uh that but as a
general rule no unless there's something
you know they're if you're forcing a
beer down someone's throat and then
giving them their car keys obviously
it's a slam dunk but if you're just
serving a a beer and someone you don't
know they're inated that is generally
not what happens to
them thank you thank
you seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the witness for Testimony thank
you all have a good afternoon and I'll
just remind members of the public who
are in attendance uh if you are in
attendance please uh raise your hand
we'll call Joseph
Ebert good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Joe Ebert it's ebrt
I'm a captain with the New Hampshire
State Police I oversee our Investigative
Services Bureau I want to start by
saying um I I truly feel for the
families who've testified here today uh
and I have great respect for retired
detective Art Williams um I I do have
some questions uh within the bill and
representative B's uh previous question
gets to some of where uh my concerns
come in the uh the line within the bill
that speaks about or any conduct of
another I I wonder if uh the bill were
to uh proceed forward out of this
committee if the committee would
consider some type of guardrail uh
around what conduct could or could not
be attributed
uh to the sale of a drug um so that's
the the first thing uh the second as it
relates to um the homicide case that was
discussed although I don't know the the
details of that um I understand the
intent is
to is to take away a defense of a drug
dealer but as somebody who worked uh
homicides for a number of years what I
can tell you is that we have to
independently uh look at self-defense in
in many cases in which people put
themselves in those uh scenarios so I I
offer that to you that does not make um
the loss of the life that took place
there any any less and I don't want that
to come across that way but I I would
suggest to you that unfortunately um
that is that that is the rule of law we
look at self-defense uh uh regardless of
how a person became in in a given
situation U so having said those things
and and expressed my concern I'm more
than willing to answer any questions
from the
committee thank you uh thank you for
your your testimony seeing No Hands
raised the witness is
excused Ken
Barnes okay
bars
M chair recognizes Tristan mlan
move on to the next
witness hey wait wait wait sorry
technical
difficulty um my name is just mlan and
I'm speaking as a resident of Cl New
Hampshire and a member of the
public um there seems to be a disconnect
in the protections for to the lgbtqa
community and testimony voiced in
opposition of this bill I fail to see
how an instill fear of someone's sexual
orientation or identification has any
business in justifying assault murder of
any individual or group including the
LGBT community we preached that New
Hampshire is safe in a nonpartisan form
and this is just one of a number of
bills that is working to remedy past
transgressions and providing legislative
safety for every individual regardless
of characteristics my mother should not
have to worry about her son dying
because someone fears fiend fear what
would you do if this was your family
what if this protection was dressing
Christianity or Caucasian would you be
feeling
different that's all I have to
say thank thank you for your testimony
see seeing No Hands raised the witness
is
excused this time we were
w says the LGBT bar president but just
please identify your full name record
and whether you're testifying in support
or opposition
to yes thank you Mr chairman uh members
of the committee I am Wesley bazelle uh
my pronouns are he him and his uh I'm
privileged to serve as president of the
national LGBT Bar Association and and
I'm here to convey our strong support of
HB 238 uh this is an issue the LGB bar
has been working on for over a decade
some may wonder why this bill is
necessary today unfortunately panic
defenses are not a relic of the past
throughout the country judges allow the
defense to be raised prosecutors fail to
object and biased juries refuse to
impose a just punishment and murders
escape the punishment they deserve I'd
like to address a few questions that
have been raised by the committee uh
first in response to representative
testerman's question uh because there is
no systematic way of tracking criminal
cases we do not have a clear picture of
just how many times the defense has been
used across the country uh the FBI does
not even systematically track the
murders of lgbtq plus victims and trial
court proceedings in criminal matters
are rarely published uh what we do know
is that uh we have found hundreds of
cases uh throughout the
country mainly from a result of press um
accounts of them um we also uh would
note that there are no no due process
concerns regarding uh this bill this
bill does allow the um allowance of
evidence uh and several Scholars have
looked at uh whether there are due
process concerns raised and uh all have
resulted um that the Montana V Eagle
Hoff Supreme Court case uh is consistent
with the U Banning of the lgbtq panic
defense um finally I would just say uh
we urge these enactment of this
important legislation that will prevent
violent criminals from escaping the
punishment they deserve and will make
Equal justice under the law a living
breathing reality for victims of
violence thank
you representative B you're recognized
for a question thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question are you aware
that this uh uh Bill only pertains to
manslaughter should it not also uh
pertain to
homicide uh thank you representative um
so what this bill um does is that it
would
um you know would prevent the use of the
provocation defense
um as a as a um defense in in
manslaughter to bring down a defense in
the manslaughter cases uh is my
understanding of of how how the bill uh
is drafted
so to reduce a sentence of of Murder in
the second degree to
manslaughter I guess that's not how I'm
I'm reading it but uh that's what you
think is that's fine thank
you representative true thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
sir um so this bill would this bill
proposes that a particular line of
defense would not be allowed can you
give us some other
examples of lines of defense that and
other cases that aren
allowed sure happy to do that thank you
representative um so so this is not
saying that the the the defense is not
allowed what it is saying is that um the
use of a person sexual orientation or
gender identity as the reason for the
defense is not objectively reasonable um
there are a number of other cases um
where we see um this arise uh where we
either limit evidence um or say that a
um a defense is not permissible um for
instance intoxication uh generally is
not a defense and crime uh We've also
have rape shield laws uh that limit
testimony about a um rape victims uh
sexual history um and there are
other laws uh in other states that cabin
uh the use of defenses uh for instance
at least 15 states require a duty to
retreat uh in order for a self-defense
justification uh as well so so it is um
a number of other states have certainly
limited or cabined the defense uh
including in other heat of passion
defenses such as adultery uh where a
number of jurisdictions have eliminated
uh adultery as uh a reasonable
provocation uh for assault or
murder thank
you representative testman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I assume you're uh licensed to
practice in New Hampshire so I'll ask
you a question that that was the other
part of the question I asked before was
how many cases are there like this in
New Hampshire in the last 10 years sure
thank you representative I am not
licensed um to to practice uh in New
Hampshire um I I don't have that that
information in front of me I I you know
again point out that that we do um have
cases from across the country uh
recently uh in Virginia uh where we last
worked on this uh we found um eight or
nine cases uh there
um it requires a lot of digging because
there is no uh way to find these cases
other than through press accounts or
going to each of your uh Superior Courts
uh and and going through each of the
criminal proceedings um to determine
because these cases are not published uh
criminal cases uh at the tri court level
generally are not published uh and so
there's no comprehensive way to to
research
them thank you
representative Colley thank you Mr
chairman and thank you um sir for taking
the question do you provide in as
briefly as possible a rundown of the
strategy behind using this defense is it
to get the actor off you know have the
charges dismissed is it to instill doubt
how is this used uh by defendants across
the country
sure so we typically see this um in
three ways uh one of which here is
addressed um by the bill um so it it is
typically used in a um a claim of
self-defense uh or a claim of diminished
capacity or as uh the case this bill
addresses in the case of provocation um
uh factually how this typically happens
uh is that an
individual um discover s that uh someone
who um they are with uh makes a pass at
them uh and and in that moment discovers
that they are lgbtq plus uh and reacts
violently to that uh that is what we've
seen in cases the other uh type of case
that we primarily see this in is where a
uh man makes a pass at a transgender
woman uh and does not realize uh her
transgender status uh and when he does
uh reacts uh
violently in uh response to that as
well thank
you the chair would inquire of a
question and I want to thank you in
advance for taking my question uh is
there any specific case that you could
reference uh
for this committee to refer to where
this I look at this as more of a
mitigation defense well this mitigation
defense was actually successfully used
in a in a trial
setting yes it has been um successfully
used
um uh and you are correct that it is uh
typically a uh a mitigation defense um
there was a case in Texas um that uh a
murder that occurred in in 2015 I think
the the trial occurred in 201 18 uh
where a um the defendant uh stabbed and
and murdered uh his
neighbor uh claiming that he was
rejecting a sexual Advance uh and acted
in in
self-defense um despite the fact that
the physical evidence uh disproved uh
this claim uh this um defendants
conviction was mitigated uh from murder
to criminally negligent manslaughter
uh the other the other um most familiar
case that that people may have may know
of is where it was attempted to be used
but not used successfully uh was in the
murder of Matthew Shepard uh in
Wyoming thank you for taking my
question see no further hands raised I
want to thank the witness for his test
oh excuse me representative Conley thank
you this is more question the chair and
this is in line with your question
because I'm I'm
legitimately hoping to get better
understand it does one in New Hampshire
need to demonstrate uh that the defense
that they're that they're using is
Justified like can I just make up any
excuse I want um including one like this
one in hopes that it might get me a
reduced sentence or R
charge well is that for me the witness
well I guess so the witness
I try to tackle that
first thank you representative um so
what what I would say is that um the
reason that the defense is necessary is
is based on um digma and Prejudice uh
that uh judges and juries uh continue to
have um so you know certainly in in
other ways a defendant can raise a a um
theory of provocation
uh based on on whatever they like um
that the person was wearing you know the
color red and and that uh created a um
violent reaction in them um and it's up
for the try or fact in this case the
jury to determine whether that's
reasonable or not um the problem here is
that even with the advances that we've
seen uh with lgbtq equality um this the
type of evidence that's being uh
presented uh sways the emotions of the
juries and feeds on their pre-existing
biases um to um allow the defense to be
successful I the chair would just
inquire of a question you gave me a name
of of some
defend out of Wyoming was Matthew was
the first was what was the last name of
that person uh Matthew
Shepard um his his mother Judy Shepard
uh has has testified and supported this
bill in various places uh the uh Matthew
Shepard James Bird hate crimes uh bill
at the federal level is named after
after Matthew's
death represent
Newman yeah I just thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question I I
just have a quick question my
understanding of the of the bill as it's
written
um is does the the section the new
section four is that used as mitigation
or prevent the
mitigation of a murder charge because
they they were in that state of of U
being
upset is that what it
does uh representative that is my
understanding yes thank you
seeing No Hands raised I want to thank
the witness for his testimony thank you
committee and
chairman
hello my name is Asal honei and I'm
going to be speaking um for two bills
I'll make this quick I'm speaking in
opposition of HB 603 because we can't
punish our way out of drug use uh I
sympathize with the mother that spoke
about her son Mike and my heart breaks
for her just as it breaks for the wife
and mother who just spoke also who lost
her husband but clearly one doesn't
understand that punishment would not
have stopped her son's death while the
other had to go on a journey of
realizing punishment isn't going to end
drug use or the sale of drugs uh the
mother who spoke about her son Mike it's
very sad and unfortunate death um just
fails to realize that her son if he
lived he would have been arrested by the
same laws that she's promoting and yet
is asking exact that to happen of other
sons and and daughters so I also I'm
speaking in support of h238 because it
gives people more protections to ensure
that people who are trans and nonbinary
in our state are not targeted by people
and are not just getting off the hook by
by uh the provocation defense that could
possibly be used it doesn't matter how
many cases that's been used in New
Hampshire it's the fact that it can be
used and we need to send a strong
message in our state that we will not
tolerate that and that trans nonbinary
lgbtqia plus everyone will be included
in our uh State and we'll make sure that
we protect everyone thank
you thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is excused is there any members
of the public who are in attendance that
have not testified already that wish to
testify uh in regards to HP
for 6
603 seeing now hands raised we can we
now close the public Hearing in House
Bill 238 and House Bill
603 on those uh on those two bills uh on
House Bill 23
we had
308 uh 311 people signing in in support
we had 18 people signing in in
opposition and on House Bill
603 we had 16 people signing in in
support and 15 in
opposition thank you
[Music]
criminal justice Public Safety Committee
will be in recess to
445 Carl um m m
chair yes we can hear okay um are we
gonna exact anything
that's the goal I I just want to which
ones excuse me which
one well these two I would say all of
them
I if we can I think
um we'll we'll discuss one of them that
may may require a lot of work the
deadline coming up next week iite the
importance of the bill I feel that
we would never make that deadline to
adjust
so but we will
uh we'll be in recess to
445 e
hey guys can you hear
me John
d uh laa yes okay you you guys want to
join the bridge again sure open so the
same bridge that we joined before okay
Linda what did you want to
do
e
e e
allor right
BR can you hear
us he us I haven't heard that they hear
us his
up I heard
something representative
you guys want to tell representative
Conley I think they're still on the if
you guys are still having a caucus we
will know that a couple minutes you
still having a caucus with your guys
yeah we're wrapping up I think
everyone's coming back to the thing you
guys V
everything in that case I'll be right
back team player
that was
[Music]
good I need come to the right side
sooner or
later we going to
[Music]
you know what the horrible thing is I
looked up on Google make sure I was
pronouncing pedicure right I didn't want
to get that
wrong so now I go on Facebook gu how
many
freaking
gosh right I know
that's hello everyone
only
you at this time we we are opening the
executive session of House
Bill 526
can everyone hear us
home yes
sorry the chair recognizes D David well
to make a
motion make a motion we retain house go
526 is there second second has been
seconded by representative Hopper
wish to speak on the
motion no
we chairman I open the question up for
discussion seeing No Hands raised the
matter we put the question the question
uphold the RO if you're in favor the
motion retain please say yay if you're
opposed please say
next chairman Welch
hi representative Mooney
yes representative Hopper yes ma'am
representative
green representative W yes
representative testman yes
representative TR yes representative PR
yes representative Marson yes CL vote
Yes representative Harry G no
Representative
panus
no representative
o'n representative
W I have a question please what Bill are
we dealing
with
526 correct yes
CID uh
yes was that a yes vote
Yes representative Ms
no representative Newman
no Representative
bden
no representative Conley
yes representative C
night
no I mean yes sorry
I mean no just go with no please thank
you representative vote
no representative Bradley
no
chairman the chair votes
yes chairman the vote is 12
yay by a vote of 12 Ys and 7 a the
motion to retain is
passed at this time uh we will close the
executive session on House Bill
526 uh we now open the executive session
house still 511 all TI the penalties for
possession of certain control of
drugs representative chesman recn make I
make a motion we retain
[Music]
this that has not been
seconded that's what I had my hand up D
second the motion to
retain didn't that what they wanted to
do Mr chair could you restate the motion
that's on the floor I I withdraw my
motion to
retain so you make it somebody can else
can make another motion I would draw my
second thank you represent you wish to
be recognized to make a
motion repres hasn't had it represent TR
you wish to be recognized to make a
motion yes Mr chair Mr Mr chair I move
House Bill 511 inexpedient to legislate
second it second by representative
Wallace representative TR you wish to
speak to your motion of
in there was a there was a lot of talk
about uh people needing help uh and not
not throwing in in jail because they
have a a drug problem
but the
amount of illegal drugs being
discussed not only shows me that the
person would be selling those drugs but
according to the bill did be allowed to
sell them up to four times of being
caught um this is to me this is about a
bill authorizing the sale and that is
why I cannot support it and I moved to
itl now question up
discussion thank you very much Mr chair
as I read this bill it does not address
people who are actually selling drugs
this bill impacts people who are
basically caught in possession of drugs
um and I think one of the things that we
heard was some pretty compelling
testimony around the fact that um
different different people react in
different ways to different doses um and
absent the evidence that somebody is
actually trying to sell the drugs uh to
me it just seems to be um almost cruel G
given the way that the opioid situation
has hit our state and the way that so
many people have just fallen into this
trap sometimes almost through no you
know
no you know no fault of their own
they've just uh run with the wrong
people they've gone with the wrong crowd
or whatever to
me it
seems unnecessary uh and cruel to to
keep our possession laws the way that
they are um I think it's time that we
try to different approach um the
approach that we have tried for years
and years and years uh we just hear one
person after another coming up saying um
it's not
effective um so I say if you're selling
if you're selling drugs you should get
prosecuted to the full extent of the law
but if you're caught with them I think
that's a different situation and I think
we need to as a as a body look at that
situation with a lot more compassion
especially given what the state has gone
through over the last five or six years
with the opioid crisis this is a crisis
that has touched so many families um in
such a difficult and painful way um and
and I think this bill would actually go
at least part of the way of of trying to
put some of that behind us without um
relieving penalties for people who are
actually engaged in the sale of
Narcotics
representative thank you Mr chair um I
really would like rather see us retain
this bill rather than uh really
inexpedient to
legislate uh we have just and then house
just passed HB 615 which did reduce
penalties for drug cases but we don't
know what it will happen to it in the
other body and what will happen to it
when this it reaches the governor's desk
if if it does re does not become law
then we are to keep this for us to uh
make changes what we need to uh drug
penalties so I'm going to vote against
the itl motion and hope for a another
motion to
retain thank
you representative rhs thank you Mr
chairman so um a couple of things
representative us made a
statement you know that you know you if
a person is doing the drugs or person is
selling the drugs about two different
penalties you you can't sell them if you
don't have them and now we're we're
getting into a territory of trying to
decide what the person's intent was and
representative true made a good point of
just how deadly a very small amount of
some of these Jaws is and the other
thing that I think we have to we have to
take into consideration here is
that everybody's tolerance level is
different based on their usage and the
long the more we keep on raising the bar
of how much you're allowed to have the
more the bar will be raised on how much
people continue to push it so right now
they know if oh you know the legal limit
is this they're going to keep it right
at or under that and then whenever we
raise it they're going to they're just
going to keep on raising it to to what
point to what point is it not their
fault pretty
good
thank representative hoer thank you Mr
chairman
um I know quite a bit about
addiction and I will tell you
that if somebody in this room was caught
with a
revolver playing Russian roulette
somebody was sitting at this table right
now playing Russian roulette they would
be taken and brought to the conquered
mental hospital for evaluation and maybe
stay there for a month or two everybody
that sticks a needle in their arm is
playing Russian Roulette they have zero
control over their lives anymore the the
drug is making their decisions for them
I know I heard testimony the testimony
is not correct somebody who's on
fentanyl or heroin is no longer in any
way remotely in control of their
faculties and should be put in treatment
they should be taken to the state
hospital put in there for evaluation and
stay there until they're
level and see if they will actually
respond to getting help because they're
going to die the idea of raising the the
uh the the thing to four grams give need
a break 500 a gr will kill 500 people
you going raise it to four that that's
insane I'm I'm vo ined to legisl we're
doing this all wrong we're doing we're
we're this there's this is not the right
way to deal with this problem but given
people a free ride and letting them get
out of jail free for a few times only is
enabling them to dig themselves deeper
into the
hole thank
you welcome I think there's a lot to
unpack here I think what a represented
of Hopper said some of it was I agree
with is that if people are misusing
something and self Haring they deserve
to get treatment and what we're doing as
a state now is making it worse we are
not giving them treatment we're
condemning them we're putting them in
confinement on our people's dime and
then they become get it back out they're
homeless so it's contributing the
situation because they didn't get the
resources that they needed and then we
arrest them again and then our people
are paying for it again and it's this
cycle right so um how do we help our
people get the help that they deserve
and need and how do we limit wasting our
people's money for paying to have these
people incarcerated when all they're
doing is self Haring and with all due
respect I think a lot of us don't know
how drugs work because we're not drug
abusers and I think that there's a lot
of misinformation in this committee
right now where people think they
understand how much much something does
and where it causes and what what harm
it causes but then I think there's a
complete lack of Education really
understanding what these drugs do and
what they're used for you know
regardless of we're talking about we're
trying to make the distinction between
people starting a business and people
that are self Haring and this bill
clearly states that difference and we
need to have compassion if we're going
to help these people get over treatment
and we we don't have that and we need to
work in the right direction to give them
a chance to access that care and I think
this build is the right step in that
direction to get that care instead of
condemning the people that are suffering
from illness and that we end up paying
for over and over and over
again represent your hand was
raised no I don't I don't have anything
to
say see no further hands raised
uh matter we put the question the court
can up call the role if you are in
support of the motion spe to legislate
please say yay if you oppos please
stand Thane chairman Welch I
representative Mooney yes representative
Hopper yes representative
green he's not here representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
Pratt yes representative Maron
yay CLK votes yes representative Harry
G yes
representative
pakus
yes representative
o'n representative bon
no representative muse
no representative Newman
no Representative
bden
no representative Conley
no representative p
no representative Bradley no chairman
the chair votes yes Mr chairman the vote
is 12 to seven a vote of 12 Days Seven
Days
pass be Minority Report
[Music]
repr true will you be doing the yes
report this time we will close the
executive
session
on house
511 this time we will now open the
executive session on House Bill
603 recognizes David EXC representative
wel to make a
[Music]
motion move that we retain house
603 represent Mars you recognize I will
second the
motion represent wish to speak on on
your
motion and I would just say that uh in
respect to the members of the public and
the bill
sponsor there's a lot of uh very
important issues that were raised by
testimony today a lot of things to put
into consideration the bill has deadline
of Mark 11 uh if we attempted to we
don't have the ability to meet in
subcomittees so if we were to attempt to
work on this
bill I would be I'm confident we would
not be doing the Justice or respected
that the issues deserved so I would
be I would be supporting the motion to
retain and hope as a committee we can
work together on this and try to address
all these concerns raised by test
question Mr chair
no just a
question when you retain a bill does the
amendment go with it the amendment
technically well no but yes I mean it's
not like the amend we keep the amendment
for our own knowledge
because yeah we still have it it's not
the amendment hasn't been adopted but I
would why I asked the
question okay thank you
that Bo thank you Mr chairman um I don't
understand why we are retaining this
field it clearly is uh um a stand your
ground uh and it uh should be
ited um retain retaining will not do
anything for us
any any anyone anyone else wish to speak
on motion to
retain seeing No Hands raised the matter
we put the question for now call the
rooll if you are in support of the
motion to rain please say yay you oppose
please say
no Vice chairman Welch
yes representative Mooney yes
representative Hopper
yes representative
green representative Wallace yes
representative testerman
yes representative true y representative
Pratt yes representative Marston yay the
clerk votes yes representative har G
no Representative
pantelakis
no representative o'n
Representative
bord no representative muse
no representative Newman
no represent
golden
no representative Conley
yes representative kin Knight
yes representative Bradley
no chairman
votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is 12 y
7 I voted 12 Y and
S
the pass this time we
will close the executive session House
Bill
603 at this time we now open the
executive session on house fill 238
recognized I make a motion to we
IDE Mar you wish be
recognize second the motion next to
legisl
[Music]
yes speak
I think this the case where we
have trying to come up with another
reason for a jury and I I think the
jury's smart enough to to take a case
like this and proceed with it correctly
without
telling
open question for
discussion representative Knight
yes I I think we have a duty to the
state of New Hampshire to protect all
people including those that um are
different amongst us and clearly there
is something wrong in our law that
basically allows somebody to commit
murder when they feel like they've had a
pass made at them and that is just
unacceptable um if you're gonna vote to
kill this you're sending a clear message
to the people of New Hampshire that you
don't support protecting lgbtq Plus
members thank you night we not we're not
supposed to speak to the intent of the
of the
members uh including anything implied in
their vote uh and this also will not
legally justify any type of lawful
killing it's simply a bill that involves
the
mitigation of someone who's charged with
second degree murder and simultaneous
man water they will not be they're not
going to be convicted both simply a
mitigation a mitigation
defense to second degree murder no one's
getting away with killing
someone so just to clarify that I don't
believe anyone in this committee would
support someone getting away with
killing people simply Bas on their
sexuality thank you Mr chairman I think
that you and the attorney are have
misread this bill this is not a bill
that
allows
uh you to uh go from murder to Def to
manslaughter this is only to exclude a
uh defense against
manslaughter
um I myself think that it's a good deal
and I would like to uh uh pass it
so I'll explain representative B I just
and I'll just admit I've never worked on
on a murder case in my professional
career but I will but I am my
understanding is quite often when
someone's charged with manslaughter that
when it involve violence it's often
second Dee murder is often charged as
well where you wouldn't have a
conviction of
both but you could have conviction one
but not the
other with this would do if and
basically the facts that described in
the testimony you wouldn't be able to
claim this as a reason what that caused
you to lose control to no longer be
obje be objectively reasonable or and
made you lose your pool and that's why
you lost all control of yourself you're
not going to claim that as a
reason to mitigate second Remer to man
that's but this doesn't need to
mentioned second murder doesn't need to
address that that's a different that's
RSA will be not impacted at all so
I this is not a flat out defense toand
and I'll recognize representative board
a to respond to what I just said even
though not there other members hands on
I hope no one raises a point Thank you
Mr chair um maybe I'm misreading the uh
the rsas but um
630 2 is devoted only to manslaughter it
has nothing to do with homicide and this
is where this paragraph is being
inserted it is being inserted as this is
not a defense for uh man
water I'll read it again but
I I just I respectfully disagree but
representative time to do it you can
talk to me sometime when we have more
time on our
hands thank you Mr chairman I would like
to see this bill passed with it such an
animosity out there nowadays we haven't
had it happen in our state but it could
I remember years ago
when elg was out that they
would beat a man half to death because
they found out he
might be gay so I don't think it hurts
anything to put this on the books it
hasn't happened and maybe it never will
but at least we're protecting them thank
you represent
Muse Mr chairman um we heard that
intoxication and adult
aren't acceptable defenses and and I
think a pretty good case was made today
that a person's identity um should also
not be grounds uh for them to be
victimized in this way um I think one of
the things you know I've been kind of
looking for an analogy and I think this
situation is very much analogous to a
lynching defense that would center
around a person being triggered by
seeing black people and in many parts of
the country that was an acceptable
defense until not too many years ago I I
I think I think that passing a bill like
this um is part of the process that we
need to make as Society um
to essentially get to a point where all
of our people have equal protection
under the law uh and really do have
equal protection under the law um I I've
yet to see a bill come across uh uh come
across our desks uh this term um that
that isn't more about that than than
this particular Bill uh so I'm going to
oppose the itl
motion iire a
question you said
that man excuse me that adultery would
not be um grounded as a mitiga defense
to claim that you can't be objectively
reasonable is that in New Hampshire law
so I didn't I'm just wondering I
didn't weird testimony from the uh the
person from the lgbtq btq bar um that uh
that was the case I'm not 100% sure if
that that's the case in New Hampshire uh
but it sounded like that case in some
other
states um and if if it is pretty and
it's not the law in New Hampshire we
should join those States as
well representative
Bradley thank you um I really feel like
this is a good bill and that we should
be we should be trying to pass it it it
just I agree with representative Klein
night that if if we itl this bill it
just sends a clear message to the people
of New Hampshire and it's
it's awful so I I will oppose the
itl representative Conley thank you Mr
chairman we heard testimony today that
this Panic defense let people
concoct a defense that may or may not be
based in
reality and depending on the jury that
they draw and the prejudices those
jurors
have um
about
LG btq plus people to then potentially
allow for reduced
sence um this is a type of defense that
is unique in our statute one sexual
orientation should not be used uh the
victim sexual orientation should not be
used as a mitiga offense um we we heard
testimony that a number of states have
done this red States blue
States it's good practice and we should
represent
Newman thank you Mr chair and I also
believe this is a good bill and I I I
believe that from the testimony we heard
today that this te that the um this
mitigation effort because of the sexual
orientation of the victim it can
objectively not be used when someone
could potentially be uh convicted of
murder or second deegree murder so
that's my take on the bill for my two
cents thank
you guys thank you Mr chairman I
seconded the
itl and my reasoning for doing that is
couple a couple of reasons one of them
to start with is our constitution
already covers everybody
and we're not are we looking to carve
out and if we're going to carve out one
group of people
today then tomorrow somebody's going to
want to carve out the Liberals for
attacking the
conservatives there yeah we just we
don't need to use that type of R we just
try to may I continue then you may
continue but referring to people as
liberals conservative that does not
provide any productive thought to okay
we're all members in that's fine well we
refer to people as gay or lbgs and so on
and so forth and we want to C them out
and say they got special privileges our
constitution of New Hampshire as I
understand it covers everybody to begin
with and we only a number of years ago
amended our constitution about
discrimination towards some
and we don't we don't want to do that
but I'm just saying we don't want to
have special privileges for special
people we're all the same group we're
all the same people if you kill somebody
you should be charged for murder and
then you should be tried on it and
there's no way in heck that you're going
to be able to say well because he or she
was some deviant sexuality that I'm not
Senator
Maron we none of a no member is able to
speak of someone's deviant
sexual what is
LBG
D we're
gonna close the executive
[Music]
session commit
now for